EDUCATION AS I INDICATED WE'RE
GOING TO START [inaudible]
WITH THE VERY IS SOME MEMBER
REQUESTS ACTUALLY VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS IT'S ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS FIRST SO FIRST TO CENTER
PAN IF YOU'LL COME UP.
IT IS THAT YOU LIMóN TO TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU CAN USE.
THE MATTERS ARE FULLY DESCRIBED
IN THE AGENDA BUT WE DO NEED TO
GET THEM IN THE RECORD AND THEN
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT BY THE WAY
WE WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS TO ALL ITEMS -- AT THE END OF
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE SESSION TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO CHAIR YOU WERE YOU WERE HERE
ON ITEM ONE Q. AND ONE FIFTY
CORRECT YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I'M HERE A A VICE CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ON ONE OF OUR CAUCUSES
BUDGET PRIORITIES TO REQUEST AN
ONGOING REINVESTMENT IN THE
COLLEGE READY IN THIS BLOCK
GRANT.
I CO AUTHORED SB TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH SENATE THEN
SENATE PRO TEM EMERITUS.
KEVIN DE LEóN TO ESTABLISH THIS
BLOCK GRANT AND WAS LATER
INCORPORATED INTO THE SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
BUDGET.
THE CALIFORNIA READY THIS BLOCK
GRANT PROVIDES A ONE TIME
PROVIDED A ONE TIME ALLOCATION
OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS TO CATER TWELVE
DISTRICTS FOR COLLEGE READINESS
AND COMPETITIVE.
COMPETITIVENESS ACTIVITIES BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF AND DUPLICATED
PUPILS AND ROLLED UNDER THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
AND TWENTY MILLION FOR THE UC'S
TO PARTICIPATE IN OUTREACH
ENROLLMENT RETENTION EFFORTS.
FOR LOW INCOME AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS FROM LCF PLUS HIGH
SCHOOLS.
LCF PLUS HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
SCHOOLS WITHIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH JUNE POPULATIONS OF 75% OR
MORE A DUPLICATE PUPILS WERE
NOTIFIED AS EITHER ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
LOW INCOME ARE FOSTER USE THIS
BUDGET REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITION OF TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
SLOTS AT THE UC EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR NEEDIEST
STUDENTS.
THE C. R. V. G. MOST SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S LCF
BUS SCHOOL DISTRICTS GENERATING
INCREASED APPLICATIONS AND
MISSIONS ENROLLMENTS AND YOU SEE.
THE ORIGINAL BUDGET ALLOCATION
SUNSETS THIS YEAR SO THIS BUDGET
REQUEST IS ASKING FOR
REINVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TOWARD.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LCF BUS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TWENTY MILLION
TO THE UC'S AND AN ON ON AN
ONGOING ANNUAL BASIS WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL SLOTS.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HAS
PRIORITIZE THIS BUDGET REQUEST
BECAUSE THIS INVESTMENTS
ADDRESSES IN EQUITIES THAT WE
SEE IN HIGHER EDUCATION WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
FOSTER YOUTH AN UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY STUDENTS
INCLUDING BLACK LATINO AND
SOUTHEAST ASIAN STUDENTS AND AS
WE CONSIDER INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR NEEDY
STUDENTS WE SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT.
ONE THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO WORK
DESPITE DECLINING EMISSIONS TO
THE UC FROM CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
IN GENERAL THE LCF PLUS STUDENTS
HAVE MAINTAINED THE SAME RATE OF
ADMISSIONS IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS THANKS TO INVESTMENTS LIKE
THIS BLOCK GRANT.
WITHOUT A REINVESTMENT THE OUR
REGION RETENTION PROGRAMS ON UC
CAMPUSES IN THE CRITICAL
PIPELINE COUNSELING AND SERVICES
IN OUR LCF PLUS HIGH SCHOOLS
WILL CEASE OPERATION.
SO THE ON BEHALF OF THE L. A. P.
I. LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS -- I URGE
THE SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION TO CONSIDER THIS
PROPOSAL AND TO REINVEST IN THE
CADRE THIS BLOCK GRANT WHICH OF
COURSE ORIGINATED IN THIS VERY
HOUSE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
EXPAND NEXT ITEM IS ONE E.
HEALTHY START.
NO I DO HAVE THIS.
OKAY THEN I'LL PRESENT HEALTHY
START FOR YOU ARE [inaudible]
SENATOR ALSO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DRUGS ARE YOU ARE PRESENTING ON
ITEMS MY RECORD REFLECTS ONE G..
TWO A AND TWO J. [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I'M
HERE TO THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON THREE
OF BUDGET REQUEST THAT OUR
PRIORITIES FOR THE LAST THE
DAHLE CAUCUS AND I'M YEARS OF
VICE CHAIR.
OF THE FIRST OF BUDGET REQUEST
OUR IS FUNDING FOR THE LATINO
POLITICS INITIATIVE AT THE UCLA.
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS THIS
PROGRAM HAS ALREADY
DISTINGUISHED DISTINGUISHED
ITSELF TO ITS RESEARCH POLICY
AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
THE CAUCUS IS REQUESTING TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT.
OF THE INITIATIVES OPERATING
BUDGET.
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL
ALLOW FOR THE HIGHER OF SUPPORT
STAFF.
OF TO HELP MANAGE THE RESEARCH
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS.
AND ALLOW FOR A WIDER
DISSEMINATION OF DATA POLICY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ON THAT REQUEST AND FOR THE
RECORD THAT'S ITEM TO A NEXT.
OKAY OF THE SECOND OF ITEM I
HAVE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION IS A
REQUEST TO EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE.
BY THE SECOND YEAR FREE TUITION
FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE POLICY PROPOSAL IS CONTAINED
IN A.. TWO BY ASSEMBLYMAN
SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE REQUIRES A TOTAL OF
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. TO BRING
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS ACROSS OUR STATE.
OF A YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM SERVES TWO
MILLION STUDENTS AT A HUNDRED
FIFTEEN COLLEGES AND IT VERY
VERY DIVERSE.
UP PROVIDING THE STUDENTS WITH
THE SECOND YEAR OF FREE TUITION
WILL PROVIDE.
A WILL PROVE A HUGE RELIEF FOR
THOUSANDS OF THOSE STUDENTS
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET --
AND THIRD -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
OF THE LIKE THE CAUGHT THIS IS
US SUPPORTING CONCERNS.
FUNDING FOR THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION THE SAFETY PROGRAM
ALSO KNOWN AS A S. P. S..
A RECENT SHOWS OF COURSE THAT
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS PROVIDE A
VARIETY OF BENEFITS TO STUDENTS.
INCLUDING IMPROVE SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE AND ENGLISH FLUENCY
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SKILL
DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE REQUESTING A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE MILLION FROM THE GENERAL.
FUND.
IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN OF FOR THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WELL THE
COSTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF A
SCS PROGRAMS HAVE.
CONSISTENTLY INCREASED.
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT IN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE NOT QUE
KEPT PACE FOR OVER A DECADE.
OUT WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE FORCED
TO CUT SERVICES FOR STUDENTS.
AND SOME WILL EVEN SHUT DOWN.
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
OF THESE PIORITY BUDGET REQUEST --
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SEN DRUGS SO YOU GET THE OF
GOLD STAR FOR BREVITY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
BEFORE I GAVE UP THANK YOU HAVE
THIS ORDER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
OTHERWISE.
THAT'S A CHALLENGE I'M NOT SURE
THE SOUL LAWYER CAN MATCH. FOR
BREVITY BUT I HAVE TO REQUEST.
ONE IS A MODEL SCHOOL LIBRARY
STANDARDS FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN UPDATED
SINCE SINCE.
TWENTY TEN AND AS WE KNOW WE ARE
SEEING A RAPIDLY EVOLVING
LANDSCAPE -- WE NEED THE THIS
THESE.
IMPROVEMENTS TO PREPARE STUDENTS
FOR THE FUTURE INFORMATION
ECONOMY PART OF THIS DEALS WITH
ME MEDIA LITERACY THE ABILITY TO
THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT.
THE SOURCES OF INFORMATION THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING. TO
DEAL WITH QUESTIONS OF FALSE
NEWS FAKE NEWS -- THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP IN
CYBER BULLYING WHICH WE KNOW IS
HAVING A VERY SERIOUS IMPACT ON
OUR USED TODAY.
SO THAT IS A TWO HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLAR ASK.
THE SECOND ASK.
IS THE TRIAL CARE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FUNDING.
INEQUITIES THE WORKING FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS FACES EVIDENT IN
OUR STATE'S EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SYSTEM WERE NEARLY 60%
OF THE STATE'S CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE RELIES ON GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO GET BY.
AND A WORKING SINGLE MOTHER IS
PAYING NEARLY 70% OF HER INCOME
ONE CHILD CARE.
THIS IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
IT'S NOT RIGHT AND I KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER.
SO THE RIGHT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS ALSO A MUST
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE ARE NO
MORE VOICES.
OTHER NO VOICES MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
CHILD CARE NEEDS THAN.
THE PRIMARILY WOMEN WHO CARE FOR
AN EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN AND WHO
FUEL OUR ECONOMY BY MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR MOMS AND DADS. TO
REPORT TO WORK SO I'M ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO JOIN ELEVEN OTHER
STATES.
IN EMPOWERING CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO FORM A
UNION AND HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE TO EFFECTIVELY ADVOCATE.
FOR THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THEY CARE FOR IN SUPPORT
INCLUDING THEIR OWN SO THE
SPECIFICALLY IS A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR ASKING FUNDING TO ENSURE
WE HAVE.
ADEQUATE STAFFING AND NEEDED
TECHNOLOGY ASSISTANCE OF DSS CD
E. AND HER.
THESE DOLLARS WOULD BE DEDICATED
TOWARD COMPILING A LIST OF
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WOULD MINISTER SAID STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE A BIG
PROBLEM PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHERE
TO GO.
SHOCKINGLY THE STATE CURRENTLY
DOESN'T COLLECT THIS INFORMATION
WHICH IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT TO
ENSURING THAT WE ARE BUILDING
THE STRONGEST.
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
POSSIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS FUNDING WOULD
REQUIRE THAT PURRS A BOARD TO
OVERSEE AND CERTIFY A UNION
ELECTION FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THIS YEAR.
AND IN SUPPORTING THIS ASK WE
CAN BEGIN TO BUILD THE
FOUNDATION FOR A CHILD CARE
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS OUR
EDUCATORS.
RECOGNIZING THEM AS THE
PROFESSIONALS THEY ARE AND HELP
CHILDREN THRIVE FOR DECADES TO
COME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
EXCELLENT JOB FOR THE RECORD
THOSE THAT WAS ITEM NUMBER ONE
P. AND ITEM ONE HIM CORRECT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR GLAZER.
YOU ARE PRESENTING ON ITEM TWO
T..
TANGO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I AM HERE TO URGE YOU TO
PROVIDE FULL FUNDING FOR THE CS
USE GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
I AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO BRING
THE SYSTEMS MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS.
CLOSER TO NATIONAL STANDARDS FOR
THE NUMBER OF COUNTS. TO STUDENT
RATIO.
THESE ARE TWO CRITICAL ISSUES TO
STUDENT SUCCESS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE CSU LAUNCH
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO INCREASE
FOREIGN SIX YOUR GRADUATION
RATES TO FORTY AND 70%
RESPECTIVELY.
THE CSU HAS IMPROVED GRADUATION
RATES FOR BOTH FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER STUDENTS.
BUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NECESSARY FOR THIS TRAJECTORY TO
CONTINUE.
AND TO PROVIDE CAMPUSES WITH THE
RESOURCES TO IT TO ELIMINATE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
CSU SYSTEM. FOR YOUR GRADUATION
RATE INCREASE FROM 19% 225%.
I AND SIX YOUR GRADUATION RATES
OF IMPROVED FROM 57% 261% THESE
ARE MEASURABLE IMPROVEMENTS AND
DOES THE FACULTY.
ADMINISTRATION CAMPUS LEADERSHIP
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE.
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS HAVE NARROWED.
FOR RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS --
BUT ONLY NARROWLY.
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO TO BE
DONE THERE.
AND STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING WITH
FEWER ACCESS UNITS.
OVERALL THE SYSTEM HAS SHOWN
IMPROVEMENTS.
IN A NUMBER OF AREAS RELATED TO
STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS -- BUT WE HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO.
THE CSU REQUESTED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
JANUARY AT LEAST ONLY.
PROVIDED FORTY FIVE MILLION.
IN ADDITIONAL MILLION THIRTY
MILLION THAT THEY'VE ASKED FOR
IS DESERVING.
I WOULD MEAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
MORE COURSE SECTIONS ENHANCED
ADVISING AND IT.
VAST ACADEMIC SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
SO I HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER THAT.
I IN THE AREA OF MENTAL HEALTH.
I'M HERE TO REQUEST AN ONGOING
ALLOCATION OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
NUMBER STUDENTS SEEKING HELP FOR
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
GUY ROCKET OVER THE LAST DECADE.
SYSTEM WIDE THE NUMBER STUDENTS
SEEKING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ON CAMPUS INCREASED ABOUT 15% IN
JUST THE PAST TWO YEARS.
ALL ENROLLMENT WAS UP LESS THAN
1%.
ADDITIONALLY WAIT TIME AT
COUNSELING CENTERS CONTINUE TO
BE AN ISSUE FOR STUDENTS.
THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR AN
APPOINTMENT EVEN IN CRISIS
SITUATIONS IN MANY CAMPUSES.
THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME SYSTEM
WIDE IS BETWEEN TWO AND FOUR
WEEKS THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU'RE UNDER STRESS.
TRYING TO COMPLETE YOUR STUDIES
AND IT COULD BE ACADEMIC STRESS
IT COULD BE PERSONAL STRESS.
NINE WHEN YOU CALL THE
COUNSELING OFFICE THEY SAY WE
CAN SEE YOU AND AND A COUPLE
WEEKS IT'S JUST NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE SITUATION.
I IN JANUARY THE GOVERNOR
PROVIDED YOU SEE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
BUT WE SHOULD DO THE SAME FOR
THE CSU AND PROVIDE THAT
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
FOR WORK.
WITH THAT -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
CONSIDERING THESE TWO IMPORTANT
CLASS.
THERE IN FORT INVESTMENTS OF IN
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR STATE.
TUITION INITIATIVE AND FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE [inaudible]
HERB JOBSON [inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
YOU ARE PRESENTING ON ITEM TWO
L..
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS.
I COME BEFORE YOU TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ASSIST IN THE
CITY OF WHITTIER.
AND ITS LIBRARY IN REPAIRING
THAT LIBRARY IT IS SO VERY VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMUNITY IN
THIS REGION.
THE WINNER LIBRARIES IN DANGER
STATE OF DISREPAIR.
THIS IS BEEN TEAM THIS SIZE
RIPLEY UNSAFE AND HAS ELECTRICAL
PLUMBING MECHANICAL AND ROOFING
PROBLEMS.
THIS INCLUDES MATERIALS IN THE
BUILDING IT CONTAINED THE
SPECIALS AND EVEN SEWER BLOCKAGE.
IT IS A TOUGH TOUGH THING FOR
THE CITY OF OF WITH YOUR IN AND
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED.
THE STRUCTURES IN IMMEDIATE NEED
OF CONSTRUCTION UPGRADE TO
ENSURE ITS INTEGRITY.
IT HAS REACHED A POINT THAT THE
CITY IS CONCERNED THAT IS GOING
TO HAVE TO CLOSE THE DOORS
BECAUSE OF SAFETY.
AND IT IS A HUGE CONCERN TO THE
CITIZENS OF OF THE REGION THERE.
IN WHITTIER.
THE ESTIMATED COST TO MAKE THESE
UPGRADES IS OVER FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS BUT THE CITY HAS
SECURED TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING AND IS REQUESTING ONLY
FOUR POINT -- FOUR TO FINISH THE
PROJECT.
THESE FUNDS WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TOWARD THE REBUILDING OF THE
COMMUNITY AND IT'S BEEN.
MUCH MUCH TOO LONG.
THE LIBRARY IS IS SUCH A A
SOURCE OF OF OF COMING TOGETHER
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE LIBRARY IS A REGIONAL
ATTRACTION AND HAS BECOME A
REGIONAL CENTER FOR VETERANS TO
ACCESS AND BECOME INFORMED ABOUT
THE SERVICES THAT ARE STILL
NEEDED TO THEM.
AND MAKE AVAILABLE TO THE
VETERANS OF THE COMMUNITY.
THE CITY HAS WORKED TO FIND THE
THE FUNDING AS I HAD MENTIONED
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT FOR
TWENTY YEARS NOW. FOR THE CITY
DID LOSE THIS RESOURCE IN THIS.
AREA OF OF OF OF COMMON GROUND
TO COME TOGETHER IT WOULD BE
DESTRUCTIVE TO THE COMMUNITY.
I URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
STATE TO HELP THIS LIBRARY IN
THE CITY OF WHITTIER KEEP ITS
DOORS OPEN TO HELP THE OCCUPANTS
THE CONSTITUENTS.
AND TO CONTINUE SERVING OUR
CHILDREN ARE VETERANS OF SENIOR.
IN THE USE OF ALL AGES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION ON THIS
REQUEST.
THANK YOU SIR TO A THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SIR RUBIO.
SIR YOU ARE PRESENTING MY
RECORDS REFLECT ON ITEMS ONE A
AND ONE FIFTY AND GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
TODAY I WILL TART WITH MY OUT
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL.
INITIATIVE ODD TODAY IMPRISONING
BUDGET A BUDGET QUEST FOR THREE
MILLION TO SUPPORT GRANTS. TO
FUND FOR SCHOOL FOOD AUTHORITIES
THAT WANT TO EXPAND THE
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL.
MEAL SERVICE MODELS OVER THE
NEXT THREE FISCAL YEARS.
THE SCHOOL BREAKFAST PROGRAM IS
A FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM WHICH
ASSIST SCHOOLS AND OTHER
AGENCIES IN PROVIDING NUTRITIOUS
BREAKFAST WHERE CHILDREN.
AT REASONABLE PRICES THE USDA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING THE
PROGRAM NATIONALLY IN CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ADMINISTRATES THIS
PROGRAM.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN SB TWO EIGHTY
TWO IS SIGNED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
PRIORITIZING TWO MILLION IN
GRANT FUNDS BUT AFTER FACE TO
START OR EXPAND THEIR BREAKFAST
AFTER THE BELL PROGRAM.
AS A RESULT OF HECTIC FAMILY
SCHEDULES AS WELL AS BUSTED
LADIES STUDENTS SOMETIMES COME
TO SCHOOL WITHOUT ANY FOOD IN
pBE AB PROGRAM SEEKS TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION IN SCHOOL
BREAKFAST PROGRAMS TO STUDENTS
AFTER THE START OF THE SCHOOL
DAY. TWENTY FIFTEEN STUDY SHOWS
THAT 87% OF PRINCIPLES THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROGRAM
AGREED THAT MANY OTHER SCHOOLS
SHOULD DO THE SAME.
COM AND EIGHTY PRINCIPLES ALSO
NOTED AN INCREASE IN
PARTICIPATION AND ATTENDANCE
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY THREE
POINT TWO MILLION LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AT A TEN K. TO TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
OF THESE THIRTY EIGHT PART 30%
PARTICIPATED IN THE SCHOOL
BREAKFAST PROGRAM WHICH IS ONE
OF THE LOWEST SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PARTICIPATION IN THE NATION.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT SCHOOL.
BREAKFAST SUPPORTS ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT ATTENDANCE AT SCHOOL
AND OF AND PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
HEATH AS WELL.
I'M I'M JUST HERE PERSONALLY TO
TELL YOU IS A SCHOOL TEACHER HOW
MANY TIMES YOU KNOW I A CHILD
CAME UP TO ME.
EVERY MORNING AND SAID I CAN
THINK I CAN READ MY TUMMY HURTS
AND I ALWAYS KNEW BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE BREAKFAST.
SO I ALWAYS SET OUT TO HAVE FOOD
IN MY CLASSROOM BUT WE IT'S NOT
ALWAYS FEASIBLE AND SO IT WOULD
BE REALLY NICE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A CHILD THAT COMES TO CLASS
PREPARED MENTALLY PHYSICALLY AND
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WAS ITEM OF ONE
DE.
MORNAY ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP
DOWNSIDE THE BREAKFAST --
BREAKFAST AFTER THE BELL SO THAT
WAS ITEM ONE DAY YOUR NEXT ONE
IS ITEM ONE A. WHICH IS ENGLISH
LEARNER REST.
REST S..
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING AGAIN SO
TODAY I'M PRESENTING A BUDGET
REQUEST FOR THIRTEEN MILLION TO
FUND THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNER ROAD MAP INITIATIVE.
WHICH IS ALSO LET YOU KNOW
CAUCUS PRIORITY WE'RE REQUESTING
AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR MILLION
AND OVER THE COURSE OF ABOUT
THREE FISCAL YEARS BEGINNING
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR.
THE APPROPRIATION WILL COME OUT
OF THE GENERAL FUND ANGLE TO
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE ADDITIONAL MILLION WOULD
COVER THE OVERALL COST OF
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES EXPRESS
FOR THE C. C. E. AND THE CD.
IN JULY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION CREATED THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNER ROAD MAP POLICY
WHICH IS DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES FOR E. L. STUDENTS.
HOWEVER THESE ARE WAS THAT THERE
WAS A LACK OF FUNDING TO TRULY
SUPPORT OUR EDUCATORS WHO WERE
IMPLEMENTING OF THE ROADMAP.
AND WILL BE IMPLEMENTING IT THIS
IS WHY I SUBMITTED A BUDGET
REQUEST TO ALL ALLOCATE THIRTEEN
MILLION TO HELP SUPPORT TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
IMPLEMENTING THEIR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE.
LEARNER ROAD MAP INITIATIVE THE
FUNNY WILL DIRECTLY HELP OUR
EDUCATORS WITH THE FOLLOWING.
FIRST THEY WILL BUILD CAPACITY
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAM.
SECOND I WILL ENSURE INCLUSION
OF YELP ROAD MAP AT EVERY LEVEL
OF THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT.
NUMBER THREE ESTABLISH
CONNECTIONS WITH LOCAL CONTROL
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN THE EL
CAP AND TITLE THREE PLANS
LEADING TO MEANINGFUL GOALS AND
OUTCOMES.
REQUIRING FULL ACCESS TO
CURRICULUM ASSURING MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS TOWARDS ATTAINING
ACADEMIC.
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY IN CLOSING
GAPS IN ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE E. L..
NUMBER FOUR IT WILL ALSO
IMPLEMENT INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS
THAT EFFECTIVELY DEVELOP
ACADEMIC CONTENT KNOWLEDGE
DISCIPLINE SPECIAL.
A SPECIFIC PRACTICES ACADEMIC
LANGUAGE AND BI LINGUAL
PROFICIENCY THE FUNDING WILL BE
CO ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE. FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LEAD COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ONCE AGAIN I COME TO
YOU WITH MY PERSONAL STORY AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE LEARNER.
I ASKED RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT JOB CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SIR WELL.
SIR MY RECORDS INDICATE YOUR
PRESENTING ON ITEM TO ELF.
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITIES NO
FROM -- THE THREAT.
TO SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AND
HEALTH PRETTY OF COURSE STATE
BUILDING -- SERASA MEMBERS THANK
YOU.
FOR ALLOW ME TO PRESENT THIS
REQUEST -- THIS IS A REQUEST FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- GENERAL FUND TO BE
OKAY TO SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY BEGIN PLANNING.
A MIXED USE HOUSING PROJECT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND I WILL
BE PRESENTING THE SAME REQUEST
WILL PRESENT OF THE ASSEMBLY ON
PRODUCING AIR.
HOW DOES A STATE?
ADD SIGNIFICANT VALUE TO THE
REGION IN THE STATE IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST CAMPUSES IN OUR
SYSTEM.
BUT ISN'T URBAN CAMPUS ON ONLY
NINETEEN DOWNTOWN CITY BLOCKS.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO EXPAND
ITS PHYSICAL FOOTPRINT.
THE SILICON VALLEY REASON HAS
MEDIAN RENTAL RATES AMONG THE
HIGHEST IN THE IN THE NATION.
THIS SOUNDS A STATE.
LOSES AT LEAST ONE FACULTY OR
STAFF CANDIDATE PER MONTH DUE TO
HIGH HOUSING COSTS.
IS A HORRIBLE HORRIBLE SITUATION.
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO EXPAND
THE CAMPUS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE GROWING COMMUNITY.
BUT WE WILL WE SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL OF THE STATE OWN
ALQUIST BUILDING.
SO BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS AN OUTDATED PROPERTY THE
BLOCKS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THE VITAL PEDESTRIAN QUARTER.
IN DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE IT'S NEXT
TO A LIGHT RAIL STOP.
DIRECTLY ACROSS THE THE FOR SALE
FROM THE HAMMER THEATER OPERATED
BY.
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE.
AND IS ONE BLOCK AWAY FROM THE
CAMPUS.
LOCATIONS A GREAT LOCATION BUT
THE BUILDING IS UNSAFE.
THERE'S NO PARKING FOR THE
EMPLOYER VISITORS.
AND OF COURSE IT DOESN'T MEET
THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THAT USE THE STATE
SERVICES THERE.
IT COULD IT COULD BE SO MUCH
MORE FOR SAN JOSE FOR STUDENTS
AND FOR THE STATE.
WE HOPE AND EXPECT BASED ON
PLENARY DISCUSSIONS THAT THE
OFFERED ALQUIST BUILDING WILL BE
IDENTIFIED.
BY THE STATE AS A CANDIDATE FOR
DISPOSITION IN THE NEW FUTURE.
IF REALIZE THE PROJECT COULD
EXPAND THAT UNIVERSITY'S
CLASSROOM SPACE.
AN INCREASE THE HOUSING SUPPLY
FOR FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS.
THIS IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
THAT ALLOWS UNIVERSITY INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY.
THE FACULTY AND STUDENTS COULD
AFFORD SMALL INVESTMENT IN THE
PLANNING MONEY AT THIS TIME. ONE
ABLE SOUNDS THE STATE TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE AND THE CITY. TO
DEVELOP A CLEAR VISION.
OF OR THE PROJECT ENABLE INPUT
FROM KEY STAKEHOLDERS AND BILL
SUPPORT IN COMMITMENTS FOR THE
NEXT STEP.
ARCHER APPROVAL FOR THIS --
IMPACTFUL REQUEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR [inaudible]
SURE WILK.
YOU'RE PRESENTING YOU ARE
PRESENTING ON ITEM. ONE F..
SURE SCHOOL FACILITIES GRANT
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER.
AND REQUESTING THE COMMITTEE
PROVE A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM TO COVER
CURRENT AND FUTURE GROWTH IN THE
PROGRAM.
MY DISTRICT INCLUDES THREE
CHARTER SCHOOLS BENEFITING FROM
THE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
GRANT PROGRAM WHICH ENSURES WE
HAVE QUALITY FACILITIES EVERY
YEAR.
IN ADDITION THE GRANT PROGRAM
REIMBURSES SCHOOL SERVING HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS 475%.
OF THEIR RENT OR LEASE COSTS --
SO THE GOVERNOR'S GOVERNOR
PROPOSES A BASE FUNDING OF A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN MILLION TO
THE PROGRAM IS THE SAME
ANNOUNCED LAST YEAR AND YET
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO GROW.
AND FACILITY COSTS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING CUTS AS HIGH AS 20% TO
EVERY SCHOOLS GRANT WILL RESULT
IN THEM BEING FORCED TO SPEND
ADDITIONAL GENERAL.
GENERAL PARADING FUNDS UP
FACILITIES HARMING THE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THEY PROVIDE TO
STUDENTS THIS IS ALMOST THE
EQUIVALENT OF SEVENTY JR SELLERS
TO PAY FOR THESE FACILITIES. FOR
THESE REASONS ARE REQUEST THAT
THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE TO COVER
THIS PROJECTED GROWTH ENSURE THE
PROGRAM REMAINS FULLY FUNDED.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
EXCELLENT JOB CENTER WILL THANK
YOU.
SHADED BY PAGE [inaudible]
THANK.
I WILL BE PRESENTING THE
ADDITIONAL BUDGET REQUESTS BUT
I'M GOING TO DEFER DOING THAT
UNTIL THE END OF OUR VARIOUS
PANEL DISCUSSIONS AND AS I
INDICATED I WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AS TO ALL.
OF THESE ITEMS -- AT THE END OF
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE SESSION SO
WITH THAT WHY DON'T WE PROCEED
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL DISCUSSION
IT'S ITEM SIXTY ONE HUNDRED
ISSUE NUMBER THREE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MENTAL HEALTH AND
SCHOOLS LOCAL PERSPECTIVES.
BUT RATHER THAN HAVING YOU SIT
AND LISTEN TO ME READ THAT SHE
WOULD RATHER BE PRESENTING TO US
SO.
WE'LL DO IT THAT WAY LET'S START
WITH THE INTRODUCTIONS FOR THE
RECORD TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT
SIR.
MANY.
FIVE ASA COUNTY OFFICES.
THIS NUMBER OF THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
MORNING I'M BLANCA CAVAZOS I'M A
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE TAFT UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK YOU
FOR COMING.
GOOD MORNING -- MICHAEL
MCCORMACK SUPERINTENDENT OF
ALBERTINA FIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT
YOU FOR JOINING US SIR.
WHO WANTS TO START?
I'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGAN.
YOU SHOULD HAVE SOME -- ONE
PIECE OF PAPER UP THERE THAT'S
FROM THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL HEALTH.
COMING OUR WAY OUTSTANDING.
THE ONE STATISTIC ON THERE THAT
STARTLING TO ME THAT I WANTED TO
POINT OUT -- TO THE MEMBERS IN
THE CHAIR.
IS THE AVERAGE DELAY BETWEEN
ONSET OF SYMPTOMS AN
INTERVENTION. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS TEN YEARS.
THAT'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME [inaudible]
AND THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
BILLS I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS IS CURRENTLY
CONSIDERING AND WE'D WE'D LOVE
TO SEE IF THERE CAN BE A
STRATEGIC APPROACH -- MAYBE SOME
SORT OF A COMMISSION OR A TASK
FORCE THAT REALLY DIVES DEEPLY
INTO.
YOU KNOW CHALLENGES THAT -- THAT
THAT WERE FACING -- WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
AND WE'RE SEEING EXTREME
BEHAVIORS FROM YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER STUDENTS SO MANY GIVE ME
AN EXAMPLE OF A FIRST GRADE
STUDENT IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT OCCURRED.
IN THE LAST TEN DAYS.
WITH THE STUDENT AT LUNCH
EMPTIED OUT THEIR JUICE BOX.
WENT TO THE RESTROOM URINATED IN
THE JUICE BOX AND ATTEMPTED TO
SERVE IT TO HIS FIRST GRADE
CLASSMATES.
SO WHAT YEAH FIRST GRADE SIX
YEARS OLD.
INTO THE THAT WELL THAT'S KIND
OF AN EXTREME STORY.
THE TEACHERS AND THE STAFF.
WERE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH THE
TYPE OF TRAUMA WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE FACING AND
HOME ENVIRONMENTS AND THEN OF
COURSE.
AS A PARTNER -- THE SCHOOLS --
WHAT WE KIND OF USED TO SEE IN
THE PAST THOSE SAME KINDS OF
STRATEGIES THAT OUR TEACHERS AND
OUR SUPPORT STAFF WERE USED TO
DEALING THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY WORK -- WERE NO LONGER
SEEING THOSE SAME STRATEGIES
WORK WITH THE ADDITIONAL --
TRAUMA THAT OUR STUDENTS SEEM TO
BE BRINGING TO SCHOOL AND SO WE
THINK THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. TO TRAIN
STAFF -- TO TO DEAL WITH THE
CHALLENGES AND AND HELP OUR
STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN IN
THE SCHOOL SETTING.
AND SO -- WE HAVE A COUPLE OF A
COUPLE OF BOX [inaudible]
MANY AS WHEN FOSTER CARE STE.
COME TO OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT OR
CHANGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
EVERYBODY GETS IN A TWIST OF
THOSE STUDENTS ARE NOT ENROLLED
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS
VERY OFTEN TIMES THE STUDENTS
ARE RECEIVING TREATMENT AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
IN THEIR PREVIOUS SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND IN SOME CASES IT'S NOT HEARD
OF THAT IT'S TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
MONTHS.
TRANSFERRED FROM THE THE
TRANSFERRING COUNTY. TO THE
COUNTY THAT IS RECEIVING THE
STUDENT AND SO WHAT THAT MEANS.
IS STUDENTS ARE COMING IN AND
THE SERVICES THAT THEY USED TO
RECEIVE ARE NOT FOLLOWING THEM
IN A TIMELY FASHION.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY SOME OF THE
MEDICATIONS THAT THEY WERE
PRESCRIBED THE WERE THEY RUN OUT
THE REFILL IS NOT AVAILABLE.
AND SO NOW WE HAVE STUDENTS WHO
ARE RECEIVING THE COUNSELING AND
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES.
AND THEY ALSO ARE RECEIVING --
THE MET MEDICATION THAT'S BEEN
PRESCRIBED BY THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL.
AND YOUR RESPECTIVE OF YOUR
PHILOSOPHY OR YOUR THOUGHTS ON
MEDICATION FOR THESE THESE
SERVICES.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE SERVICES
ARE NOT IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
THE STUDENTS IN A TIMELY FASHION.
SO.
THAT'S THAT'S ONE THING FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION -- THE OTHER THING
THAT THAT WE THINK IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
IS THAT SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING BE PART OF TEACHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS YOU KNOW START
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE LONG GAME --
BUT WE THINK THAT IF TEACHERS
ARE COMING INTO THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SETTING AND THEY'VE HAD
SOME INSTRUCTION.
IN SOME DISCUSSIONS AND SOME
ABILITY TO LEARN SOMETHING MORE
ABOUT SUPPORTING STUDENTS
THROUGH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING PROGRAMS WHEN THEY
ARRIVE INTO OUR SCHOOLS WE THINK
THAT WOULD BE.
EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
JUST THE FINAL THING I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT BEFORE A SHOW MY
COLLEAGUES SHARE.
IS THAT THE ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTRATORS.
HAS A TASK FORCE ON MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND WE'RE HERE TO SHARE AND
COLLABORATE IN ANY WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA -- EDUCATORS ARE
FACING TODAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
JUST WANNA GIVE YOU A PICTURE --
AS I START OF ARE DISTRICTS SO
THAT AS I SPEAK YOU CAN.
ENVISION WHAT THIS IS LIKE -- WE
ARE SMALL HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
WITH ROUGHLY A THOUSAND STUDENTS
ATTENDING.
EITHER.
OUR HIGH SCHOOL OR OR
ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION SITES SO
WERE RELATIVELY SMALL.
A 60% 67% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
ARE SO SO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED UP 48% ARE WHITE
FORTY FIVE PERCENTERS PANIC AND
ABOUT 7% OF THEM ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS IN ABOUT 10%. FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES WE'RE
IN A RURAL COMMUNITY ABOUT
THIRTY MILES WEST OF BAKERSFIELD
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
OF IN IN A COMMUNITY WITH ABOUT
NINE THOUSAND RESIDENTS THAT ARE
PRIMARILY EMPLOYED IN OIL AND
AGRICULTURE.
THE MEDIAN INCOME IS ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS ALMOST 16%
IN MARCH WHICH IS ABOUT FOUR
TIMES AS MUCH AS THE STATE
AVERAGE -- YOU POST THREE
QUESTIONS OF US AND AND I WANT
TO START OUT WITH THE FIRST ONE
IN THE FIRST ONE WAS ONE OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF YOUR
STUDENTS AND HAVE THESE CHANGED
OVER TIME.
AND I WANT TO START OUT BY --
JUST GIVING YOU SOME RAW DATA.
ERROR A HIGH SCHOOL -- WE DID AN
ACTIVITY FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHICH IS CALLED I WISH MY
TEACHER NEW.
AND A HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX OF
OUR FRESHMEN STUDENTS ARE ABOUT
65% PARTICIPATED IN THIS
ACTIVITY IN THEIR ENGLISH
CLASSES AT THE HIGH SCHOOL --
THIS DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION SITE
BECAUSE I THINK THE ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION SITES WOULD SHOW MUCH
MORE STARK STATISTICS -- I HAVE --
PROVIDED FOR YOU UP PICTURES OF
A BULLETIN BOARD.
OF IN WHAT THE ACTIVITY WAS WAS
THAT THE TEACHER ASKED STUDENTS
TO RESPOND TO THIS PROMPT I WISH
MY TEACHER NEW AND HAVE THE
STUDENTS.
WRITE THEIR RESPONSE ON POST IT
AND SO THESE ARE ANONYMOUS.
RESPONSES ARE I'M GIVING YOU AN
OVERALL SHOT AND THEN GRADUALLY
CLOSER SHOTS OF THIS IS RAW DATA.
SEVENTY OF THESE OR 42% OF THEM
INDICATE THAT STUDENT IS
FUNCTIONING UNDER SOME SORT OF
DURESS -- AND IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF THE POST IT NOTES IT
INCLUDES A STUDENT THAT TALKS
ABOUT HAVING BEEN RAPED.
IT TALKS ABOUT A STUDENT WHO'S
DEALING WITH THEIR GRANDPARENTS --
BECOMING PROGRESSIVELY ILL AND
MOVING INTO A WHEEL CHAIR --
STUDENTS THAT -- HAS HAD A
PARENT DIE RECENTLY FOLLOWED BY
A SUICIDE OF A SIBLING THESE ARE
JUST -- OUT OF A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX STUDENTS THIS IS JUST.
A SAMPLING FOR YOU I FELT THAT
THIS WAS -- MORE OR LESS OUT OF-THE MOUTH OF BABES THIS IS WHAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE TELLING US AND
IT ISN'T ALL OUR STUDENTS IT'S A
SMALL SAMPLING OF OUR STUDENTS --
I SPOKE TO OUR SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST.
OF TO TO FIND OUT HOW MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE DEALING WITH
THE DEATH OF A PARENT.
AND SHE REPORTED THAT.
SHE HAS DEALT WITH THESE ARE THE
STUDENTS THAT WE KNOW OF AND
AGAIN THIS IS A SWEET --
DISTRICT OF A THOUSAND I SHE'S
WORKED WITH SIX FRESHMEN WHO
HAVE LOST A PARENT SIX
SOPHOMORES TO JUNIORS AND FOR
SENIORS WHO ARE DEALING WITH THE
LOSS OF A PARENT.
AND THERE ARE -- GRIEF SUPPORT
SERVICES ARE NOT -- READILY
AVAILABLE IN THE COMMUNITY SHE'S
HAD FIFTY EIGHT MEETINGS AND AND
AGAIN WE ONLY HAVE ONE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST TO THE THOUSAND
STUDENTS SHE SAID FIFTY EIGHT
MEETINGS WITH STUDENTS WHO OF
SELF REFERRED TO BEEN.
REFERRED BY AN ADULT -- DEALING
WITH AGAIN GRIEF -- I ALSO SPOKE
TO OR DRUG AND ALCOHOL
INTERVENTION SPECIALIST WHO'S
BEEN WORKING WITH TEENS AND
ADULTS FOR OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS
WE CONTRACT WITH HIS -- COMPANY
WITH HIS BUSINESS FOR THE
SERVICES AND HE'S WORKED WITH
OUR DISTRICT FOR FOURTEEN OF
THOSE THIRTY TWO YEARS.
ON AVERAGE HE SEES ABOUT.
SIXTY TO NINETY OF OUR STUDENTS
I IN THE DISTRICT PER YEAR HE
WORKS IN OUR COUNTY WITH ABOUT --
THREE HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
TEENS IN.
IN THEIR INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT
PROGRAMS.
HE ESTIMATES THAT 90% OF THESE
TEAMS HAVE A DUAL DIAGNOSIS OF
DEPRESSION ANXIETY BI POLAR AT
CETERA.
AND THEY USE DRUGS AND ALCOHOL
TO SELF MEDICATE TO DEAL WITH
THESE.
ISSUES -- AND HE SAID THAT SINCE
THE THE YEAR -- TWO THOUSAND
PROFESSIONALS IN HIS IN HIS
FIELD HAVE SEEN A TREMENDOUS
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF YOUTH
ABUSING DRUGS AND ALCOHOL AND
NOW.
IT HAS STARTED REACHING STUDENTS
AS EARLY AS FOURTH GRADE.
AND I YOUR YOUR SECOND QUESTION
WAS WHAT STRATEGIES AT THE
DISTRICT OR SCHOOL LEVELER
TARGETING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AND WHERE ARE THERE GAPS OR OR
WHAT NEEDS.
THAT WE HAVE THE KANATA THAT WE
CANNOT FILL.
OUR WE'VE DONE -- PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR STAFF IN SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND WHEN I SPEAK
ABOUT STAFF I'M SPEAKING NOT
ONLY ABOUT OUR TEACHERS BUT
EVERY ADULT THAT WORKS IN OUR
DISTRICT.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
STUDENTS HAVE A DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH -- NOT ONLY
TEACHERS BUT ALSO THEIR BUS
DRIVER THE CUSTODIAN THE THE
PERSON WHO WORKS IN THE
CAFETERIA AT SEVERANCE SO WE
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THEY HAVE THIS TRAINING -- AS
WELL WE'VE HAD OUR TEACHERS --
GROUP OF TEACHERS TRAINED IN
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES AND OF
COURSE -- THE B. I. S. POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS.
AS FAR AS OUR OUR TRAINING WE
ACTUALLY HAD A MEETING -- JUST
THIS WEEK WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
IN PLANNING OUR EL CAP AND WE
DISCUSSED THIS VERY ISSUE NOT
BECAUSE I WAS COMING HERE BUT
BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A PRESSING
ISSUE. FOR US IN EDUCATION AND
SO FOR OVER THE NEXT -- SCHOOL
YEAR WE ARE OUR TEACHERS OUR
STAFF WILL BE RECEIVING TRAINING
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ACADEMIC
LEARNING -- WE WILL ALSO HAVE --
PROFESSIONAL COME IN WHO
SPECIALIZES IN GRIEF -- PERCENT
ON GRIEF SUPPORT STRATEGIES.
AND ALSO -- ANOTHER PROFESSIONAL
THAT WILL PRESENT ON STRESS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES AND STRESS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES NOT ONLY.
FOR THE STUDENTS BUT AS WELL FOR
THE ADULTS WE LIVE IN A VERY
VERY STRESSED SOCIETY -- WE'VE
ALSO -- IMPLEMENTED MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT IN BOTH THE
PERSONAL AND ACADEMIC AREAS --
WE'VE CREATED A PERSONALIZED
ACADEMIC CENTER SO WE'VE MOVED
OUR INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM
FROM WHAT IS HAS BEEN
TRADITIONALLY.
A ONE HOUR A WEEK ONE ONE TIME
YOU KNOW ONE HOUR A WEEK -- TO A
THREE HOUR PER DAY PROGRAM WHERE
STUDENTS COME IN AND WORK
INDIVIDUALLY -- ON THE COMPUTER
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF AN
EDUCATOR.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THE SO
IT'S THREE HOURS A DAY AND THEN
THEY ALSO RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM A
COUNSELOR THAT MEETS WITH THEM.
ARE WE HAVE TO CALL COHORTS WHEN
THE BEATS IN THE MORNING AND ONE
THAT MEETS -- IN THE AFTERNOON.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
COUNSELING SUPPORT IS CRITICAL
SOME OF THOSE STUDENTS ARE IN
THAT PROGRAM BECAUSE OF ANXIETY
ISSUES WHERE THEY CAN NOT ATTEND.
A TRADITIONAL -- SIX PERIOD
SEVEN PERIOD DAY AND AND WITH.
WE'RE SMALL WERE SMALL WERE
SMALL.
DISTRICT WERE SMALL I SCHOOL AND
FOR THEM IT'S TOO MANY PEOPLE TO
BE IN THE ROOM WITH AT THE SAME
TIME -- WE ALSO HAVE -- HAVE A
AN EDUCATOR WHO CONDUCTS GROUPS
OF FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE.
REFERRED TO ALTERNATIVE TO
SUSPENSION SO THESE ARE STUDENTS
SUSPEND DOUBLE BUT INSTEAD THEY
WORK WITH THIS EDUCATOR AND ON
THE SPECIFIC CURRICULUM AND THEN
SHE ALSO HOLDS GROUPS WITH THEM.
WE'VE.
ALSO ADDED TO OUR CURRICULUM OF
COURSE CALLED HUMAN ELEMENT
WHICH THE STUDENTS IN THAT
COURSE DESIGN POSITIVE
ACTIVITIES FOR STUDENTS AND HELP
CREATE WELCOMING -- THE
WELCOMING LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
YOU ASKED ABOUT THE GAPS.
THE GAPS ARE ONE OF THE THE HUGE
GAPS THAT EXIST IS THAT THERE
ARE REALLY NO IN BETWEEN
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS WHO IS IN
CRISIS.
BUT YET THEY ARE NOT A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS OR HAVE NOT
VIOLATED THE LAW WE HAVE A
STUDENT -- LAST YEAR WHO WAS
ABSOLUTELY IN PRICES DID NOT
WANT -- TO BE AROUND HIS FAMILY
WE ARE -- A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER COULD NOT TRANSPORT HIM
TO BAKERSFIELD THIRTY MILES AWAY.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THE
TREATMENT THAT HE NEEDED BECAUSE
HE HADN'T YET HARM HIMSELF OR
OTHERS OR VIOLATED THE LAW.
THERE IS A A LOCAL -- SERVICE
BUT IT DID SERVICE PRIMARILY.
THAT ARE ON MEDICARE ALL IN HIS
FAMILY HAD INSURANCE HE DID NOT
WANT HIS FAMILY TO TRANSPORT HIM
TO BAKERSFIELD.
HE DID NOT WANT TO BE AROUND
THEM.
WE WERE NOT ABLE -- TO GET ANY
SERVICES FOR HIM UNTIL HE HARM
THE FAMILY DOG.
AND AND THAT'S REALLY REALLY
UNFORTUNATE SO WE NEED THOSE IN
BETWEEN SERVICES AND WE NEED
SOMEWHERE WHERE WE CAN REFER TO
THE STUDENTS AND THAT THEY CAN
THERE NEEDS OUT WHEN THEY ARE IN
CRISIS CAN BE.
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY WE ALSO
NEED TO ADDRESS THE DIFFERENT
FUNDING STREAMS.
THERE'S A CROSSOVER HERE BETWEEN
HEALTH.
AND EDUCATION AND AND ALSOTHEY
HAVE DIFFERENT REGULATIONS AND
DIFFERENT ETHICAL CODES THAT THE
FOLLOW THAT GOVERN. FOR EXAMPLE
THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR THE SOCIAL.
WORKER AND SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
WE NEED THAT ALIGNMENT --
BETWEEN THOSE SERVICES -- WE
NEED TO FACILITATE THE LEGAL
ABILITY FOR EACH.
ENTITY TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
EACH OTHER IN ORDER TO BETTER
SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES --
SOMETIMES FOR BUT GETS IN THE
WAY -- AS HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST WITH STUDENT SERVICES AND
FOSTER CARE SERVICES.
ARE THERE ARE DIFFERENT --
CONFIDENTIALLY CONFIDENTIALITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR EACH OF THOSE --
THREE A PROFESSIONS THAT I
MENTIONED THERE'S ALSO DIFFERENT
CREDENTIALING SCHOOL COUNSELORS
AND A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST CAN BE
CREDENTIALED BUT THE SOCIAL
WORKER IF WE HIRE THEM THEY HAVE
TO BE A CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE --
WE NEED GRIEF COUNSELING AND
SUPPORT -- ESPECIALLY FOR AND
AND JUST MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS WHERE
THE AVAILABILITY OF THOSE
SERVICES IS SLIM TO NONE.
AND OVERALL JUST MORE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES NOT ONLY FOR YOU
BUT ALSO FOR THE ADULTS THE
PARENTS IN THE AREA -- AND THEN
YOUR LAST QUESTION WAS WHAT
OTHER NON EDUCATION SUPPORT IS
AVAILABLE IN YOUR COMMUNITY
INCLUDING ANY PARTNERSHIPS WITH
ANY OTHER AGENCIES SURE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR SUPPORTING
FAMILIES WERE STUDENTS AND IN
TAFT WE HAVE OF THE WEST SIDE
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT AND I'VE
MET WITH THEM ECAUSE THEY DO
NOT.
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH CARE THEY
ARE PROVIDE MENTAL MEDICAL AND
ARE A SOON GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT DENTAL -- SERVICES BUT TO A
MEETING WITH THEM -- THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN PARTNERING WITH
THE DISTRICT AND AND SCHOOLS AND
BUT THEY'RE LOOKING AT GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
AND WE ARE MORE THAN WILLING TO
PARTNER WITH THEM IN WRITING
THOSE GRANTS -- THERE ALSO IS --
COLLEGE COMMUNITY SERVICES WHICH
SERVICE MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE
ELIGIBLE. FOR IN THOSE THAT DO
HAVE INSURANCE THAT MEANS THAT
FOR OUR RESIDENTS -- OUR
STUDENTS -- THAT.
THAT ARE.
IN THAT ARE ARE IN THOSE
SITUATIONS THEY HAVE TO TRAVEL
AT LEAST THIRTY MILES ONE WAY IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND THERE ALSO IS NO IMPATIENT
AND OR A VERY LIMITED EMERGENCY
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS IN CRISIS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
SO I A CARRY A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT OF A PERSPECTIVE I
COME FROM A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND OUR GOAL AND OUR
ROLE IS TO SUPPORT.
DISTRICTS SO ALL ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU POSED DRESS
KIND OF FROM THAT COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION LANDS -- START IN
WITH -- THE THE DATA THAT THEY
PRESENTED TO YEAR ROUND MENTAL
HEALTH AND THEIR NEEDS -- FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF.
WHO ARE IN OUR SYSTEMS THERE IS
A REAL CRITICAL CHANGE IN
EDUCATION WITH THE PASSAGE OF OF
AB ONE FOURTEEN MOVE AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FROM COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS?
MORE TOWARDS A SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
I THINK THAT WAS A REAL TURNING
POINT IN EDUCATION BECAUSE IT
HELPS TO RAISE THE AWARENESS OF
THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY.
AND REALLY HELP -- TO SHIFT THE
TIED FOR EDUCATORS AND
UNDERSTAND AND WHAT OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES GOING THROUGH --
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS YOU POSED
AS WAS THERE HAS THERE BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE AND AND
MENTAL ILLNESS OR THE NEEDS OF
OF STUDENTS AND I THINK. FOR
EDUCATION PARTLY WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WE'VE BECOME MORE
AWARE THEY ILLUSTRATED SEVERAL
PROGRAMS.
SO ARE A CUTIE OF UNDERSTANDING
WHAT'S HAPPENING OUR KITTY OF
UNDERSTAND AN ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES.
HAS INCREASED GREATLY -- THAT
HAS REALLY KINDA GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
PARTNERSHIPS.
THE NEXT QUESTION YOU ASKED IS --
WHAT STRATEGIES ARE WE YEARS AND
IN OUR DISTRICTS ARE FROM MY
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE IN PLASTER
COUNTY?
TO JUDGE DRESS THOSE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITY OR
IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STREET
THIS.
STATE IS SO THAT FORMER CHILDREN
SYSTEM OF CARE SO WE HAVE A
THIRTY ONE YEAR.
SYSTEM OF CARE OF INTEGRATED
SERVICES IN PLASTER COUNTY THAT
FOCUS ON AND IT AND INTEGRATED
COLLABORATION MY STAFF FROM THE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
LITERALLY SET NEXT TO SOCIAL
WORKERS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR
SOME TIME I HELP TO COORDINATE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
PLASTER COUNTY FOR SCHOOLS.
BY A FUNDING FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT PLANT IN
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES INTO
SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT AND HAVE A
SYSTEMS PERSPECTIVE WHAT KINDS
OF INTERVENTIONS DO WE HAVE THE
COUNTY OFFICE ALSO COORDINATES.
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION --
STRATEGIES FOR THE COUNTY NOT
JUST FOR EDUCATION BUT FOR THE
WHOLE COUNTY.
AND THAT'S WORKS -- REALLY WELL
OVER THE YEARS BUT WE KNOW WE'RE
NOT ADDRESS AND ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS YOU HEARD THE GAPS THE
IN BETWEEN -- IS PLAYING PLASTER
COUNTY WE LOOKED AT THAT HIGHER
AND PART OF THE SYSTEM THAT THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE AT AMMON AT
RISK -- IN EDUCATION WE CALL
THEM STUDENTS WITH TIER THREE
NEEDS [inaudible]
AND SO.
WE'VE REALLY BEEN GONE FOR A
CHEF TO IDENTIFY THE GAPS BETTER
AND SOME OF THOSE GAPS INCLUDE
HAVE AN A. INTEGRATED CONTINUUM
OF SERVICES.
AT THE SCHOOL SITE SO UP UNTIL
NOW IT'S BEEN AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL TYPICALLY BUT WHAT IS AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM LOOK LIKE
LITERALLY AT A SCHOOL SITE.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE COLLABORATING
WITH COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES ON
INTEGRATED TEAMS SO THAT'S BEEN
A GAP OF UNTIL NOW IT'S STARTING
TO HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA BUT NOT
AS?
AS AS WE LIKE TO SAY.
ALSO WE WE TEND TO LOOK AT
STUDENTS WHO ARE AT ADMIN AT
RISK AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN REALLY
GOOD AT LOOKING AT DATA.
SO LOOKING AT DATA ACROSS A
SCHOOL SIDE ACROSS THE DISTRICT
ACROSS THE STATE WHAT TYPES OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS DO WE HAVE
UNIQUELY TO US AT TAFT AT
PLASTER.
IS EVERY SCHOOL SITE WILL HAVE
UNIQUE AND DIFFERENT NEEDS.
SO. ONE OF THE THINGS I ADVOCATE
FOR A LOT A LOT FOR IS
OPPORTUNITY FOR DISTRICTS TO
WORK WITH THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY. TO IDENTIFY WHAT
TYPES OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS DO WE NEED AT TAPPED OR
DO WE NEED AT ROSWELL CITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE QUESTION ABOUT -- WHAT ARE
THE NON EDUCATIONAL SERVICES OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THE GAPS
KIND OF LATE IN TO THAT?
AT WE HAVE A A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY GIVEN TO US AND
PLASTERED FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
THAT IS ENHANCE AND THE SYSTEM
OF CAE THAT WE HAD AT THIS HIGH
LEVEL.
AND HELPING US IN PLASTER ALONG
WITH FOUR OTHER COUNTIES TO PUSH
THAT DOWN INTO THE SCHOOL SITE.
I'M NOT JUST THE DISTRICT LEVEL
BUT RIGHT INTO THE SCHOOL SITE
AND CREATE AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM.
WITHIN A SQUALL WHERE WE CAN
LEARN THE THE PROJECT IS
ORGANIZED AROUND BEING A
DEMONSTRATION PRODUCT.
OF PROJECT SO WE CAN LEARN HOW
DO WE COMMUNICATE.
WE HAVE BETWEEN HAPPEN FOR PA --
HOW DO WE SET UP A SYSTEM WHERE
WE CAN HAVE REGULAR ROUTINE TEAM
MADE ENDS HOW DO WE CREATE A NOT
JUST A WELLNESS CENTER AT A
SCHOOL SITE BUT A WELLNESS?
CAMPUS WITH PARTNERS.
AND WE'RE FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE
COMMISSION TO DO THAT.
BUT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH TO
STRATEGIES AND AND WE JANET
ACTUALLY MEET BEFORE TODAY.
THAT MY COLLEAGUES TO THE LEFT
TALKED ABOUT IS THAT WE DO THAT
AND AND NOT JUST AN INTEGRATED
WAY BUT THAT WE USE MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT. TO LOOK AT
HOW WE SCAFFOLD THOSE SUPPORTS
TERRACE SCHOOL SITE.
AND THAT WE USE A FRAMEWORK OF
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS
AND SUPPORTS SO THAT WE CAN
GROUND AND SUPPORT STUDENTS AT A
SCHOOL SITE.
HELPING STUDENTS WHO HAVE AN
RECEIVE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND OR DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE SOCIAL SKILLS THEY NEED TO
NAVIGATE.
SO I THINK A LOT OF TIMES
WITHOUT D. V. I. S. AT A SCHOOL
SITE WE TEND -- TO END OF
CORRUPTION THE DATA BECAUSE
CHILDREN COME FROM SO MANY
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW IF THEY WERE TAUGHT --
BASIC SOCIAL PROTOCOLS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES SO.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
SOLID FRAMEWORK THAT WE SCAFFOLD.
THE TYPES OF SUPPORTS THAT THEY
TALKED ABOUT TO SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY.
THAT'S EVIDENCE BASED AND DRIVEN
BY DATA.
WE'RE NOT JUST REACT IN ALWAYS
TO STUDENTS WITH TEAR THREE
NEEDS BUT WE MOVED DOWN THE
CONTINUE ANSWERS SUPPORT
STUDENTS EARLIER.
I WHEN WHEN HONESTLY IT'S
CHEAPER.
IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE AND IT'S
MORE FAMILY FRIENDLY.
THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS ABOUT
FAMILIES WE NEED AN EDUCATION.
TO EVERY PART OF THE PROCESS AND
NOT JUST FAMILIES BUT OLDER
YEARS.
AS I GET IN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL AND HEAR THOSE
VOICES.
AND HAVE THEM HELP US IDENTIFY
WHAT ARE OUR NEEDS AS A FAMILY
WHAT ARE OUR NEEDS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND LITERALLY HAVE THEM BE PART
OF THAT AND TSS TEAM TO DECIDE
WHAT TYPES OF SERVICE I
PREVENTION PROGRAM DO WE NEED.
IN OUR COMMUNITY OR AT THIS --
SCHOOL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND FOR THE EXCELLENT WORK
YOU'RE DOING ON THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
LET ME TELL YOU A STORY -- WAS
THIS YEAR I BELIEVE.
I WAS IN MY OFFICE AND I WAS
VISITED BY SOME OF THE PTA.
MEMBERS WHO ALSO BROUGHT SOME
STUDENTS ALONG.
ETCETERA MY TABLE AND SOME OF
THE STUDENTS SAID IN THE COUCH
IN THE OFFICE AND THERE WAS A
YOUNG MAN ON THE COUCH IN --
AFTER THE PARENTS.
HAVE FINISHED.
ASKING ME QUESTIONS AND MAKING
THEIR COMMENTS OF THE GIVE THIS
YOUNG MAN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AND HE WAS VERY VERY YOUNG.
ANY TOLD ME A STORY AND HE SAID
YOU KNOW I I WENT INTO THE
RESTROOM AND MY SCHOOL.
THE OTHER DAY AND I FOUND A
YOUNG MAN.
MY AGE SITTING ON THE FLOOR
CRYING UNCONTROLLABLY.
AND HE HE WAS DISTRAUGHT.
AND THE STUDENT TOLD ME I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO BECAUSE THERE
WERE NO THE COUNSELORS AT MY
SCHOOL SITE THIS IS A SCHOOL IN
THE DISTRICT.
IN MY SCHOOL SITE.
THERE WAS NO NURSE I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
SO I'M SURPRISED HE COULD SAY
THIS BUT HE SAID I WONDER BEING
THE THE COUNSELOR FOR THIS YOUNG
MAN TO GET HIM.
IN GOOD ENOUGH SHAPE TO GO BACK
TO THE CLASSROOM TO TALK.
TO OUR TEACHER.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
ALL IS HOW DO YOU STAFF YOUR
CAMPUSES YOUR SCHOOL SITES WITH
RESPECT. TO TO MENTAL HEALTH.
PROVIDERS OF ONE FLAVOR OR
ANOTHER -- MAYBE I MISSED IT IN
THE PRESENTATIONS AND IF I DID
PERHAPS YOU CAN REMIND ME.
HELLO IN PLASTER COUNTY IT
VARIES AMONG SCHOOL SIZE
DEPENDENT ON FUND AND AND
STRATEGIES WHAT I SEE HAPPEN AND
AND OUR COUNTY.
IS DISTRICTS ADOPT AN
INDIVIDUALS LIKE -- HEALTH
PROVIDERS MF CHEESE OR LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS TO THE
SCHOOL SITES.
SO I SAY AN INCREASE AND EVER
INCREASING A RALPH FOR THOSE
TYPES OF INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
COUNSELORS.
AS WELL OR SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS
BALUSTRADED VERY NICELY THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PROVINCIAL PEOPLE SOME OF THEM
ARE CLASSIFIED SOME OF THEM ARE
CERTIFICATED.
AND WHAT I'M SEEING ACROSS OUR
COUNTY AND AND OTHER -- COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE IS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE START INTO SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF AB. ONE FOURTEEN
WEEKS AND AN INCREASE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS STARTED TO WORK AT
SCHOOL SITES.
I MEAN IS IT A LOCAL OPTION.
IS THE COUNTY OFFICE GET
INVOLVED TO THE DISTRICT OFFICES
GET INVOLVED WHO DECIDES.
WHO DECIDES WHO GOES WHERE WHAT
METRICS DO YOU HAVE HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE NEED WHAT ARE YOUR
FUNDING SOURCES AND WHERE YOU'RE
FUNDING SHORTFALLS YOU KNOW THAT?
WITH RESPECT PROP COUNTY YOUR
WRITTEN.
A SOME COUNTIES HAVE DECIDED --
TO TO BANK THE MONEY -- LA
COUNTY BEING NOTABLE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IS NO OF CHAMP ON THIS.
AND NOT ROLL THE MONEY OUT TO
PROVIDE BADLY NEEDED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AT OUR SCHOOLS.
AND OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO.
THAT'S A THEY TOLD US NOT TO ASK --
COMPOUND QUESTIONS IN LAW SCHOOL
BUT THAT'S A COMPOUND QUESTION
BUT PERHAPS IF YOU CAN REMEMBER
THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF A BIG.
ALL OF THOSE I WILL TRY TO GET
MY POINT.
AND I'D LIKE TO JUMP IN ON THAT
AS WELL I DO VERY VERY WELL TAKE
THE OTHER HALF OF THE COMPOUND
THAT'S OF REAL UP RELATIVE -- TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND
FUND AND IN THE LEGISLATION IT'S
COMMUNITY TROFENSE SO WE SEE
DIFFERENT PLANTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIFAT FOR
THIS DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION I
THINK IS REALLY CRITICAL.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT.
DID UNDER PROP.
SIXTY THREE WHETHER THE MONEY IS
DRIVEN TO SEE BE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FOR PURPOSES OF
ASSISTING SCHOOLS.
OR DIRECTLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT WE'RE SOMEHOW PROHIBITED
FROM USING THE PROP SIXTY THREE
MONEY FOR THIS NO.
NO NOT AT ALL WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
REFERENCE IN IS COMMUNITIES HAVE
ORGANIZED IT IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
SAID THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE
DESCRIBING ABOUT HAVING
COMMUNITY WELLNESS CENTERS ON
CAMPUS OR STAFF ON CAMPUS.
IN SOME COUNTIES AS DRIVEN
THROUGH MORE OF A CLINICAL MODEL
WHERE STUDENTS WILL GO TO A
CLINIC AND RECEIVE.
THOSE SERVICES -- TO AN EXAMPLE
MIGHT BE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
AN INCREDIBLE YEARS PROGRAM
THAT'S SUPPORT AND YOUNG
STUDENTS -- TYPICALLY CAVE
THROUGH THIRD GRADE BUT THAT
MIGHT NOT BE HAPPEN AND AT THE
SCHOOL SITE.
HOW HOW DOES THAT STUDENT IN?
HOW'S THAT STUDENT IN IDENTIFIED.
AND HOW DOES THE STUDENT GET TO
THE CLINICAL SIDE [inaudible]
IN SUCH.
THE MOST TRAGIC IN CATASTROPHIC
ONES WHERE WE HAVE A SUICIDAL
STUDENT TOURS SOMEONE WHO'S AN
EXTREME DISTRESS AND THAT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY UNDER THIS SHIFT
WHERE SAN SINCE AB.
ONE FOURTEEN IS TO HELP SCHOOLS
I UNDERSTAND THE TYPES OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE NEED ON
CAMPUS AND HOW DO PARTNER WITH
OUR MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
IN MOVE AND SO THE THE INSTANCE
I GAVE IN PLASTER COUNTY.
WE WORKING WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH UNDER THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT USE THOSE DOLLARS
TO PLANTS INCREDIBLE YEARS
PROGRAMS DIRECTLY ON A SCHOOL
SITE CAMPUS.
SO FOR PLASTER COUNTY WE TAKE
THOSE PROGRAMS INCREDIBLE YEARS --
THINGS LIKE FUNCTIONAL FAMILY
THERAPY AND WE CREATE A STRONGER
AND ACCESS DIRECTLY TO THE
SCHOOL SITE.
AND I THINK WHAT I'M SAYING
ACROSS THE STATE IS A SHIFT IN
THAT DIRECTION.
I WAS LIKE A LESSER COUNTY IS
WILLING TO USE THE PROP SIXTY
THREE MONEY. FOR THE PURPOSE ONE
OF THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH IT WAS
INTENDED TO ROLL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OUT.
TO INTO THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING
INTO ART SCHOOL.
YES YES VERY MUCH IN THE NOT
SURE THAT'S THE CASE IN OTHER
COUNTY I'M GONNA SUGGEST THAT.
THAT IS NOT MY EXPERIENCE --
THAT WE WE HAVE NOT SEEN THOSE
DOLLARS AND THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
OR HUNDRED THIRTY SIX BILLION IN
THE AND THE ORIGIN -- IN THE IN
A HOT YEAH.
SO I WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE USED A PORTION OF OUR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
DOLLARS THROUGH OUR LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN.
TO FUND ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THROUGH OUR EL CAP.
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE TODAY
IS WE'VE HIRED -- WE HAVE
EIGHTEEN MENTAL HEALTH IN EARNS.
WHO ARE GUIDED BY A LICENSED
MARRIAGE FAMILY COUNSELOR UNDER
THEIR LICENSE AS THEY ARE
LEARNING AND SO THESE ARE?
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WORKING
THROUGH THEIR PROGRAM.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO STAFF
ORDERS PAID THEY ARE PAID
INTERNSHIPS SO SO IT'S SO.
IT'S SOMEONE IS WORKING TOWARD A
LICENSE CLINIC TOWARDS THEIR
TOWARDS OUR FULL LICENSE AND WE
WE WE PAY THEM.
BASICALLY ENOUGH MONEY TO COVER
THEIR GAS.
IS HOW IT WORKS AND THAT AND
THAT'S REALLY UNFORTUNATE BUT ON
THE OTHER SIDE THE VALUE THAT
THEY ADD.
I JUST MET WITH OUR PRINCIPLES.
THAT ARE TWELVE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL SITES WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
STAFF.
AT TWO POINT FIVE DAYS A WEEK
[inaudible]
AND THE VALUE THAT THEY'RE
BRINGING TO OUR STUDENTS AND THE
STAFF THE PRINCIPLE THAT
TEACHERS AT THOSE SITES BY BY
BEING ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THERAPEUTIC SERVICES
FOR OUR STUDENTS HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT.
THE DIFFERENCE THAT I SEE IS
THAT OUR SCHOOL COUNSELORS WELL
THEY ARE EXTREMELY VALUABLE.
WE'RE MOVING INTO A SITUATION
WHERE.
WE REALLY NEED THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL WHO CAN PROVIDE NOT
SIMPLY COUNSELING SERVICES BUT
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES AND FOR US
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
AND THE OTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT.
WELL WE DO HAVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
THERE AND AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THAT IS NOT ACCESSIBLE IN ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IN SO FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF MY
SUPERINTENDENT COLLEAGUES HAS A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OF THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX STUDENTS.
IN ORDER TO GET THIS THE STUDENT
WHO IN NEEDS THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES THEY HAVE TO TAKE A TWO
HOUR BUS RIDE.
UP FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
THE SERVICES AND BACK.
IN SO MY THINKING IS THAT IF THE
DOLLARS ARE MOVING MORE TOWARDS
WHERE THE WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE
LOCATED -- THE SERVICES CAN BE
MORE ON DEMAND.
HAVE YOU MADE AN ATTEMPT TO
ACCESS THE PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDING THROUGH THE COUNTY
PROCESS WE NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE --
WE WE HAVE I WOULD SAY WE HAVE
NOT.
AND THEN LET ME I DON'T WANT TO
CUT THIS DISCUSSION UP BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S VALUABLE BUT I ALSO
WANT.
TO THROW ANOTHER QUESTION IN MY
COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS.
PERSONS IS THE MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS THAT UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES -- SCHOOL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN CONFIRM CAN
I ASSUME COUNTY OFFICES CAN
FOLLOW TO RECOUP SOME OF THE
COST OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
HAVE YOU ATTEMPTED THAT AND HAVE
THERE BEEN CHALLENGES IN DOING
SO YES AND YES.
SO OUR NORMAL SCHOOL COUNSELORS
HAVE A P. P. S. C. CREDENTIALED
PEOPLE PERSONAL SERVICES
CREDENTIAL.
THEY CANNOT BILL FOR MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT IN THEIR ROLE.
AND AND THIS IS I'M BEING I'M
BEING TOLD THIS BY I JUST MET
WITH ALL OF MY FOLKS BEFORE.
YOU KNOW ARRIVING HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THEY'RE
THEY'RE SUGGESTING IS SOME SORT
OF A STATUTORY CHANGE THAT WILL
ALLOW THEM TO BILL FOR DIRECT
MEDI CAL SERVICES AS A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR.
NOW OUR MENTAL HEALTH THERAPISTS
ARE SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST THEY CAN
BUILD DIRECTLY.
AND I I THAT THAT TO ME IS IS
SOMETHING THAT THERE MAY BE A
GAP -- FOR AND AND I THINK THIS
IS WHAT YOU ALSO ALLUDED TO THAT
THERE'S THERE'S DIFFERENT.
LICENSING.
AND CREDENTIALING AND WHAT THE
LICENSING AND CREDENTIALED STAFF
CAN DO AND BILL FOR IS NOT IN
COHERENCE WITH ONE ANOTHER.
WHICH DOESN'T NECESSARILY
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENT.
I THINK IT'S VERY I MEAN I'M NOT
A EDUCATOR AND I'M NOT A
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS CERTAINLY
NOT A MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
THE THAT THE CORE OF ALL THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE SOME.
POINT OF CONTACT ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS WHO CAN AT LEAST DO THE
INITIAL -- WHO CONTACT TRIAGE
AND IN APPROPRIATE CASES MOVE
THIS IF THE STUDENT IS AN
EXTREME SITUATION MOVE THEM TO A
CLINICAL SETTING BUT IF NOT?
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS THAT WE THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE NOTES -- THAT
WERE PRESENTED IN THIS HANDOUT I
THINK THAT'S WHY THIS PROJECT
WAS SO PER PERFECT TO FALL
UNDERNEATH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACT TRIAGE DOLLARS.
THE OTHER PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP DISTRICTS
UNDERSTAND AND LEARN OURSELVES
AND IMPROVE IN THIS PROCESS.
IS THE IDEA OF RATED OR BLENDED
FUND.
SO WHILE CERTAIN STAFF CAN'T YOU
KNOW THE THE LAW REQUIRES
CERTAIN TYPES OF STAFF TO DO
CERTAIN TYPES OF FELL IN THE
NEXT SATURDAY IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED LAW ONE THING WE CAN
DO IS MAKE.
THOSE ROLES LESS COMPLICATED.
YEAH UNTIL THEN HOW DO WE
SUPPORT DISTRICTS AND UNDERSTAND
AND ABRADED FUND AND MODEL.
WHERE EVERYBODY CAN BRING THEIR
FUNDING SOURCES TO TO THE TABLE
PLASTERS THERE ON HAT IN SOME
DEGREE I THINK MONTEREY COUNTY
IS ALSO AND EXCELLENT EXAMPLE?
WITH A AMY MILLER HER LEADERSHIP
THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKING
WITH ACCOUNTING OFFICE TO LOOK
AT HOWEVER HOW CAN WE SPEND
THESE DOLLARS.
HOW CAN WE PUSH THEM INTO?
GATHERS SO WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER
LC -- FAST MEDI CAL EDUCATION MA
RELATED MEDICO OPTIONS TOGETHER.
TO MAYBE IN A NOT SHOW AND I
KNOW YOU'VE COVERED THIS BUT HOW
IS IT THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
RELATIVELY SUCCESSFUL IF NOT
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
IN TAPPING INTO THE MIDDLE OF
SERVICES ACT PROP.
SIXTY THREE MONEY IS A BECAUSE
YOU SAID ON THE LOCAL BOARD.
PARTLY YES SO IN PLASTER COUNTY
WE HAVE A MONTHLY.
MEET AND A LOOK AT OUR OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
COUNTY IT'S COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE ME THEN.
THAT COLLABORATIVE DRIVE SOME OF
THE DECISION MAKING AROUND OR
MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS.
ALSO I THINK BECAUSE WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM.
PRIOR TO EDUCATION I USED TO BE
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR OUR
SYSTEM OF CARE BEFORE MOVING TO
THE COUNTY OFFICE.
SO THE IDEA OF HAVE AND I
SYSTEMS OF CARE MODEL.
NOT AT THE COUNTY LEVEL OR THAT
COLLABORATION EVEN AT THE STATE
LEVEL BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS COULD
RESOLVE SOME OF THE FUNDING
NEEDS AND AND BARRIERS AT ARMS
PLACE.
OVER THAT COLLABORATION DOWN TO
REGION ALL AND COUNTY LEVELS
WHERE WE ME.
EVERY OTHER WEDNESDAY AS I
COUNTY LEADERSHIP GROUP TO LOOK
AT ALL KINDS OF CHALLENGES FOR
PLASTER COUNTY FROM CHILD
WELFARE TO MENTAL HEALTH.
THE FUNDING CHALLENGES PROBATION.
OUR PROBATION DEPARTMENT FUNDS A
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL THIRTY
DAY.
CRISIS CENTER OUT OF PREVENTION
DAHLE.
WHICH I THINK IS PRETTY UNHEARD
OF AS WELL.
SO THE IDEA OF OF BRING AND YOU
PEOPLE USE THE METAPHOR OF YOUR
YOUR TOYS TO THE SANDBOX OR
PUTTING YOUR MONEY ALL THE MONEY
ON THE TABLE AND YOUR HANDS
BEHIND YOUR BACK AND HOW CAN WE
SERVE OUR KIDS.
IN A MORE -- LEADERSHIP MODEL OR
DO LEADERSHIP DRIVEN MODEL -- IT
TAKES SOME COURAGE FROM PEOPLE
LIKE -- OUR DEPARTMENT HAS OR
MONTEREY OR THE DESERT ITSELF I
THINK IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW
THEY'VE USED.
FUND AND STRATEGIES.
TO BILL MEDI CAL THROUGH THE
SOUTH.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE THE THE
EFFORT NEEDS TO START AT THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
AROUND THE STATE AND I IMAGINE
IT'S PRETTY DIFFICULT FOR ONE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OUT OF A BUNCH.
TO GET FIGHT THE WAY TO THE
TABLE AND STICK A HAND IN THE
BUCKET GRAVEL BUNCH OF MONEY.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO DRIVE.
BEST PRACTICES FROM -- ONE COE
TO OTHERS AROUND THE STATE SO
THAT WE HAVE A SOMEWHAT.
RECOGNIZING THEIR DIFFERENCES
WHAT'S YOUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PARTNERS THERE WITH YOUR TO
DRIVE DOWN JACK LEE.
EXACTLY.
THANK YOU SORRY THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE NO PROBLEM YOU HAD LOTS
OF INTERESTING THINGS TO SAY
RICHARD.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
IMPORTANT I THINK THIS IS FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS I DID READ
THROUGH ALL OF THE COMMENTS.
TIMES ARE SO DIFFERENT NOW THAN
WHEN HE MADE ANY OF US WENT TO
SCHOOL AND I THINK THAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND OUR CHILDREN
ARE LIVING IN SITUATIONS.
THAT NONE OF US CAN ALWAYS
IMAGINE SO I THINK THIS THIS IS
HELPFUL FOR A COUPLE REASONS.
ONE EVEN OUR TEACHERS PROBABLY
DON'T UNDERSTAND EXACTLY BECOME
RATED TEACH EVERY DAY AND RAY TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE DOING WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO.
BUT THEY MAY NOT REALIZE FULLY
WITH THEIR STUDENTS ARE LIVING
AT HOME.
BUT I ALSO THINK THIS IS A GOOD
AVENUE FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO START EXPRESSING THEMSELVES
AND MAY BE STARTING TO REALIZE
THAT BY EXPRESSING WHAT'S GOING
ON THEY CAN ACTUALLY ASK FOR
HELP.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
AND I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THINGS LIKE THIS.
SECONDLY -- YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY
A BIT -- SUBMIT THAT.
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS ON
CAMPUS IS REALLY AN EUITY ISSUE.
IF WE HAVE.
SCHOOL DISTRICT ALL DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS BASED ON HOW
THEY SPEND THEIR EL CAP BASED ON
IF THEY CAN PULL DOWN MONEY FROM
PROP.
SIXTY THREE I WOULD SAY -- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE REALLY DOESN'T
WANT TO HEAR THIS BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING AS A STATE
TO MAKE SURE EVERY CAMPUS IN
EVERY SCHOOL.
ARE IN EVERY DISTRICT HAS A
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T DO THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I FEEL LIKE
THAT WE JUST HAVE THIS PATCHWORK
THAT WE KEEP DOING AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT ONE SCHOOL OVER HERE
OR SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU'RE WHO
SAYS.
THIS IS OUR PRIORITY SO THESE
KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO IT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SAYS WELL THIS
IS OUR PRIORITY BUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THOSE KIDS SO.
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR WHAT ALL
OF YOU WERE DOING BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO DO MORE AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
THIS EQUITY ISSUES ADDRESS FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS I THINK IT'S
ESPECIALLY SO WITH A VERY SMALL
ROOM GET DISTRICTS BECAUSE IT.
ISN'T IT IT YOU KNOW HAVING
RELATIONSHIPS IS VERY IMPORTANT
SO THAT YOU CAN GET SOME OF
THOSE SERVICES BUT ALSO THE
GEOGRAPHICAL DISTANCE WHERE.
YOU MAY HAVE THE FUNDING SOURCES
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THE HUMAN
RESOURCES THE PERSON THAT WILL
COME OUT AND WE LIVE IT EVEN
TALKED WHEN I TALK TO THE WELL.
WEBSITE HEALTH CARE DISTRICT WE
EVEN TALKED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF TELEMEDICINE YOU
KNOW WHERE IS A STUDENT WOULD
CALL IN AND THEY'RE TALKING TO A
PROFESSIONAL BECAUSE THE PROBLEM
FOR US TONIGHT I THINK WE WOULD
ALL SAY THIS IS.
WE ARE NOT MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WE'RE NOT AND SO
WHEN A STUDENT WHO IS IN CRISIS
COMES TO US WE ARE DOING THE
ABSOLUTE BEST THAT WE CAN AND
WE'RE MAKING DECISIONS AND
TRYING TO CONNECT THEM.
TO SOMETIMES STRUCTURES THAT
DON'T YET EXIST RIGHT AND SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AS
WE THINK OF THE MANY SMALL RURAL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE OUT THERE IS
HOW DO WE SUPPORT.
THEM AND MAKE THAT POSSIBLE FOR
THEIR STUDENTS WHERE IT'S NOT
BASED ON GEOGRAPHY.
TOTALLY AGREE I THINK WE NEED TO
USE ALL THE TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX
AND IF TELEHEALTH TELEMEDICINE
IF THAT WORKS BETTER.
IT'S A EIGHT A GREAT THING TO
USE I'M ALWAYS A FAN OF SOMEONE
LOOKING SOMEONE IN THE EYE AND
BEING RIGHT THERE.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK THAT WAY
SO THAT TO BE CREATIVE -- BUT I
JUST THINK THAT WE CAN DO BETTER
BY OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THEY REALLY
ARE.
WE NEED TO PUT THE MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS THANK GOODNESS AND
I THINK YOU KNOW WE WE AS
DISTRICTS I MEAN WE HAVE
DISTRICT PSYCHOLOGISTS BUT ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES WITH THEIR
ROLE.
IS OFTENTIMES THEY'RE DOING THE
EDUCATIONALIST SUSSMAN'S FOR THE
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION UP
PLANS.
AND THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT RIGHT THEY
HAVE TO DO THAT THEIR SPECIFIC
TIME LINES.
IS OFTEN TIMES YOU KNOW THE THE
PERSON WHO'S KIND OF VIEWING
FROM THE OUTSIDE OF THE SYSTEM
MIGHT SAY WELL THEY HAVE A
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST.
WITH THE ROLE THAT THEY'RE IAN
WE WE REALLY NEED -- THE
PROFESSIONALS WHO CAN FOCUS ON
PROVIDING THE THERAPEUTIC MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO THAT'S THEIR SPECIALTY
AND AND TO MAKE THOSE SERVICES
AVAILABLE ON DEMAND AND IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY.
SO THAT WE'RE GEARING TEAM.
THAT EVERY STUDENT WHO NEEDS IT
HAS ACCESS.
AND AND BY THE WAY THE FAMILY
THAT'S ATTACHED TO THAT STUDENT.
NUMBER DIFFERENT. TO THE HAS
DIFFERENT SKILLS ALWAYS IN.
AND I AGREE I HAVE A COUPLE
FRIENDS WHO ARE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND THEY SPEND
ABOUT 80% OF THEIR TIME TO THE
I. E. PEAS AND THE PAPERWORK
WHICH IS GREAT IT'S MANDATED
THAT'S OUR JOB.
BUT TO ONLY HAVE 20% OF THEIR
TIME LEFT OVER TO ACTUALLY
COUNSEL AND MAYBE THEY CAN DO
THAT THEY CAN DO THE I EP IS A
WHAT NOT AND WE HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER IT'S RIGHT THERE
WITH THEM IS COMING AND I JUST I
WANTED THIS OUT.
I WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE I GOT
THIS RIGHT BECAUSE MY FOLKS BACK
HOME I WOULD JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M I'M GIVING.
SO THAT THE ONE RECOMMENDATION
IS ALLOW SCHOOL BASED THERAPIST
WITH OUT A PUPIL PERSONNEL
SERVICES CREDENTIAL. TO MEDI CAL
BILL.
AND SO I THINK I HAD IT REVERSED
IN THE FIRST TIME I PRESENTED IT
SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
CORRECTION.
WE'RE WORKING ON SO ACCESS
SUPERINTENDENT WHILE I HAVE YOU.
HAVE YOU DONE A CALCULATION. TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH ADDITIONAL.
OF FUNDING YOU WOULD NEED IN
ORDER TO STAFF YOUR THE SCHOOLS
WITHIN YOUR DISTRICT
APPROPRIATELY FOR PURPOSES OF
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO YOUR STUDENT POPULATION.
I HAVE NOT QUANTIFIED THAT I
COULD BE INTERESTING I COULD DO
THAT AND I'D BE HAPPY TO GET
THAT TO POLICE.
INTERESTING TO KNOW WHAT THE DEL
IS YES.
AND DOCTOR HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE --
TO THROUGH YOUR COUNTY OFFICE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS PROP SIXTY
THREE FUNDING FOR WE HAVE NOT WE
HAVE NOT.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT.
DOESN'T WITH MY KNOCKING ON THAT
DOOR AS A SURPRISE ME WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE TWO
EXAMPLES WHERE IT TO FIGURE THIS
OUT -- AT SOME POINT
[inaudible]
ANYTHING ELSE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I'VE
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING.
MORE OF IT THIS IS A VERY HIGH
PRIORITY FOR OF MEMBERS OF THE
OF OUR CAUCUS IN THE SENATE.
WE INTEND TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IT THIS YEAR AND IN THE YEARS IN
THE FUTURE IN PARTICULAR TO TRY
TO FIX THE REGULATORY ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH.
MEDI CAL BILLING.
OUTSTANDING THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS CHAIRMAN.
GET THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM SIXTY
THREE SIXTY COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING BUDGET PROPOSALS.
WE HAVE A PANEL
.
OKAY IF I COULD -- THIS YOU ALL
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELVES STARTING
TO MY LEFT YOU ARE RIGHT NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY LEAHY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS MERRY VECSEY SANDY ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
WE SHOP ROLE WITH THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF MINISTRY TO SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
HE MERELY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM -- GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN MY NAME IS KIMBERLY LET
HIM WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOW BE BRIEF BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZE THAT DOCTOR SANDY HAS
A SHORT TIME COMMIT OR HAS A
NEAR TIME COMMITMENT. FOR AN
AIRPLANE -- SO WHETHER YOU'RE
HERE.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES -- TWENTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN TEACHER
CREDENTIALS FUND. FIVE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS TEST
DEVELOPMENT A AND ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNT FUNDS AND FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR A TOTAL
OPERATING BUDGET.
OF TWENTY NINE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS THIS FUNDING SUPPORTS
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS. FOR THE
COMMISSION STATE OPERATIONS
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES TWO MILLION ONE TIME
TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT FUNDS.
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT -- EXCUSE ME
OVER TWO YEARS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHT TEACHER
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION CREDENTIAL
CANDIDATES.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES -- ONE
ONGOING POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
TEACHER PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS.
IN ADDITION THERE'S A ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENTS IS PROPOSED FOR
THE COMMISSION TO UTILIZE
FUNDING PROVIDED BY SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY. FOR AS PART OF
THE THIRD AND FINAL YEAR AWARDED
BY THE WALL AS A FOUNDATION TO
SUPPORT ONGOING WORK.
ON THE IT -- CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATOR PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT INCLUDING A FIELD
WORKSHOPS AND THREE SMALLER
STATEWIDE MEETINGS.
AND FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO UPDATE THE EXISTING
STATUTE GOVERNING TEACHER MISSUS
I MET MONITORING.
THESE CHANGES WOULD REFLECT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PERFORMANCE INDEX.
THE ELIMINATION OF THE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED TEACHER REQUIREMENT
THE FEDERAL NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND
ACT.
AND THE IT WOULD INCORPORATE THE
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENT OF
THE FEDERAL EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACT IN ADDITION IT
WOULD ADD CHARTERS TO THE
ASSIGNMENT MONITORING FOR
CHARTER CORE COURSES -- IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER THEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT THE
COMMISSION'S BUDGET.
ARE WE HAVE THREE PRIMARY
FUNCTIONS OF THE COMMISSION
FIRST IS THAT WE SET STANDARDS
FOR THE PREPARATION OF THE
EDUCATIONAL WORKFORCE.
WE ARE CREDIT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ENTITIES THAT PREPARE
THAT WORK FORCE.
WE ISSUE CREDENTIALS TO PEOPLE
WHO EARN THEM AND ARE QUALIFIED
FOR THEM.
AND WE ENGAGE AN EDUCATOR
DISCIPLINE ARE WHEN THERE ARE
CASES OF MISCONDUCT.
ON THE LAST EIGHT YEARS WE'VE
HAD THE GREAT GOOD PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH DR LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND AS OUR CHAIR.
SHE OF COURSE IS MOVED TO THE
STATE BOARD OF PRESIDENCY AND WE
HAVE A NEW CHAIR OF OF THE
COMMISSION.
DR TINA SLOAN FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA.
US SO THAT'S A BIG SHIFT FOR US --
BUT ALL ALL FOR THE GOOD OF THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF OVERHAULING OF WORK
BRINGING ALL OF OUR STANDARDS
FOR TEACHERS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATORS FOR ADMINISTRATORS.
FOR SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKERS TO PERTINENT TO YOUR
LAST PANEL.
UP TO DATE -- WE'VE ADOPTED NEW
STANDARDS FOR ALL OF THOSE TYPES
OF EDUCATORS WHICH HAS BEEN
IMPORTANT WORK BRINGING THAT
INTO ALIGNMENT.
WITH THE STATE'S -- EXPECTATIONS
FOR SERVICE TO STUDENTS -- WE'VE
ALSO DEVELOP PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENTS FOR TEACHERS AND FOR
ADMINISTRATORS WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK.
ON A SPECIAL EDUCATION FORM OF
THAT WE'VE OVER HOLDER
ACCREDITATION SYSTEM AND WE'VE
BEEN PLEASED TO SERVE -- AS THE
VEHICLE FOR GETTING A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GRANT FUNDING OUT TO LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO SUPPORT
TEACHER SHORTAGES SO.
I KNOW THAT'S A TOPIC FOR A
SECOND PANEL THAT I'D LOVE TO BE
PARTOF LET ME JUST WRAP UP BY
YOU SAYING WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
ANYWAY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION I TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT.
SO YOU SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
HANDOUT THAT I'LL BE SPEAKING
FROM DURING MY PRESENTATION THIS
AFTERNOON.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS WHETHER
TO ADOPT A NEW ASSESSMENT
INTENDED TO MEASURE WHETHER
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE PREPARED
TO ENTER THE CLASSROOM.
THIS ASSESSMENT IS KNOWN AS THE
TEACHING PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
OR THE DPA.
THE STARTING ON PAGE ONE BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND THE TP A IS A
PORTFOLIO BASED EXERCISE THAT
ASKS PERSPECTIVE TEACHERS TO
DEMONSTRATE THE SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE EXPECTED OF BEGINNING
TEACHERS.
THESE TASKS MAY INCLUDE
PREPARING LESSON PLANS ASSESSING
STUDENT LEARNING AND REFLECTING
ON PASS INSTRUCTION ASSESSMENT
IS INTEGRATED INTO THE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS AND SO
PERSPECTIVE TEACHERS COMPLETE
THE T. PAY.
ALONGSIDE THEIR COURSE WORK.
AND THEN THE PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS SUBMITS A PORTFOLIO OF
WRITTEN AND VIDEO RECORDED WORK
FOR AN INDEPENDENT ASSESSOR TO
THEN SCORE.
THE STATE HAS REQUIRED GENERAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS TO PASS
EIGHTY P. A TOP TEN THEIR
TEACHING CREDENTIALS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE ORIGINALLY INTENDED
THIS TO IMPROVE TEACHER
PREPARATION.
BY -- STANDARDIZING AND BY
ESTABLISHING CONSISTENCY IN
TEACHING ASSESSMENT.
CREATION PROGRAMS.
NOW IN CONTRAST TO GENERAL
EDUCATE.
STATUTES SEIZE SILENT ON WHETHER
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE
REQUIRED TO TAKE A TP A TOP TEAM
THE CREDENTIAL.
RATHER STATUE GIVE CDC THE BROAD
DISCRETION OVER ASSESSMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND CURRENTLY
CTC DOES NOT REQUIRE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS TO PASS.
YEAH.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.
HERE WE DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR.
BUDGET PROVIDES ONE POINT TWO
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE CCC TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
EIGHTY K. FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THIS FUNDING WOULD COME FROM THE
TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT THIS IS A
SPECIAL FUNDS THAT COLLECTS
REVENUES FROM FEES PAID.
BY PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS WHEN
THEY TAKE THE STATE REQUIRED
ASSESSMENTS.
CDC ESTIMATES THE TOTAL COST TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TO PA TO BE
TWO MILLION AND INTENSE ACROSS
THE REMAINING OF OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
CDC ANTICIPATES A FOR YOUR
TIMELINE TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER HEY.
THIS YEAR C. D. C. WOULD ENTER
INTO A CONTRACT WITH A TEST
DEVELOPER TO START DEVELOPMENT
THEN THE NEXT TWO YEARS SPELL
START PILING THE TASK TO THEIR
FIELD TESTS.
AND THEN BEGINNING TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND USE A NEW --
NEW SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
WITH THEM YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
TAKE THE CPA TYPE TEAM OR
TEACHING CREDENTIAL.
AND CDC INTENSE THE COST OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION GPA TO BE
COMPARABLE TO THE EXISTING DPA
TO BE A WHICH IS CURRENTLY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TEST TAKER.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND ON GOING FROM THE
TEST DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNT FOR ONE
NEW FULL TIME POSITION TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION PTA.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.
WE BELIEVE THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TO PA COMES WITH SOME STRENGTHS
AND LIMITATIONS WE'LL START WITH
A PROPOSAL STRENGTH.
FIRST A SPECIAL EDUCATION TP A
COULD BETTER PREPARE NEW
TEACHERS TO ENTER THE CLASSROOM
BY ASSESSING WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE EXPECTED.
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS TO PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION TO STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS THIS MAY INCLUDES.
MANAGING CASES AND HER PARENTS
ABOUT VISUALIZE -- EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
ALTHOUGH THE EXISTING RESEARCH
IS LIMITED WE DID FIND THREE
STUDIES THAT JENNER ART THAT
WERE GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE.
OF THE CONNECTION BETWEEN HOW IT
TEACHER PERFORMS ANA TKA AND
ASSOCIATED IMPROVEMENTS IN
STUDENT ACADEMIC OUTCOMES.
SECOND EIGHTY PA COULD IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
CITY SEE INTENDS TO ANALYZE THE
RESULTS FROM THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION T. PA AND AND USE THAT
INFORMATION TO INFORM WHETHER OR
NOT TO IMPROVE PREPARATION
PROGRAMS.
WHETHER TO APPROVE THEM DURING
THAT CREATION PROCESS.
THIS DATA ANALYSIS WOULD ALSO
HELP CDC IDENTIFY THE RELATIVE
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES OF EACH
PROBE.
LASTLY WE CONSIDER THE PROJECT
COST AND FUN SOURCE TO BE
REASONABLE.
CITY SEIZE COST ESTIMATE FOR THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION T. PAY
REFLECTS SOME SAVINGS FROM THE
RE PURPOSING OF COMPONENTS OF
THE GENERAL EDUCATION GPA.
IN OTHER WORDS CITY SEE WOULD
NOT BE STARTING FROM SCRATCH
WHEN DEVELOPING THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TVA.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSED FUND
SOURCE IS IF THE CIVIC WE
INTENDED FOR THE DEVELOPMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION OF TAX.
THE SPECIAL FUND HAS BEEN
GROWING IN THE RECENT YEARS AND
IS LIKELY ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL'S.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.
HERE WE DISCUSS TO POTENTIAL
DOWNSIDES WITH THE PROPOSAL'S.
FIRST WHEN WE SPOKE TO GENERAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS WHO COMPLETED
THE EXISTING T. PA.
WE CONSIDER THE T. PAY TO BE A
RATHER TIME INTENSIVE EXERCISE.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF TIME IT TOOK RELATIVE
TO HOW HELPFUL THEY FOUND IT AS
A PREPARATION TOOL AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO OTHER
COMPONENTS OF TEACHING
PREPARATION SUCH AS COURSE WORK.
AND STUDENT TEACHING.
LASTLY WE ARE UNCERTAIN ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT THAT A
SPECIAL EDUCATION T. PAY MIGHT
HAVE ON TEACHER SUPPLY.
AS YOU KNOW THE STATE FACES A
CHRONIC SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS WHICH WILL
SPEAK MORE ABOUT IN THE NEXT
PANEL.
BUT TO MEET THE DEMANDS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS RSORT TO YOU
OUR STATE RECRUITMENT OR HIRE
STAFF WHO DO NOT MEET ALL
CREDENTIAL REQUIREMENTS.
IN NEW TO PAY REQUIREMENT WHAT
OUT OF WORK AND COST TO THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER.
ALTHOUGH THE ADDITION OF A T. PA
MIGHT SEEM MODEST IN THE CONTEXT
OF ALL THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS WE
HAVE FOR NEW TEACHERS.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT SOME OF THE
SOME OF THIS SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS COULD AFFECT THE
NUMBER OF PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN AND
ULTIMATELY UP TINA SPECIAL
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL.
MOVING ON TO THE LAST PAGE.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO FUND THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TO PA AND AT
ONE NEW POSITION TO CDC.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE SOME
TRADE OFFS BUT ON BALANCE WE
THINK THE PROPOSAL'S COULD HELP
IMPROVE TEACHER PREPARATION AND
BRING SPECIAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS IN LINE WITH THE
ONES THAT THE STATE HAS FOR
GENERAL EDUCATION.
HOWEVER WE RECOMMENDS THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CDC TO
ASSESS AND REPORT HOW THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION T. PA WHAT MAY
AFFECT TEACHER SUPPLY BY JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICH IS WHEN
THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
CDC COULD COLLECT INFORMATION
DURING THE PILOT PHASE OF
IMPLEMENTATION REGARDING QUAN%
HOW THE T. PAY IS AFFECTING
INTEREST IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS. TO
HOW MUCH TIME IT TAKES TO
COMPLETE THE DPA AND HOW THIS
AFFECTS THE OVERALL WORKLOAD.
AND THREE WHAT PERSPECTIVE
TEACHERS CONSIDER THE ADDED
VALUE OF THE T. PAY AND BETTER
PREPARING THEM FOR THE CLASSROOM.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN THEN USE
THIS INFORMATION TO EVALUATE
WHETHER A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACH PA COULD AFFECT INTEREST
WORKLOAD AND COMPLETION RATES IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
LASTLY IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE T. P.
AND STUDENT OUTCOMES WERE
GENERALLY IT COULD FIND AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION.
THIS WOULD HELP INFORM WHETHER
REQUIRING GENERAL AND IN SPECIAL
ED TEACHERS TAKE A GPA ACHIEVES
THE ACTUAL GOALS OF IMPROVING
TEACHER PREPARATION AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
WELL JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS --
YOU KNOW IT OCCURS TO ME THAT IF
THE TP A IS.
AS VALUE FOR GENERAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS I DON'T KNOW WHY WE
WOULDN'T DO WITH DOING THAT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS --
BUT I THINK THE OVERRIDING
QUESTION WHICH MAYBE IS YET TO
BE ANSWERED.
IS GIVEN THE TEACHER RECRUITING
ISSUES.
GIVEN THE SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY VALUE
ASSESSMENT OF THE T. P. A. IN
GENERAL WITH RESPECT SPEC TO THE
GENERAL.
EDUCATION.
TEACHER POPULATION.
OF AND HAS THAT WHEN WAS THAT
ASSESSMENT AND WHAT WERE THE
RESULTS AND IF NOT.
PERHAPS IN ADDITION TO DOING THE
ASSESSMENT.
FOR OF THE SPECIAL ED -- SEGMENT
IS THAT THIS RULES OUT MAYBE THE
ASSESSMENT SHOULD BE APPLIED TO
THE GENERAL CHECK.
POPULATIONS WELL DR I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER OF THOSE QUESTIONS SO
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
TEACHING PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS
FOR THE GENERAL POPULATION. FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS.
ARMS AND SO WE'VE LEARNED A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS
AND AND HOW THEY BEST SUPPORT
AND STRENGTH IN THE PREPARATION.
OF TEACHERS WITHOUT OVER
BURDENING THEM WITH MEANINGLESS
TASKS THIS IS NOT YOUR AVERAGE
TEST WHAT WITH THIS ASSESSMENT
DOES IS IT IT ORGANIZES THEIR
STUDENT TEACHING EXPERIENCE WITH
SOME VERY SPECIFIC CONCRETE
TASKS AROUND PLANNING
INSTRUCTION.
ADAPTING INSTRUCTION TO THE
LEARNERS THEIR TEACHING
ASSESSING INSTRUCTION
DETERMINING WHO'S LEARNING WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO NEXT INSTRUCTION
ONLY IT'S VERY DEEPLY.
AND IT OCCURS COMPLETELY WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF STUDENT TEACHING
SO IT'S NOT AN ADDED REQUIREMENT
IT IS AN ORGANIZER IF YOU WILL
OR THAT PART OF THE EXPERIENCE.
WE HAVE NOT FOUND THAT IT IS A
HINDRANCE TO RECRUITMENT IN THE
JANET SPACE -- AND WE'RE NOT
EXPECTING IT TO BE IN THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION -- WORLD
EITHER.
ESSENTIALLY IT'S OUR IT'S OUR
EXPERIENCE THAT WHEN CANDIDATES
APPLY TO ENTER INTO TEACHER
PREPARATION REGARDLESS OF THE
CREDENTIAL THEY'RE SEEKING.
ACCEPT THE CONDITIONS OF THAT
PREPARATION.
AND THEY THEY AREN'T
PARTICULARLY DISCRIMINATING AT
THE POINT OF APPLICATION SHOULD
I GO IN SHOULD I NOT GO IN --
THERE'S A BIG TEST I MIGHT NOT
THAT'S NOT WITH THINKING THEY'RE
THINKING I'D LIKE TO BE A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER WHERE'S THE
BEST PLACE FOR ME TO GO AND HOW
DO I GET THIS DONE AND IT OCCURS
WITHIN THE IN THE IN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THEIR STUDENT
TEACHER.
THAT'S CORRECT AND AND WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE AFTER YOU TAKE
YOUR TP A IS -- IS -- FEEDBACK
IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED YES SO
IT'S USED AS A TOOL TO THEN
PROVIDE FEEDBACK TO THE TO THE
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO AND WHAT THEY NEED TO
BETTER MULTI FACETED FEEDBACK.
THE THE ASSESSMENTS AS WE'VE
DESIGNED OF THEM NOW HAVE.
OF DIAGNOSTIC RUBRICS WHERE THEY
GET FEEDBACK ON IT FOR JANET
TEACHERS I THINK IT'S EIGHTEEN
OR SO DIFFERENT DIMENSIONS OF
THEIR TEACHING.
THEY GET A SPECIFIC SCORE -- AND
ITS USE THEY USE THOSE THAT
FEEDBACK TO DESIGN THEIR
INDIVIDUALIZED INDUCTION PLANS
WHEN THEY BEGIN EMPLOYMENT THEY
GO INTO AN INDUCTION PROGRAM.
SO THIS BECOMES AWARE WERE MY
STRINGS WERE MY WEAKNESSES HOW
WHAT'S NEXT FOR ME AND
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS ITS
FORMATIVE IN THAT WAY.
BUT IT ALSO IS THE ACCREDITING
BODY TELLS US A LOT ABOUT HOW
PREPARATION IS WORKING IF ALL OF
THE CANDIDATES ARE STRUGGLING
WITH LET'S SAY ADOPTING
INSTRUCTION TO SPECIAL ED KIDS.
THEN WE KNOW WHAT TO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR WHEN WE GO IN AND A
CREDIT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO SEE
WHAT PATTERNS OF PERFORMANCE
LOOK LIKE AND IT'S EXTREMELY
HELPFUL IN THAT REGARD -- SO WE
USE IT FOR ACCREDITATION
PURPOSES FAQ MULTI IN THESE
PROGRAMS USE IT SO THEY CAN
GAUGE WHERE ARE WE HITTING THE
MARK WHERE WE MISSING IT WITH
OUR CANDIDATES WHERE DO WE NEED
TO STRENGTHEN.
SO THIS IS A TOOL THAT GIVES US
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT ACROSS
ALL SECTORS STATE PROGRAM AND
CANDIDATE.
SO EXCELLENT EXCELLENT RESPONSE
THANK YOU.
ANYTHING FURTHER.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
WE WILL BE REVISITING AT NEXT
WEEK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABSOLUTE YOU
MAKE YOUR FLIGHT RIGHTWELL I
THINK I'M GONNA STAY FOR THE
NEXT PANEL BERMAN NAY.
BUT PLEASE FORGIVE ME IF I DO
HAVE TO LEAVE IF THIS GOES
LONGER THAN I FIGHT MY COLLEAGUE
MICHELLE PAROLED WILL TAKE OVER
FOR ME.
WE APPRECIATE YOU STAYING AS
LONG AS YOU CAN YOU CAN.
SO SO YOU'RE ASKED TO QUESTIONS
IN THIS REPORT WE'VE HAD WE'VE
HAD CHRONIC TEACHER SHORTAGES
FOLLOWING A PERIOD OF TIME WHEN
WE LAID OFF TEACHERS.
AND HAD OF A SURPLUS AND THAT
WAS DUE TO ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
OF WE VERY QUICKLY AS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY OCCURRED SHORTAGES
ACROSS THE STATE BEGAN TO OCCUR
I WOULD SAY THAT IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION SHORTAGES WERE CHRONIC
AND OF MAINTAINED EVEN THROUGH
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
THE NEED FOR SPECIAL ED TEACHERS
HAS BEEN GREAT AS WAS STEM IN
OTHER FIELDS.
ON SO IN RECENT YEARS THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDED THROUGH A SERIES OF
PROGRAMS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN GRANT FUNDING TO RECRUIT
PREPARE OR PLACE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND OTHER
TEACHERS.
ARE.
AND THAT'S WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
THAT AFFECTING THE LIKE THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS TO TAKE TO FULLY ROLL
THIS OUT AND SEE WHAT THE YIELD
WILL BE FROM THAT INVESTMENT.
SO ONE AND I THINK WE HAD A
HANDOUT THAT YOU PROBABLY HAVE.
A YOU MAY HAVE AND IN FRONT OF
YOU.
YES THAT WOULD BE IT -- SO IN A
WALK YOU QUICKLY THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS THE FIRST PROGRAM I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
CLASSIFIED TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM
THIS IS A GRANT TO RECRUIT
CLASSIFIED STAFF IN THE SCHOOLS.
WHO HAVE AT LEAST IN A A LEVEL
OF OF A DEGREE ATTAINMENT TO
COMPLETE A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
IN A CREDENTIAL -- THAT'S BEEN A
VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM FOR US
WE'VE SEEN FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS INVESTED IN IT OVER TWO
CYCLES.
OF THE FIRST COHORT OF A
THOUSAND CLASSIFIED STAFF --
WERE FUNDED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND FIFTY OF THEM
HOWEVER AND THEIR CREDENTIAL
THEY HAD A LOT OF THEIR COURSE
RECORDED COMPLETED THEIR THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT IF YOU WILL.
OF THE SECOND COHORT WAS FUNDED
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FIVE OF THEM HAVE EARNED THEIR
CREDENTIALS IN THEIR TWELVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CANDIDATES IN
THAT POOL.
SO THIS PROGRAM IS JUST STARTING --
TO TO GET GROUNDING AND MAKE
MAKE -- MAKE TRACTION FOR US A
BIT OVER THE OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS WE EXPECT TO SEE
AT LEAST FIVE THOUSAND TEACHERS
COME THROUGH -- NO IT'S NOT
THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
TEACHERS COME THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM AND GET CREDENTIALED.
WITH INTEGRATED PROGRAMS THIS
WAS SAID THIS IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION TO CREATE NEW.
UNDERGRADUATE COMPLETE A BULL
PROGRAMS WERE TEACHER COULD GET
pIN FOUR YEARS THEY'RE GOING FOR
SPECIAL LET IT WOULD BE FOUR AND
A HALF YEARS.
SO THESE GRANTS WERE FOR TWO
YEARS FOR PROGRAMS TO DESIGN
THIS THIS POT THIS PATHWAY.
THEY'VE BEGUN IN ROLLING A
CANDIDATES JUST THIS YEAR -- IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE HAD TWENTY
SEVEN PROGRAMS THAT ERE
DEVELOPED OUT OF A TOTAL OF
FORTY ONE THAT THE GRANT OF
SUPPORTED ACROSS ALL CONTENT
AREAS. FIVE HUNDRED SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS WERE ARE
PROJECTED TO BE ENROLLED THIS
YEAR AND WE WOULD EXPECT BECAUSE
THIS IS INFRASTRUCTURE
REBUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
WILL BECOME A PATHWAY.
THAT WE HOPE IS POPULAR AND
DRAWS YOUNGER FRESHMAN INTO A
PATHWAY THAT GETS THEM A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL QUICKLY AT
THE SAME TIME THAT THEY GET
THEIR DEGREES.
SOME OF US WERE SURPRISED TO
LEARN THAT.
THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN THE
TYPICALLY YOU GO YOU GO GET YOUR
FOR YOUR DEGREE.
EITHER IN AND EDUCATE AND
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION OR IN THE
SUBJECT MATTER.
AND THEN YOU GO BACK TO SCHOOL
RIGHT EITHER IN THE SAME
INSTITUTION OR SOME OTHER
INSTITUTION FOR IS IT A ONE
HELLO IS USUALLY A ONE YEAR
PROGRAM OR WHEN YOU'RE PLUS OF
SUMMER.
OR TWO SUMMERS SO WE HAVE BEEN A
POST BACCALAUREATE PREPARING
STATE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS FOR
TO FOUR THIRTY FORTY ACRES THAT
SAME ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE
ARE THAT'S IT'S IN USE THAT SO
CERTAINLY THAT IS THE WAY THE
PEOPLE GET CREDENTIALS BUT THE
EDUCATION MAJOR.
IS IN MUCH GREATER USE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THEN IT HAS BEEN IN
CALIFORNIA PARTLY BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE DISALLOWED AN
EDUCATION MAJOR IN LIKE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONLY RECENTLY
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS HAS THE
RESTRICTION AGAINST HAVING A
PROFESSED A DEGREE IN EDUCATION
BEEN LIFTED.
BY THE LEGISLATURE SO.
THIS EIGHT IT'S OPENED UP
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE ARE VERY HOPEFUL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ATTRACT
TEACHERS INTO THIS PATHWAY AND
GET THEM FOUR YEARS.
OF LEARNING THEIR CONTENT THEORY
AND BEING A STUDENT AN
UNDERGRADUATE SPACE BUT WORKING
ON THEIR CREDENTIAL AT THE SAME
TIME.
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR TOP
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S GREAT
THAT'S AN INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE.
ALL THE LOCAL SOLUTIONS GRANT
FUNDING CAME INTO OUR BUDGET
THIS YEAR THAT WAS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS SET ASIDE SPECIFICALLY
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS.
THIS WEEK WELL IT'S BASED ON THE
FUNDING FORMULA SHOULD YIELD
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TEACHERS
PLACED.
IN SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION THESE WON'T
NECESSARILY BE NEWLY
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS BECAUSE
THIS IS OUR LOCAL SOLUTION THEM
IN THE LOCAL -- ELLIE ACE HAVE
CHOICE ABOUT HOW THEY SPEND
THESE FUNDS THEY CAN DO
FORGIVABLE LOANS THEY CAN DO
HIRING INCENTIVES BUT A PERSON.
MUST HAVE A FULL CREDENTIAL WHEN
THEY'RE HIRED INTO THIS ROLE SO
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO
YIELD OVERALL TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED BRAND NEW CREDENTIAL
HOLDERS BUT IT SHOULD PLACE THEM
IN IT SHOULD PLACE THEM IN
PLACES WHERE.
WE'RE CURRENTLY SERVING STUDENTS
ON EMERGENCY PERMIT SO SPECIAL
EDUCATE ESPECIALLY DUCATION
TEACHERS -- SO THAT'S TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS THAT WE EXPECT TO SEE --
YOU PLACED BASED ON THAT GRANT.
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS CAME IN OUR
BUDGET THIS YEAR TO LAUNCH THAT
PROGRAM FIFTY MILLION OF THAT IS
DEDICATED TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
RESIDENCIES TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR STEM IN BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
RESIDENCY IS LIKE A STUDENT
TEACHING PROGRAM EXCEPT THAT THE
RESIDENT ENTERS.
OF THEIR PROGRAM AND SPENDS THE
WHOLE YEAR IN THE CLASSROOM OF
ANOTHER MASTER TEACHER SO THEY
ARE RESIDENT TO WEAR A DOCTOR IS
A RESIDENT UNDER.
UNDER ANOTHER TEACHERS ANOTHER
DOCTOR'S PRACTICE.
ON THIS IS A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM FOR BOTH PREPARING VERY
STRONG AND WELL PREPARED
TEACHERS.
AND THEY TEND THE NATIONAL DATA
INDICATE THAT TEACHERS WHO COME
THROUGH RESIDENCIES TEND TO STAY
IN TEACHING SO IT ADDRESSES BOTH
TURN.
AND GETTING FULLY PREPARED TO DO
THE SAME TIME.
ON THAT.
THIS IS FOLLOWED THIS FOLLOWS
THEN THE COMPLETION.
OF A OF TEACHER PREPARATION
PROPOSED BUCKLER TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM.
IS THE TEACHER PREPARATION TO
TEACH MIDDLE I COME OUT OF X. Y.
Z. UNIVERSITY WITH A MAJOR IN
HISTORY -- AND I GO INTO ONE OF
THESE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
THAT IS MY TEACHER PREP.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO YOU BECOME HISTORY.
CREDENTIALS THE END OF THE
SINGLE SUBJECT INSTRUMENT RADIUS
GET MULTIPLE SUBJECT SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
WE'RE THIS IS THIS IS NEW GROUND
FOR US AND SPECIAL EDUCATION TO
DO RESIDENCY STYLE PROGRAM FOR
THAT TYPE OF EDUCATOR.
BUT IT'S AN EXCITING TIME TO BE
DOING IT.
WE HAVE OF DUNN'S WE'RE DOING
SOME MAJOR THINGS WITH -- MTS
SAYS ANOTHER OTHER WAYS OF
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE DELIVER
SERVICES TO KIDS.
AND AND THIS RESIDENCY
OPPORTUNITY NOW GIVES US THE
CHANCE TO REALLY PREPARE NEXT
GENERATION.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED A SPECIAL
EDUCATOR SHOULD BE PREPARED
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS AND AT THE END
OF THAT THE GOAL IS THAT THE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM ITSELF.
ISN'T JUST SOMETHING THAT EXIST
AS LONG AS THE GRANT FUNDING IS
THERE BUT IT'S AN ONGOING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO IN ONLY A THE GETS THIS GRANT
HAS BUILT PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OTHER HIGHER ED PARTNERS.
AND DID THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES
TO EXIST AS A WAY OF BRINGING IN
IN TRAINING THEIR OWN TEACHING
WORKFORCE.
IT'S VERY EXCITING WE AWARDED
THIRTY SIX GRANTS TO ELEAZAR TO
GET THAT WORK STARTED THIS YEAR.
AND THEN THERE WAS ALSO A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME A GRANT
PROVIDED TO RE ESTABLISH A
CENTER FOR TEACHING CAREERS.
THAT FUNDING WENT TO TULARE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IT
WAS INITIALLY A THREE YEAR GRANT
THIS IS.
A WOULD HAVE BEEN THE END OF
THEIR FUNDING BUT I THINK THEY
HAD SOME OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
COME IN AND THEY'VE GOT ANOTHER
YEAR OF FUNDING.
BUT THEY'VE PUT TOGETHER A
VIRTUAL TEACHER RECRUITMENT --
WEB BASED PLATFORM A AND THEY'VE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF TEACHER
RECRUITMENT WORK THROUGH THAT
AND AND HAVING BOTH OF VIRTUAL
AND PHYSICAL -- RECRUITMENT.
THERE'S BEEN FAIRLY SUCCESSFUL
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE TEACHER
CANDIDATES LOOKING FOR THROUGH
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO FIND OTHER
POSITIONS IN TEACHING -- SO THAT
THAT PIECE IS ALSO UNDER WAY BUT
THAT FUNDING WILL EXPIRE AND AND
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THEIR FUTURE
WILL BE.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE GRANTS HAVE
DONE -- TEN THOUSAND TEACHERS OR
TEN THOUSAND PLACEMENTS AS A
RESULT OF THIS INVESTMENT ARE
EXPECTED OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
OR FOR SEASON FIVE YEARS.
WILL THIS TAKE CARE OF THE
PROBLEM OF SHORTAGES -- IT
REMAINS TO BE SEEN WE'VE SEEN
STEADY INCREASES IN TEACHER
ENROLLMENT -- TEACHER EDUCATION
ENROLLMENT 11% JUST IN THE LAST
FROM -- 201-617-21718 SO
ENROLLMENT IS GOING UP THAT'S A
VERY GOOD TREND.
OF WE THINK THAT SOME OF THE
STIMULUS IS HELPING WITH THAT --
SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE INDICATOR
THAT THAT WE MAY BE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK -- BUT IN THE BIG PICTURE
OVERALL THIS YEAR WE SAW ABOUT A
THREE AND A HALF PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
TEACHING CREDENTIALS WE ISSUED.
TO THE FIELD THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
OF THOSE CREDENTIALS WENT TO
SPECIAL EDUCATORS -- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IN THIS IS
ABOUT A 6% INCREASE FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION SO AGAIN I THINK THAT
THE AVAILABILITY OF STIMULUS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
IS ATTRACTING PEOPLE IT'S JUST
ATTRACTIVE ON THE NATURAL WHEN
THERE'S THESE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
OUT THERE BEING ADVERTISED.
WILL COME IF YOU BUILD IT THEY
WILL COME MAYBE THAT'S A THEORY
OF ACTION. FOR AS SO AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT INFLUX
IN THAT INCOMING IN THAT GROWTH.
WE SOULD SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
EMERGENCY PERMITS LAST YEAR.
AND THAT'S BIG THAT'S  LOT OF
CLASSROOMS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE IS A CLASSROOM OF STUDENTS
BEING TAUGHT BY SOMEBODY WHO
DOESN'T HAVE A CREDENTIAL.
AND THAT IS OF CONCERN TO ALL OF
US.
ABOUT A THIRD OF THOSE WERE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND THAT'S EVEN THAT'S OF EVEN
GREATER CONCERN GIVEN THE
SPECIAL NEEDS THAT THE STUDENTS
PRESENT.
IN THE SCHOOLS -- OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS WE'VE SEEN ABOUT A
EMERGENCY PERMITS GOING TO
SPECIAL EDUCATORS.
SO THESE KINDS OF INCENTIVES ARE
REALLY QUITE CRITICAL TO STEM
THAT TIDE TO REPLACE THOSE
EMERGENCY PERMIT HOLDERS WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAINED OR IN
TRAINING TO GET TO GET THIS WORK.
WHAT IS THE A MURDER THE FOLKS
WHO ARE TEACHING WAS EMERGENCY
PERMIT HAVE HAVE TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY AND ROLLED A?
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM THEY
ARE THE PEOPLE ON EMERGENCY
PERMIT DON'T QUALIFY TO GET INTO
A TEACHER AT PROGRAM THEY HAVE
TO HAVE A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
THEY HAVE TO ADMIT THEIR BASIC
SKILLS REQUIREMENT.
BUT THEY TYPICALLY HAVE NOT
COMPLETED THEIR ABOUT THEIR
SUBJECT MATTER REQUIREMENT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE DEMONSTRATED THEY
KNOW THE SUBJECT MATTER THEY'RE
GOING TO TEACH WE HAVE A TESTING
PROGRAM FOR THAT WE HAVE PROGRAM
OPPORTUNITIES TO COMPLETE THAT.
THESE PEOPLE WERE HIRED BECAUSE
THERE'S AN IMMEDIATE NEED AT A
LOCAL SCHOOL WHERE SOMEONE WITH
THE CREDENTIAL COULD NOT BE
FOUND THESE ARE FOLKS WITH IT
DID YOU SAY WITHOUT A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE SO THEY
HAVE TO HAVE A BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE TO BE AN EMERGENCY TO
REMEMBER.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY TEACHER
TRAINING AT ALL ON THE DISTRICT
SUPERVISORS THEM AND THEY THEY
ARE WORKING TO GET THEIR SUBJECT
MATTER REQUIREMENT MET.
SO THEY CAN THEN AND ROLL EITHER
IN AN INTERN PROGRAM OR IN A
TEACHING BASED PROGRAM -- BUT
THAT'S TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
CLASSROOMS WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS WHO ARE NOT
PREPARED.
TO AND AND HAVEN'T HAD
EXPERIENCE DOING IT.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT SO -- IF WE
BRING TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
SPECIAL EDUCATORS IN THROUGH
RESIDENCIES WHICH WE EXPECT TO
DO OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS THAT
HELPS.
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S THAT THE
SITUATION IS ISRAEL THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHERE WE ARE WITH
THIS.
MMHM.
SO THAT THAT MAY BE ENOUGH
UNLESS YOU HAVE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS FOR ME THAT THAT YOU'D
LIKE ME TO ELABORATE ON I'M
HAPPY TO DO SO -- TEXTUAL
PRESENTATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HELLO.
I GUESS WE WANTED TO START BY
TAKING A QUICK STEP BACK SO WHEN
TALKING ABOUT THEIR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER SHORTAGE THERE
REALLY THREE UNDERLYING FACTORS.
FIRST IS DEMAND FOR TEACHERS HOW
MANY TEACHERS DO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEED IN OUR CLASSROOMS
ONE RELEVANT FACTOR FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS THAT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS HAS BEEN RISING OVER THE
PAST DECADE.
AND SO THERE'S BEEN HIGHER
DEMAND FOR SUCH TEACHERS SECOND
A SECOND FACTOR IS TEACHER
SUPPLY.
HOW MANY CREDENTIALED TEACHERS
ARE NEWLY ENTERING OR RE
ENTERING THE CLASSROOM THIS
INCLUDES NEARLY CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS TEACHERS RE ENTERING
THE WORK FORCE AND TEACHERS
COMING FROM OU OF STATE?
LASTLY IS TEACHER TURNOVER HOW
MANY TEACHERS ARE LEAVING THE
CLASSROOM THIS MAY INCLUDE
TEACHERS LEAVING THE PROFESSION
ALTOGETHER SWITCHING DISTRICTS
LEAVING THE STATE OR RETIRING.
AND SO TEACHER SHORTAGE WILL
RESULTS WHEN AND THE DEMANDS FOR
TEACHERS IS HIGHER THAN THE
SUPPLY OR THERE'S HIGH TURNOVR.
ONE WAY TO MEASURE OF THAT
SHORTAGE IS TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF TEACHERS THAT IN A
GIVEN FIELD ON EMERGENCY PERMITS
AS WE JUST DISCUSSED.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FOR EVERY ONE HUNDRED
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER IN THE
CLASSROOM THERE WERE SIX
TEACHERS ON EMERGENCY COMMENTS
WHICH IS A HIGHER RATIO THAN ANY
OTHER SUBJECT AREA.
LAST YEAR OUR OFFICE ANALYZE THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION STAFFING
SHORTAGE AND IDENTIFIED THREE
SPECIFIC STEPS THAT.
COULD HELP ADDRESS AT FIRST THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
SIGNALING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE A STRONGER PAY INCENTIVE
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS GENERALLY DO
NOT PROVIDE DIFFERENTIAL PAY
LEVELS BETWEEN GENERAL EDUCATION
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
HOWEVER SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS TYPICALLY HAVE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES SUCH
AS DEVELOPING -- TIME CONSUMING
I YOU KEYS AND COORDINATING
TEAMS OF SPECIALISTS TO PROVIDE
STUDENT SERVICES.
THOUGH PROVIDING DIFFERENTIAL
PAY IS TYPICALLY A LOCAL
DECISION THAT IS NEGOTIATED
THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS WE BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD SIGNAL ITS
SUPPORT FOR DIRECT DFFERENTIAL
PAY.
BY REPEALING AN EXISTING
STATUTORY PROVISION THAT SETS A
UNIFORM SALARY SCHEDULE AS A
DEFAULT DISTRICT POLICY.
SECOND WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER STREAMLINING BOTH
PRESIDENTIAL STRUCTURE TO ALLOW
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS TO
TEACH STUDENTS WITH MORE TYPES
OF DISABILITIES WITHOUT HAVING
TO ATTAIN A SECOND TEACHING
CREDENTIAL.
CURRENTLY TEACHERS WORKING WITH
STUDENTS WITH MILD TO MODERATE
DISABILITIES REQUIRE A DIFFERENT
CREDENTIAL IN THOSE WERE
STUDENTS WITH A MORE EXPENSIVE
MARKS EXPENSIVE.
SUPPORT NEEDS CONSOLIDATING
THESE CREDENTIALS COULD HELP
THOSE INTERESTED IN COMING
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS MORE
EASILY NAVIGATE THE CREDENTIAL
STRUCTURE.
LASTLY.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE.
FUNDING FOR CSU TO EXPAND
TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
SPECIALIST.
ACCORDING TURN OUNCES THIS THIS
SHORTAGE IS PARTICULARLY ACUTE
FOR SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS
CURRENTLY SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGISTS MAY BE TRAINED AT
ONE OF THE THIRTEEN CSU CAMPUS
AS WE SPOKE WITH.
ADMINISTRATORS AT THESE CAMPUSES
AND LEARNS THAT MORE STUDENTS
WERE.
IN A ROLLING AND I PARTICIPATING
IN THESE PROGRAMS AND THEY CAN
ACCEPT.
GIVEN THE HIGH DEMAND FOR THE
SPECIALIST BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WE BELIEVE CSU COULD INCREASE
ENROLLMENT IN SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY PROGRAMS BY ABOUT 5%
IN NINETEEN TWENTY WITH
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT FUNDING.
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
COULD'VE PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PER CSU TO
EXPAND SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
GRADUATE PROGRAMS TO HELP REDUCE
THIS ACUTE STAFFING SHORTAGE IN
THIS AREA.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK
YOU WILL IS THE DIFFICULT T. AT
THE C. ISSUE CAMPUSES IS THE
LIMITING FACTOR.
ENROLLMENT FUNDING.
OF CAPITAL ISSUES HAVING TO DO
WITH CLASSROOMS OR IS IT.
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF QUALIFIED
FACULTY TO TEACH COURSE
[inaudible]
IN SOME.
SOME FIELDS SUCH AS NURSING IT'S
MY RECOLLECTION ANYWAY THAT. ONE
OF THE LIMITING FACTORS WAS THE
AVAILABILITY OF OF IT'S NOT A
PHD BUT IT'S THE NURSING
DOCTORATE.
THE QUALIFIED INSTRUCTORS
INSTRUCTORS TO TEACH NURSING
COURSES IS THAT THE CASE WITH
RESPECT TO OF SPEECH ABOUT.
SO FOR SPEECH PATHOLOGY IT
REALLY IS A COMBINATION OF THOSE
FACTORS.
BECAUSE OF POOR THERE IS A THERE
IS AN LECTURE BASED COMPONENT
FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
ALSO A CLINICAL COMPONENT FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND FOR SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY THE RATIO
THAT YOU HAVE FOR A SUPERVISOR
TO STUDENT IS THREE TO ONE WHICH
IS.
MUCH LOWER THAN IN OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SO IN TERMS OF
EXPANDING THESE PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY DOES TAKE MORE FUNDING --
TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL SPOT TO THE
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
PROGRAMS THAN TO OTHER
SPECIALISTS GRADUATE PROGRAMS
WITHIN THEIR THAT'S ONE FACTOR
THAT I LIMITED FOR OMITTED FROM
MY LIST AND THAT'S THE
AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL SLIDES.
WHICH I GUESS IS ALSO A LIMITING
FACTOR IN THE OTHER.
HEALTH AND ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING PROGRAMS
AS WELL WE ALSO FIND THAT TO BE
A LIMITING FACTOR WITH SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AS WELL --
BECAUSE YOU SO IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE YOUR CERTIFICATION YOU
NEED A FAIR NUMBER OF HOURS THAT.
WHERE YOU WORK IN A CLINIC WITH
ADULTS AND ALSO WITH CHILDREN
AND SO FINDING PLACEMENTS
WORKING WITH ADULT IS ACTUALLY
QUITE CHALLENGING -- IN TERMS OF
WORKING WITH CHILDREN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN EASILY ACCEPT
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST
INTERNS AND AB THOUGHT AND THEY
CAN RECEIVE THEIR HOURS THAT WAY.
BUT WORKING WITH ADULTS SEEMS TO
BE MORE CHALLENGING SEEMS TO BE
MORE LIMITING FACTOR -- AND IN
IN ADDITION TO THIS
RECOMMENDATION WE ACTUALLY WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERING PROVIDING FUNDING ON
A COMPETITIVE GRANT BASIS BASIS
AND SO CSU CAMPUSES WOULD HAVE.
TO PROVIDE ARTICULATION AS TO
HOW THEY PLAN TO ADDRESS THESE
DRAWBACKS AND LIMITATIONS ON
EXPANDING THEIR THEIR PROGRAMS
IS WHAT I'VE FOUND IS THE
CLINICAL SLOT ISSUES DIFFICULT
FOR US -- AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
IMPACT.
AS A CLINICAL **** SERVER ARE
OFTEN PROVIDED BY -- FOLKS OTHER
THAN STATE GOVERNMENT SO.
THERE IS THE ISSUE OF SLOTS IN
WHOSE FUNDING THEM AND WHERE
THEY ARE AND TO BE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN WHOSE
COMPETING FOR THE BOTH IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR -- PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS NOT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS AND THE AND THE
STATE PROGRAMS WELL YES ONE
OTHER QUESTION I'M LOOKING AT
THIS CHART HERE.
OF IN THE ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
EIGHTEEN AND I EVERYBODY WE
USING THE TERM EMERGENCY PERMITS
[inaudible]
AND DO WE CALL IT SOMETHING ELSE
IN OUR CHART OR IS THE EMERGENCY
PERMIT.
PEACE NOT ON OUR CHART.
SO WE DO HAVE -- SO FOR
EMERGENCY PERMITS AND AND
ACTUALLY ON PAGE SEVENTEEN ARE A
YES ON EIGHTEEN IF YOU SEE.
THREE PARAGRAPHS LISA MINUS
EIGHTEEN OF IT THE MERCHANTS WHO
PERMITS ARE ARE IN TURN PERMITS
ARE SHORT TERM STAFF PERMITS SO
IT'S EASY IS BROKEN OUT.
AND ON THE CHART WHAT YOU'LL SEE
IS IF YOU SEE THE PROVISIONAL IN
TURN THE PET.
AND THE SHORT TERM STAFF PERMIT
WHICH IS THE STEPS THOSE TWO ARE
CONSIDERED OUR EMERGENCY PERMITS
TOGETHER COMBINED YEAH THANK YOU
YOU WELCOME IT'S IN THE TEXT.
WELL I UNDERSTAND YEAH AND
YOU'LL SEE YOU KNOW I I THINK
JUST JUST TO POINT OUT FOR YOU
ON THIS CHART YOU KNOW IF YOU'LL
NOTE THAT THOSE TWO COMBINED IT
JUST JUST UNDER 2% WHICH DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE A HUGE AMOUNT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND YOU
COMBINE THOSE THAT'S ALMOST.
SIX THOUSAND PERMITS THAT IF YOU
WOULD CONSIDER THEY MAY BE IN A
CLASSROOM WITH EVEN TWENTY FIVE
STUDENTS EACH.
THAT IS A TON OF STUDENTS WHO
WERE IN CLASSROOMS. FOR A YEAR
OR MORE DEPENDING ON HOW MANY
TIMES THE END UP WITH THE
TEACHERS UNDERPREPARED -- THAT
THEY'RE YOU KNOW NOT GETTING THE
BENEFIT OF FULLY PREPARED
TEACHER TEACHING THEM FOR THE
YEAR SO.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
EXPLANATION OF ANYTHING ELSE
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ISSUE NUMBER -- WELL ACT ITEM
NUMBER SIX ONE ZERO ZERO
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ISSUE
NUMBER SIX STATE OPERATIONS
.
OUR PANELISTS WOULD IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES TO THE RECORD STORE
IN MY LEFT YOU ARE RIGHT SIR.
AT HANSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU SIR.
LISA WAS READING.
THANK YOU MA'AM [inaudible]
CORTES ILIO.
AND WE'RE CABALLERO.
AND I CONGRATULATE YOU YOU LINED
UP.
IN ORDER.
SO WHO WANTS TO START.
I'LL START FIRST -- AGAIN
ENHANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S BUDGET
AND THEN I'LL MOVE ON TO QUICKLY
COVER SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE STATE
OPERATIONS BUDGET.
THAT ARE INCLUDED WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ARE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES FOUR HUNDRED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN SUPPORT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS.
SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION HEADQUARTERS.
THAT INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS SEVENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
AND TWENTY NINE MILLION IN
FEDERAL FUNDS. FOR THE STATE'S
SPECIAL SCHOOLS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT INCLUDES FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OF NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. SIXTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
OF PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
AND ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
FEDERAL FUNDS.
MOVING ON TO SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC AUGMENTATIONS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REGARDING THE
STATE OPERATION SUPPORT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
OF A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWELVE POSITIONS TO AUGMENT THE
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE DIVISION
AT THE DEPARTMENT.
OF SPECIFICALLY THAT'S NINE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND SEVEN POSITIONS TO MEET NEW
COMPLIANCE STANDARDS FOR THE
FEDERAL CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT.
A THREE HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWO POSITIONS TO
ADMINISTER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR CHILDCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ONE POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM -- AND
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
ONE POSITION UPDATE VARIOUS
REGULATIONS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
UPDATED IN SEVERAL YEARS.
OF MOVING ON TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FOR
POSITIONS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
DIVISION.
A COUPLE OF THE SPECIFIC IN
JUSTIN'S INCLUDE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THREE POSITIONS TO CREATE A NEW
UNIT WITH AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
DIVISION STOCKS FOLEY ON
ADDITIONAL.
ACCOUNTABILITY EFFORTS OF LOCAL
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS IN ON
PUBLIC SCHOOL AT CAP ISSUES. ONE
HEARD IN THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS IN ONE
POSITION TO SUPPORT IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
INCREASED MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS RENDON USE OF
RESTRAINTS SINCE CLICK AND
SECLUSION ON STUDENTS.
FINALLY BOUGHT A HALF A DOZEN
VARIOUS ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FOUR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE CORRECT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION CENTER GRANT
PROGRAM.
AND THE K. TWELVE COMPONENT OF
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWO POSITIONS FOR
ONGOING DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION AND MAINTENANCE
OF THE SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN A POSITION TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE WHICH A
DEALS WITH SUPPORTING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
SUPPORTING NOT.
A FOSTER YOUTH THAT OF
EXPERIENCE SEVERE TRAUMA.
A HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ONE POSITION.
TO REVIEW WAIVER SUBMITTED BY
DISTRICTS WHEN THEY EXPERIENCE A
REDUCTION IN STUDENT TENANTS ARE
LAWSUIT INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS DUE
TO A LOT OF NATURAL DISASTERS.
AND FINALLY A FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLAR AUGMENTATION TO
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES IN
REVIEWING SCHOOL SAFETY.
IF YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON THOSE PROPOSALS I I
WILL DO MY BEST ANSWER BUT I MAY
NEED MY COLLEAGUES TO COME UP
AND ADDRESS.
ANYTHING SPECIFIC THANK YOU NO
QUESTIONS GOOD PRESENTATION OHIO.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR CORTEZ WITH
LA L. SO PAGE TWENTY FOUR OF
YOUR AGENDA INCLUDES A TABLE
THAT SHOWS -- ARE THE WORKLOAD
PROPOSALS THAT ARE ISSUED
RECOMMENDATIONS SO TODAY I'LL
FOCUS MY COMMENTS -- ON THE
PROPOSAL'S WHERE THE TABLE NOTES
THAT WE WITHHELD RECOMMENDATIONS
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SOME UPDATE
SINCE THIS TABLE IS PRODUCED.
ON THE SECOND PROPOSAL LISTED
WHERE WE WITHHELD
RECOMMENDATIONS A WE RECENTLY
RECEIVED SOME INFORMATION SO
WILL REVIEW THOSE PROPOSALS ARE
REVIEW THAT INFORMATION AND
WE'LL NOTIFY YOUR STUFF IF WE
HAVE ANY CONCERNS -- SO ON THE
FIRST A ONE WHERE WE WITHHELD
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS WAS WITH
REGARDS TO TWELVE POSITIONS FOR
THE EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
DIVISION. NINE OF THOSE
POSITIONS ARE FOR EXISTING
WORKLOAD AND THREE OF THE
POSITIONS ARE SO SHOULD WITH NEW
WORKLOAD PROPOSED WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SO FOR THE POSITIONS PROPOSED
WITH IN THE QUé BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL SO
THOSE THREE POSITIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO WAIT AS
THOSE PROPOSAL ARE STILL BEING
DEVELOPED IN -- THE PROGRAMS
MIGHT BE MORE OMPLEX THERE
MIGHT BE ADDITIONAL STAFFING
THAT NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED FOR
THOSE SPECIFIC REPOSE PROPOSALS --
IF LIKE AN EVALUATIN COMPONENT
IS ADDED THEY MIGHT BE
ADDITIONAL STAFFING NEEDS SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU --
TO IF YOU WANTED TO EXPLORE WITH
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
STAFFING FOR THOSE NEW -- FOR
THOSE NEW PROPOSALS.
THE REMAINING NINE POSITION ARE
FOR EXISTING WORKLOAD AND AND
WE'VE AND WE'VE REVIEWED THESE
THESE PIECES AND I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THESE IN
DETAIL.
SO THREE OF THE PUT AND ALL OF
THESE POSITIONS ARE PERMANENT
POSITION.
SO THREE OF THE POSITIONS ARE
FOR TITLE FIVE COMPLIANCE
MONITORING AND THIS IS SO THAT
CD YOU COULD INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY IN WHICH IT MONITORS --
WHICH IS THAT IT WHICH TO
CONDUCT THESE TITLE COMP TITLE
FIVE COMPLIANCE REVIEWS
UNDERSTATE REGULATIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO DO THEM ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS VISIT EVERY
CONTRACTOR -- AND THEY'VE
INDICATED THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY
DOING IT ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS
WE DO NOT HEAR THAT WE THINK
THERE SOME LEGISLATIVE
DISCRETION -- WITH REGARDS TO
THESE COMPLIANCE MONITORING
BECAUSE THERE'S BECAUSE THIS IS
THE STATE REQUIREMENT.
SO THERE'S SOME -- AND YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER OTHER
MONITORING THAT TAKES PLACE FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS FOR EXAMPLE
MOST PROVIDERS GO THROUGH HAVE
TO DO SOME LICENSING INSPECTIONS
AND THEY HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS AND
SOMEBODY GOES OUT TO THE FIELD --
TO TO ANNUALLY VISIT THESE
PROVIDERS AND THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER MINUTE ON SITE
MONITORING SYSTEM CALLED THE
QUALITY RADIO READING --
INFORMATION SYSTEM SO WE THINK
THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION HERE ON
THOSE. THREE POSITIONS.
ON TE NEXT SET OF POSITIONS ARE
FOR PERMANENT POSITIONS FOR
FISCAL CMPLIANCE MONITORING.
AND THESE.
AND THESE POSITIONS ARE TO ALSO
INCREASE THE INCREASE.
INCREASE THE FREQUENCY IN WHICH
FISCAL COMPLIANCE REVIEWS FOR
EACH CONTRACTOR SO THERE SO THEY
ARE ALSO GOING TO DO IT ONCE
EVERY THREE YEARS INSTEAD OF
ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS AS EIGHT
INDICATED THEY'RE CURRENTLY
DOING.
CD CLAIMS THAT THESE POSITIONS
ARE NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS BUT ON OUR
REVIEW A WE'VE NOTED THAT THEY
DON'T REQUIRE.
THEY DON'T REQUIRE A VISIT ONCE
EVERY THREE YEARS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES REQUIRE THE
STATE TO CALCULATE AND IMPROPER%
PAYMENT RATE ONCE EVERY THREE
YEARS -- USE BUT THAT'S TO USE A
SAMPLE OF PROVIDERS THAT THEY
DON'T NEED TO VISIT A SO BECAUSE
OF THAT WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
THESE POSITIONS.
THAT THERE IS ONE POSITION
PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR A REGULATORY
COORDINATOR -- WE RECOMMEND YOU
REJECTING A WE DON'T THINK SEE
THIS WORKLOAD AS ONGOING WORK
LOAD.
AND THERE'S A POSITION FOR THEIR
INCLUSIVE REALLY EDUCATION SPEND
EXPANSION PROGRAM IT'S ONE
PERMANENT POSITION THIS WAS A
PROGRAM CREATED IN THE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT WORKLOAD I RECKON RECOMMEND
APPROVING THAT POSITION.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
BUT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
YOU.
NO QUESTIONS ELEVEN QUESTIONS.
THIS IS A WHOLE OPEN ITEM SO WE
WILL DO THAT WE WILL BE
REVISITING IT VERY VERY SOON
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS SO TIME TO STRETCH
COME BACK ON ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S BACK IN
SESSION THANK YOU FOR THE BREAK.
SOMEBODY OLD LIKE ME KIDS AT THE
PARK.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVN UNIFORM
COMPLAINT PROCEDURES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DIANA
THEATER SOME FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON.
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT THE UNIFORM
COMPLAINT PROCEDURES -- I KNOW
THAT YOU HAD TO QUESTIONS
CONCERNING OUR REPORT ONE WAS IN
REGARDS TO THE TIME LINES. FOR
SCABBERS SHEEN -- IT DOUBLES FOR
COMPLETING THE CHANGES
IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT THAT
WAS ISSUED TO YOU -- AS WELL AS
WHAT WERE THE KEY FINDINGS FROM
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT WE
ENGAGED IN.
YOUR TO ANSWER QUESTIONS BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND I THOUGHT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF WHAT IS THE
UNIFORM COMPLAINT PROCEDURES.
WE GET THAT A LOT AND SO THE
UNIFORMED COMPLAINTS PROCEDURES
OR THE UC P. AS WE REFER TO THEM
WERE ESTABLISHED BY STATE
REGULATIONS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE I'M TO
DEVELOP A UNIFORM SYSTEM FOR
RESPONDING TO COMPLAINTS I'M AT
A LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
DIRECT FROM THE CHARTER LEVEL OR
AN ALLEY A LEVEL THIS ALSO COULD
BE A COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION --
THE AT THE TIME THERE WERE SIX
PROGRAMS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE REGULATIONS SO NOT ALL
COMPLAINTS FALL WITH IN THE UC
P..
THERE WERE SIX NOW THERE ARE A
TOTAL OF SIXTEEN SO YOU CAN SEE
IS A NINETEEN NINETY ONE AT THAT
NUMBER HAS INCREASED.
AND THE PROCESS IS GENERALLY
THAT -- INDIVIDUALS COMPLAINTS
FILED COMPLAINTS USUALLY PARENTS
AT A LOCAL LEVEL FIRST FOR THE
pRESOLVE.
AND IF THE COMPLAINT IS
UNSATISFIED WITH THAT RESOLUTION
AND THEY MAY APPEAL AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
THERE'S A WIDE ARRAY OF PROGRAMS
WITH IN THE UC P. AND THEY ARE A
BROAD SPECTRUM OF PROGRAMS --
THE MOST COMMON ARE THOSE
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO
DISCRIMINATION BOWLING
HARASSMENT -- ON THE BASIS OF A
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTIC.
THERE ARE OTHERS SUCH AS
UNLAWFUL PEOPLE FEES WHICH COULD
BE FOR EXAMPLE THE CHARGING OF
GRADUATION CAPS AND GOWNS AND
ALSO SEEMS TO BE.
A VERY POPULAR [inaudible]
ONE SO I'M.
THE AS A RESULT OF HAVING SO
MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF OFFICES WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT THAT PROCESS THE
APPEALS AND SOMETIMES COMPLAINTS.
I'M RELATED TO THE UCP
COMPLAINTS AND THERE ARE IT
SHOULD ADD THAT THERE ARE SOME
CASES WHERE THE DEPARTMENT CAN
DIRECTLY INTERVENE -- BUT IT FOR
THE MOST PART -- THESE ARE
RESOLVED AT A LOCAL LEVEL AT A
DISTRICT LEVEL AND THEN THEY CAN
APPEAL AT THE STATE LEVEL IF THE
COMPLAINTS ARE NOT SATISFIED.
I'M BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF A
PROGRAMS IN OFFICES WORKING
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT ON THESE
TYPES OF APPEALS.
THE DEPARTMENT FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT SEVERAL YEARS AGO THAT
WE BUILT SOME COORDINATION
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT EVERYONE
IS KIND OF WORKING ON THEIR OWN
AND WE REALLY THOUGHT HE NEEDED%
TO INCREASE.
THE COORDINATION AS WELL AS THE
EFFICIENCY AND HOW WE PROCESS
APPEALS AND COMPLAINTS.
I'M AND THIS STARTED PROBABLY
ABOUT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE START
HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN DO THAT AS YOU'RE AWARE
THERE WAS AN AUDIT IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT ALSO HAD SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS -- PRIOR -- TO
THE AUDIT WE HAD TALKED ABOUT
CONSTRUCTING OR DEVELOPING A
CENTRAL TRACKING SYSTEM WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT BY WHICH EACH
PROGRAM OFFICE WOULD -- INSERT
DATA RELATIVE -- TO ALL OF A
PLATE APPEALS AND COMPLAINTS
THAT COME TO THE DEPARTMENT SO
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A CENTRAL
SYSTEM FOR TRACKING AND LOGGING
THESE TYPES OF COMPLAINTS AN
APPEALS.
RELATIVE TO THE UC PEOPLE.
AFTER THE AUDIT ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS THAT WE
DEVELOP A CENTRAL TRACKING
SYSTEM AS WELL AS DEVELOP.
OUR CREATE A CENTRAL OFFICE --
AFTER THE AUDIT THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUED -- TO LOOK AT WAYS IN
WHICH YOU CAN CONSTRUCT A
CENTRAL TRACKING SYSTEM AND WE
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT AN AS OF
OCTOBER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALL PROGRAM
OFFICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
ENTERED THEIR DATE AND
EVERYTHING IS LOGGED INTO ONE
CENTRAL TRACKING OFFICE.
AND WE ALSO CONTINUED -- AS PART
OF SB EIGHT FORTY TO ENGAGE IN A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND WE THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DONE THIS --
REGARDING THE UCP SO WE WERE
REALLY EXCITED AND WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ANSWERED AND ASK
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS SO WE DID
HOLD PRE MEETINGS PREVIOUSLY
WITH A SMALL GROUP.
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS WHAT WE FOUND DURING
THE SPREE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
WAS THAT THERE WAS A GENERAL
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OR
INFORMATION RELATIVE TO WHAT THE
UC P. IS AND WHAT IT IS NOT.
WHAT PROGRAMS ARE INCLUDED IN
THE U. P. AND THIS IS AT ALL
LEVELS OF THE PARENT LEVEL PLUS
YOU -- PARENTS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- AND THERE WAS ALSO
A FEELING OF THAT DAY AT THE
STATE LEVEL IS VERY COMPLEX AND
CONFUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS -- WE
THEN DECIDED THAT WE NEEDED TO
FOCUS OUR QUESTIONS ON THE
GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE U.
C. P. AS WELL AS WHAT AVAILABLE
RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
ARE AVAILABLE TO PARENTS AND TO
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS AT A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVEL.
AND SO ARE QUESTIONS REALLY
REVOLVED AROUND THE CLARITY OF
THE UC.
WHAT INFORMATION DO PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT THE UC WHAT IS IT THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO NOW?
AND THE SECOND WAS ABOUT THE
UNIFORM AND CONSISTENCY
UNIFORMITY.
WHAT WERE THEIR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE UNIFORMITY WHAT WOULD THEY
LIKE TO SEE RELATIVE TO THAT?
AND THE THIRD AREA WAS WHAT
AVAILABLE GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS OUT THERE.
AND SO THOSE WERE THE THREE
AREAS WE ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT WHAT WE FOUND WAS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DISCOVERED IN
OUR PRE MEETINGS.
AND THAT IS THAT THE
STAKEHOLDERS REALLY STRESS A
GENERAL LACK OF CLARITY AROUND
THE U. C. P..
AND THIS REALLY INCLUDED --
REGARDING THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE STATE
AND THE LOCAL LEVEL -- CLARITY
REGARDING THE PURPOSE OF THE UC
P. I'M THE INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS
AND TIME LINES SO IN ALL ASPECTS
OF THE UC P. -- THAT THERE WAS A
NEED FOR MORE UNIFORMITY AND
CONSISTENCY FOR PROCESSING OF
COMPLAINTS AND APPEALS.
I'M.
SPECIFICALLY THAT THERE NEEDED
TO BE CLEAR EXPECTATIONS IN THE
PROCESS THE PARENTS REALLY
NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
STEPS WERE INVOLVED IN WITH THE
TIME.
SWORE THAT THEY NEEDED TO BE
CONSISTENT BOTH AT A LOCAL LEVEL
AND STATE LEVEL AND AS A YOU
KNOW RECENTLY -- THERE WAS
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED THAT
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO ALSO
HAVE A SIXTY DAY TIMELINE WHICH
IS THE SAME TIMELINE THAT
DISTRICTS HAVE SO THAT IS IN AN
EFFORT TO BECOME A MORE UNIFORM.
THE BIGGEST WAS THAT THERE WAS A
NEED FOR GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND LOCAL LEVEL --
THIS INCLUDED TRAINING FOR
ADMINISTRATORS ARE CONDUCTING
INVESTIGATIONS -- WE ALSO FOUND
THAT THERE WAS A HIGH TURNOVER
RATE AND SOMETIMES IN THE
ADMINISTRATORS THAT ARE.
PLACED WITH THIS RESPONSIBILITY --
THAT THEY'RE ALSO NEEDED TO BE
THINGS LIKE RESOURCES FAQS
TEMPLATES -- ANY TYPE OF GODLY
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS.
SO OVERALL WE FOUND IT --
STAKEHOLDERS FELT IT WAS COMPLEX
CONFUSING AND INCONSISTENT AND
THAT THERE WAS A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE STATE LEVEL AND THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
SO IN RESPONSE TO THAT WE FELT
THAT WE NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING.
AND TO DO SOMETHING DRASTIC AND
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE I'M
ALSO ARE DOING AS PART OF A
RESPONSE TO THIS IS CREATING A
CENTRAL OFFICE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT.
SO WE'RE RESEARCHING CURRENTLY
WEIGHS ABOUT HOW WE CAN TO
RESTRUCTURE OUR OFFICES IN OUR
STAFFING TO THAT WE CAN STAFF.
A CENTRAL OFFICE APPROPRIATELY
THIS OFFICE WOULD RECEIVE AND
PROCESS ALL APPEALS AND
COMPLAINTS SO THERE WOULD BE ONE
OFFICE WHERE IS IN THE PAST
COMPLAINTS ARE DISTRICTS WOULD
HAVE TO CALL THE APPROPRIATE
PROGRAM OFFICE THAT WAS --
WORKING ON THEIR TYPES OF
COMPLAINTS WE WE JUST HAVE ONE
PHONE NUMBER ONE EMAIL -- WE
ALSO ARE UPDATING ACTUALLY
UPDATED OUR REGULATIONS RELATED
TO THE UCP.
THAT WAS REQUIRED IN STATUTE BUT
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO PROPOSING
CHANGES THAT WE FELT WERE IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO WHAT
STAKEHOLDERS WERE TELLING US ONE
OF THE THINGS WAS TO PROVIDE
SOME MORE CLARITY.
ABOUT THE PROCESS AND ABOUT THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS AT THE
STATE LEVEL -- ANOTHER WAS
EXTENDING THE PERIOD BY WHICH TO
COMPLAIN CAN APPEAL.
THE COMPLAINT AND THE STATE
LEVEL PREVIOUSLY IT WAS FIFTEEN
DAYS WE HAVE HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THAT THAT WAS NOT
ENOUGH TIME THEY NEEDED
ADDITIONAL TIME.
SAID WE INCREASED THAT TO THIRTY
DAY.
THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC HEARING A
RELATIVE TO THE REGULATIONS.
ON MONDAY THIS COMING MONDAY THE
THIRTEENTH IN THE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A FORTY
FIVE DAY COMMENT PERIOD.
ON THAT WILL END AND THEN WE
WILL REVIEW ALL OF THE COMMENTS
THE GOAL IS TO IF EVERYTHING
GOES AS LANNED THAT THOSE
REGULATIONS WILL BE ADOPTED IN
IN PLACE BY JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY I'M IN RESPECT TO OUR
CENTRAL OFFICE WE WORKING ON
THAT WE EXPECT.
THAT WILL BE COMPLETED WITHIN
THREE TO SIX MONTHS -- IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE WANTED TO
CREATE A MULTI FACETED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE APPROACH -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A GREAT
NEED FOR THAT -- AND WE ARE
WILLING TO RESPOND TO THAT.
AND THIS WILL OF COURSE TAKE
PLACE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT YEAR.
AND WE WILL HAVE TO BE VERY
STRATEGIC ABOUT IT AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY ARE WE
PROVIDING GENERAL FAQS AND
GUIDANCE AND TEMPLATES.
BUT ALSO SOME TARGETED I'M
TRAINING WHERE IT IS NEEDED
WE'VE SEEN ANECDOTAL KLAY.
THAT THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF
NEEDS THERE ARE SOME DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE STRUCTURES IN PLACE --
ABLE TO RESPOND TO COMPLAINTS
AND INVESTIGATE THEM AND THERE
ARE OTHER DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
HAVE THOSE.
TODAY SPOKE ABOUT THE NEED IN
RURAL AREAS AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
DISTRICTS ARE LAWYERS HAVE LESS
RESOURCES SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALL WAYS THAT WE CAN -- PROVIDE
RESOURCES MAYBE CONNECT
DISTRICTS THAT SOME HAVE
RESOURCES AND OTHERS THAT DON'T
TO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
COMMUNITY -- WE ALSO WANT TO
DEVELOP PARTNERSHIPS NOT ONLY
INTERNALLY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
BUT EXTERNALLY AS WELL TO SEE
WHAT EXISTING STRUCTURES ARE
ALREADY OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
TRAINING -- SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO REINVENT THE WHEEL OR
OVER BURDENED DISTRICTS WHO WANT
TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
RESOURCES TO THEM IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE.
SO I WILL BE RESEARCHING NOT --
AS SOON AS WE CAN DEVELOP OUR
CENTRAL OFFICE AND OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT YEAR WE WOULD
LIKE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE FOR THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
AND I THINK THAT'S ALL I HAVE
FOR MY PRESENTATION IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WITH JUST A COUPLE
OF THE COMPLAINT PROCESS IN.
HOW IT WORKS OUR ANALYSIS
INDICATED THAT?
THERE WERE ABOUT -- FOUR SIXTY
FIVE REQUESTED CD ACCEPTED ONE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE APPEAL OR
COMPLAINT REQUESTS.
IN EIGHT UCP PROGRAMS DO YOU
MAINTAIN STATISTICS ON WHY
COMPLAINTS ARE NOT ACCEPTED IN.
IN IN SOME DETAIL HER RIGHT SO
WE WE ACTUALLY JUST SPOKE ABOUT
THAT YESTERDAY SO WITH OUR NEW
DATABASE IT'S RELATIVELY NEW WE
ARE -- CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT HOW
WE CAN BETTER COLLECT DATA.
ON THIS IS A NEW VENTURE FOR US
IF YOU WILL WE HAVE NOT
COLLECTED IN AND REALLY ANALYZE
THE DATA WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN IN
THE BUSINESS OF PROCESSING
APPEALS -- SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
THAT AND IN LOOKING AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN BETTER TEASE OUT OF THE
YOU KNOW THE REASONS WHY WE'RE
NOT ACCEPTING AND WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU.
IS THAT A LOT OF TIMES --
COMPLAINTS MAY BE FRUSTRATED AND
A DISTRICT LEVEL ONE SO THEY
WANT TO COME DIRECTLY TO THE
STATE TO FILE A COMPLAINT.
AND WE DO -- ALLOWED DISTRICTS
THE REGULATIONS REQUIRE US TO
ALLOW DISTRICTS TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE THAT
COMPLAINT LOCALLY DISTRICTS DO
YOU HAVE TO HAVE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IN PLACE FOR
RESOLVING COMPLAINTS.
SO WE DO REFER THOSE BACK TO THE
DISTRICT WELL THE REASON I ASK
IS IF 71% OF THE COMPLAINTS ARE
IN THE EDUCATION EQUITY AREA OF
HEELS RELATED DELEGATION SIBLING
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION OR INTIMIDATION.
ON THE BASIS OF PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTICS.
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO US AS A
LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE KNOW THAT THERE WERE
COMPLAINTS FILED IN WHY
COMPLAINTS WERE NOT ACCEPTED?
WAS THE EVIDENCE DEEM TO BE
INSUFFICIENT THE COMPLAIN ITSELF
FAILED TO ALLEGE.
THE THE ALLEGATIONS NECESSARY
JUST TO AT LEAST FROM UP.
ALLEGATIONS TEN POINT SUPPORT OF
BULLYING CLAIM OR A RESTAURANT
OR DISCRIMINATION CLAIM AND I
REALIZE.
YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING YOUR YOUR SYSTEM BUT
IN DEVELOPING YOUR SYSTEM.
PARTICULARLY IN THAT CATEGORY.
OF I WOULD THINK WE WOULD WANT
THE SAME LEVEL OF DETAIL.
AVAILABLE AS WE WOULD EXPECT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING SURE OR THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES SUCH AS THAT
WHEN DEALING WITH SIMILAR TYPE
CLAIMS.
SO IN GENERAL AND I CAN TELL YOU
IS THAT SOMETIMES -- THE APPEAL
IS INCOMPLETE I'M IN THOSE CASES
WE DO REFER BACK TO THE
COMPLAINT AND LET THEM KNOW THAT --
IT WAS INCOMPLETE AND GIVE THEM
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY SUBMIT THE
INFORMATION THAT IS NEEDED.
REQUIREMENTS IS -- ALSO
SOMETIMES.
IN DAYS TO APPEAL ON SOMETIMES --
DEPENDING WE TRY TO ALLOW SOME
FLEXIBILITY BUT IN SOME CASES IT
IS UNTIMELY.
HI BUT I THINK I GUESS WHAT I'M.
JUST TO GO BASS I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU PROVIDED TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF SURE -- IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE STAFF SO THAT WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE.
IT'S WERE -- NOT ACCEPTED OR
REJECTED AND TRACK WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE THEY WERE ON TIGHTLY.
WEATHER INFORMATION BY THE
BACKUP INFORMATION WAS NOT
ATTACHED AND THEN I I IT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I WOULD WANT
TO SEE THOSE THAT WERE RETURNED
TO COMPLAIN IS WHAT PERCENTAGE
CAME BACK.
OF WITH THE ISSUES CURED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNICATION
PROCESS IS CLEAR IN THE PIPELINE
IS UNOBSTRUCTED.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND THEN MY FOLLOWING QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH THESE CATEGORIES
INCLUDING THE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
CATEGORY.
THAT ARE SET OUT ON TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT OF OUR ANALYSIS A
AND I I'M.
SORT OF INTERESTED IN WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE COMPLAINTS
WORSE BUT WERE SUBSTANTIATED ON
APPEAL.
AND IF YOU HAVE THE LOS TO TO I
DIDN'T SEE IT ANYWHERE IN HERE
AND I DIDN'T I DIDN'T CATCH IT
IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
COMPLAINTS AND HE'S VERY
SCATTERGORIES WERE SUBSTANTIATED?
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT CD HAS A
CORRECTIVE ACTION AUTHORITY WHO --
WHAT CORRECTIVE ACTION WAS TAKEN
TO MAKE SENSE YES ANY SECULAR?
I WOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
71% THAT FOCUS ON BULLYING
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
INTIMIDATION SO IF YOU.
IF YOU -- OUT OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN COMPLAINTS DID YOU
SUBSTANTIATE 50% OF THOSE.
AND IN THOSE CASES WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER THE COMPLAINT WAS
SUBSTANTIATED SO WE CAN TRACK
SURE HOW THIS PROCESS WORKS IN.
AND AND ALSO TRACK TRENDS I
WOULD THINK WOULD BE IMPORTANT
SURE.
AND WE CAN GET THAT INFORMATION
TO YOU DON'T HAVE. TO LIVE IN
QUESTION I'M GOOD THANK YOU.
I GUESS THAT'S GREAT SO YOU DID
A GREAT JOB THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT ITEM IS SIX EIGHT
SEVEN ZERO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT IS
STATE OPERATIONS [inaudible] ONE
DOWN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SO LET'S SAID
THAT A FIRST CELLS FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT YOU
WRITE THEM.
RIGHT SO DE SO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOOD TO
HAVE YOU HERE.
MICHELLE NEW IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JUST WHEN CHRISTIAN US MANY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SIR GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
EDGAR CABRAL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
YOUR BACK AS WELL GOOD WHO WANTS
TO START [inaudible]
GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MITCHELL
NEW IN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR THE CHANCES OFFICES
THE OPERATIONS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSESA HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND ONGOING.
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND ONE POSITION
FOR AN INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICER TO IMPROVE DATA SECURITY
CAPACITY AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROVIDES
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND FOR A STAFFING CONTRACT FOR
THE ACTIVITIES REQUIRED OF THE
FUNDING FORMULA OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT.
IT IS ALSO REQUESTED THAT A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT CAN BE MADE
TO SHIFT FUNDING LEVELS FOR
VARIOUS BONDS THAT SUPPORT THE
CHANCES OFFICES STATE OPERATIONS.
I THINK THEY NEED YOU TO PULL
YOUR MICHAEL LITTLE CLOSER MA'AM.
SURE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HEAR THIS
BETTER PERFECT.
SHOULD SHOULD I START AGAIN --
IF THERE'S OBJECTION BACK THERE
WILL DO IT.
YOU CAN KEEP MOVING FORWARD IS.
TO CONTINUE BUT OKAY IT'S
GETTING LATE.
IT IS ALSO REQUESTED THAT A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT BE MADE TO
SHIFT FUNDING LEVELS FOR VARIOUS
BONDS THAT SUPPORT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICES STATE
OPERATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE OFFICES FACILITIES
PLANNING UNIT.
THIS ADJUSTMENT ALIGNS THE BOND
FUNDING SO THAT THE OLDEST BONDS
WITH AVAILABLE RESOURCES ARE
USED FIRST AND MAKES NO CHANGES
TO THE FUNDING LEVEL PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
YES SIR ALEJO AND BROUGHT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
FACILITIES PLANNING UNIT --
REQUEST OR THE FRONT THE TOP
FUNDING FOR THE FUNDING FORMULA
OR GROUP THEY WOULD WANT TO
DISCUSS THE WE HAD SOME --
ASSESSMENT OF THE ONE POSITION
FOR INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER.
I'M WE DO THINK THAT IN TALKING
THE CHANCES OF THAT THERE'S
MERIT TO TO HAVING AN
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER --
GIVEN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM -- THE TENS OFFICE AND
STAFF OF THE DIGITAL INNOVATION
INFRASTRUCTURE DIVISION THERE IS.
A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL -- STAFF I
CAN WORK ON IMPROVING THE
INFORMATION SECURITY THERE --
THE THERE WAS A REVIEW BY THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT HER
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN DOING
REVIEWS OF STATE AGENCIES OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS -- AND AND
PROVIDING FEEDBACK AND THEY ARE
IN THE PROCESS TO TRY TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES THAT WE THINK
ANOTHER STAFF PERSON TO MAKE
THEM FOR THAT.
WE DO RECOMMEND HOWEVER THAT
THAT -- UP POSITION BE HIRED
USING EXISTING RESOURCES THE
CHANCES OF IT HAS RECEIVED
AUGMENTATIONS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO GO TO THE LAST --
AUGMENTATION THE TWO MILLION
THERE WERE NO SPECIFIC -- BUT
THERE WAS NO SPECIFICATION IN
TERMS OF WHAT WAS EXPECTED OF
THE CHANCES OFFICE TO DO WITH
THOSE FUNDS AND AND SO WE THINK
THAT GIVEN FOR THE HIGH PRIORITY
WITH PASSION BE.
ARM A PLACE WHERE SOME OF THOSE
RESOURCES ARE USED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATOR
LEYVA OF I'VE HANDED OUT A
FOLDER I WILL NOT WALK THROUGH
THE DETAILS HERE -- WE
APPRECIATE THE POSITION INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR AN
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER WE
ARE A SMALL AGENCY -- BUT OUR
INFORMATION -- THE DATA WE
COLLECT -- SPANS A VERY LARGE
SYSTEM WE HAVE STOOD LEVEL
RECORDS TODAY WE DON'T HAVE.
A A DEDICATED INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER THOSE POSITIONS
OF THOSE DUTIES ARE --
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS -- I. T.
STAFF ACROSS OR AGENCY WE THINK
IT MAKES SENSE -- FOR THE TYPE
OF WORK WE'RE DOING THAT WE HAVE
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER.
WE AGAIN APPRECIATE -- THE
PROPOSAL AROUND THE FACILITIES
PLANNING IT.
OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS ADOPTED A
REQUEST IN THE FALL WHICH IS
WHAT ARE -- THE PACKET --
INCLUDES THAT INCLUDES TWO
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS THE FIRST.
IS OUR FULL STATE OPERATIONS
REQUEST FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY A TOTAL OF SEVENTEEN AND
A HALF POSITIONS ONE AS WE
TALKED ABOUT FUNDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE APPRECIATE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL WHICH WE FOUND OUT
ABOUT TODAY THAT INCLUDES THREE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
THAT ARE INCLUDED ON HERE FOR
NUMBER FOUR FISCAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS AND FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN FOR SENIOR COUNTY.
IN POSITIONS -- WE MAINTAIN OUR
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
LARGELY -- TO REALLY HELP OUR
AGENCY SUPPORTER COLLEGES AND
IMPROVING.
OUTCOMES CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS CONSIST OF THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT
MORE.
IN THE FUTURE IF YOU'D LIKE OUR
SECOND REQUEST IS RELATED TO THE
USE OF LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS
FOR STATEWIDE NEEDS.
ARE WHEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
CREATED SOME CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS FUNDS FOR PARTICULAR
PURPOSES IT'S ALLOWED OUR OFFICE
TO CONTRACT WITH DISTRICTS TO
USE SOME OF THE FUNDS TYPICALLY
A SET PERCENTAGE. FOR STATEWIDE
SUPPORT ADMINISTRATION OVERSIGHT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE TERMS
VERY ACROSS PROGRAMS WHAT WE'VE
PROPOSED.
BRING THOSE FUNDS TOGETHER.
HOW TO ENABLE OUR OFFICE TO MORE
STRATEGICALLY USE THE FUNDS IN
SUPPORT OF THE COLLEGES --
IMPROVEMENT UNDER THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS AND DOWN I WILL.
WE'VE INCLUDED THE DETAILS THERE
FOR YOU -- HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT IN THE FUTURE IF YOU'D LIKE.
WELL IT WILL ANYBODY ELSE.
COULD ANYBODY OUT.
OBVIOUSLY INFORMATION SECURITY
IS A KEY ISSUE.
NO DOUBT PARTICULARLY IN YOUR
CASE PARTICULARLY.
GIVEN THE GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S INTEREST
AND AND THE LONGITUDINAL -- DATA
SYSTEM.
YOU MAY HAVE MORE DATA IT NEEDS
TO BE PROTECTED NO QUESTION IT'S
A HOLD OPEN ITEM BUT WE WILL
REVISIT IT.
NEXT WEEK I HAVE OVER.
ALL CONCERNS ABOUT MANNING AND
STAFFING IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
THAT ARE TIED IN PART TO THE
NEXT AGENDA ITEM WHICH I I I
KNOW THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ROUGH WILL NOT BE ABLE TO STAY
FOR AT LEAST THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING.
YOU WILL HAVE A COMMUNITY
CULTURE UP HERE MAY OR SOMEONE
ELSE THE PERFECT YES I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT STAFFING ABOUT
MANNING IN THE ABILITY.
TO FULFILL RESPONSIBILITIES AT
EITHER WE'VE ASSIGNED YOU WERE
THAT YOU HAVE A SIGNED.
FROM OTHERS.
Q. I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
POSITIONS IN THE CHANCE IN THE
SYSTEM OFFICE CORRECT. HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE POINT FIVE I
GUESS.
HAS -- AND I THIS THIS PIECE OF
PAPER THAT I HAVE IN FRONT OF ME
HIS -- THE EIGHTEEN NEW
POSITIONS LISTED ON THERE.
SO WHEN'S THE LAST TIME THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE CHANCES OFFICE
IS DONE A JUST AN OVERALL
MANPOWER STUDY. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER EXISTING STAFF OR YOUR
APPROPRIATELY SIZED FOR THE
FUNCTIONS YOU HAVE WITH YOU NEED
MORE WHETHER YOU NEED FEWER
POSITIONS.
I'VE SEEN THE BCP PROCESS AND
THAT DOESNT.
RISE TO THE LEVEL OF A MAN PAR
STUDY.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT YEAH.
IT DOES NOT SO.
SO WHEN CHANCELLOR OAKLEY CAME
IN TWO YEARS AGO -- FOLLOWING
HIS -- APPOINTMENT AS CHANCELLOR
WE DID A REVIEW OF THE AGENCY
REALLY FOCUSED ON FIGURING OUT
HOW DO WE ADJUST OUR POSITIONS
REALLOCATE OUR POSITIONS WITHIN
THE EXISTING AUTHORITY SO -- YOU
KNOW HE WAS ESPECIALLY INTENT IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE
MANAGING THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
APPROPRIATELY -- THAT OUR
POSITION AUTHORITY EXCEEDED THE
ABILITY FOR US -- TO TO FUNDED
GIVEN THE EXISTING STATE
RESOURCE SAYS AND WINE TO MAKE
SURE THAT GIVEN THOSE
LIMITATIONS -- WE WERE
ALLOCATING OUR POSITIONS ARE
EXISTING POSITIONS TO THE AREAS
OF THE OFFICE WHERE THEY WERE
MOST CRITICAL NEED SO THIS WAS
NOT A CERTAINLY A MANPOWER STUDY.
AS I WOULD IMAGINE AND I THINK
AS YOU WOULD IMAGINE IT BUT
ESSENTIALLY TO SAY LET'S FREEZE
THE HIRING WHERE WE CURRENTLY
ARE FIGURE OUT HOW MANY
VACANCIES WE HAVE.
AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHICH WE CAN
FIND IN WHERE WE SHOULD PUT
THOSE MOST STRATEGICALLY SO
THAT'S PROBABLY THE CLOSEST
THING WE'VE GOTTEN TO THAT TYPE
OF STUDY.
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OVER MANY YEARS TO DO
SIMILAR WORK TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
OUR NEEDS.
THIS RECALL YOUR FOLLOWS ON A AN
INTENT TO PRIORITIZE WHAT WE CAN
FUND -- WITH OUR STATE
OPERATIONS DOLLARS BUT AGAIN I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE THE POINT --
KIND OF OUR SECOND PROPOSAL
RELATED TO MORE STRATEGIC USE OF
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
GOING TO THE INSTITUTIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS PARTNERSHIP
INITIATIVE.
GOING TO BE SET ASIDE FROM
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS -- YOU KNOW
THE CHANCELLOR BELIEVES THAT TO
THE EXTENT WE COULD USE THOSE
DOLLARS MORE STRATEGICALLY THAT
WE COULD BEGIN TO RESOURCE THE
STATE WIDE EFFORTS.
INA WAY THAT COULD BETTER
SUPPORT OUR COLLEGES MEETING
THEIR GOALS WELL I'M CONCERNED
THAT THE IT.
PERHAPS BECAUSE OF MANNING
DEFICIENCIES.
THAT THE SYSTEM OFFICES UNABLE
[inaudible]
TO PROPERLY.
MANAGE SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
THAT I TO THE GOVERNOR
ADMINISTRATION OF PUT IN THE
BUDGET OR THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS FUNDED.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT YEAH --
AS WE WILL GET INTO WHEN WE GET
TO THE NEXT ISSUE AND IF THAT'S
TIED TO MANNING SHORTFALLS IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE NEED.
TO PUT A MANNING.
THE TEAM MEMBERS SURVEY TEAM
INTO THE SYSTEM OFFICE TO FIND
OUT WHO'S DOING WHAT.
AND WHEN.
AND WHETHER YOU NEED TEN MORE
FIFTEEN MORE OR FIFTEEN LESS --
I CAME OUT OF THE MILITARY AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD THOSE WITH
SOME REGULARITY AND SOMETIMES
YOU ONE AND SOMETIMES YOU LOST
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU
KNEW.
WHAT YOU WERE GOING TO DO AND
YOU YOU HAD?
JOB THAT YOU WERE EXPECTED TO DO
SO.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CRACK THIS NOT I UNDERSTAND IT'S
NOT PROP NINETY EIGHT IT'S
FUNDED OF THE GENERAL FUND.
BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOUR
OPERATION -- THEN WE NEED TO
FUNDED PROPERLY.
AND IF WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE FOR
NEGATIVE FUNDED PROPERLY THEN.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT ANOTHER
WAY TO DO IT.
I I RECOGNIZE THESE KINDS OF
STUDIES GENERALLY ARE RISKY BUT
I THINK WE WOULD BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT BECAUSE I THINK
WE WOULD -- I THINK WE WOULD
DEMONSTRATE THAT -- UNDER
CURRENT PRACTICES WE ARE HAVING
TO PRIORITIZE BETWEEN WHERE WE
SPEND OUR YOU KNOW TIME AND
ENERGY AND PERSONAL RESOURCES.
ON CERTAIN THINGS OBVIOUSLY
ABOUT WE THINK ARE CLOSELY
LINKED TO THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
OR WHERE WE ARE PUTTING OUR
PERSONAL DOLLARS TODAY THERE
LIKELY OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT WE
COULD BE DOING THAT -- WE HAVE
DE EMPHASIZE BECAUSE THEY ARE
LESS -- BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED
RESOURCES AND THEY'RE LESS
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE VISION.
WELL I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
THIS BUT WE PROBABLY SHOULD
EXPLORE WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE INTERNALLY HAS THE
CAPABILITY OF DOING THAT SORT OF
ASSESSMENT OR WHETHER WE NEED TO
LAUNCH THE STATE AUDITOR OVER
THERE AND LET THE STATE AUDITOR
DO THE THEY'RE GONNA BE NERVOUS.
MAN FOR A STUDY BUT WE NEED TO
DO IT BECAUSE MEASURE BECAUSE AS
YOU WILL NOTE WE NEED TO WE NEED
TO FIX THE THINGS IN THE NEXT
ISSUE AS WE GET THEIR CENTER
LIVE ANY QUESTIONS.
ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS.
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AGAIN IT'S A HOLD
OPEN ITEM WE WILL REVISIT IT
NEXT WEEK [inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE -- THREE ITEMS SIXTY
FOUR FORTY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S SIXTY SIX ONE ZERO
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY SET
SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THE ISSUE
IS ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES
.
MA'AM WE CAN PULL UP ANOTHER
SERGEANTS OR HELP WITH YOUR
THEIR WE'LL MAKE YOU DO YOUR OWN
CHAIR [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S HAVE EVERYONE
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT OF
YOUR HERE [inaudible]
MA'AM.
KERRY READ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MARSALA RUIZ
CHIEF OF THE IMMIGRATION REFUGEE
PROGRAMS BRANCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
SAY EVER CANON UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
CHRISTIAN ASPEN YOUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IT HOUSING.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OKAY HOWEVER KEEP IT ALL
STRAIGHT BUT THAT'S OKAY WHO
WANTS TO START.
I THINK THIS PURPOSE.
BRIEF PRESENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MICHELLE
NEW IN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
INVESTMENTS IN LEGAL SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED AND IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF FOR
EACH SEGMENT.
THIS INCLUDES TEN MILLION ON
GOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SEVEN MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CSU.
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION ON
GOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE UC
SPECIFICALLY STARTING IN. TWENTY
TWENTY WO TWENTY THREE THESE
INVESTMENTS WERE ADOPTED AS ONE
TIME FINDING IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT AND OUR
BUDGET AS ON GOING FUNDING. TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
STABLE FUNDING AND SUPPORT. FOR
THE UC SPECIFICALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES THE
ONE TIME FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
LEGAL SERVICES IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
IS SUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT ITS
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM THROUGH
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR.
THE LEGAL SERVICES MAY INCLUDE.
SERVICES SUCH AS ASSISTING
APPLICANTS SEEKING DEFERRED
ACTION FOR CHILDHOOD ARRIVALS OR
DACA.
ASSISTING APPLICANTS SEEKING
NATURALIZATION.
AND PROVIDING LEGAL ADVICE AND
REPRESENTATION FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THE X..
AGO NEXT IN LINE.
POLICY HOUSE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE MISTER AS
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE OTHER
PANELISTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
HAVE USE THIS YEAR TO PLAN FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
PROGRAM -- ON CAMPUSES IMMIGRANT
LEGAL SERVICES.
FOR STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES.
AS A RESULT OF FUNDS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED.
I DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
FOR LEGAL SERVICES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THAT CURRENT YOUR
MONEY IS NOT BEEN SPENT YET --
IN THE US IT'S AVAILABLE TO
COVER PROGRAM COSTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
WITH US RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO CARRY OVER AND USE.
THE UNSPENT FUNDS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE USE THE FUNDS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IN HIS
JANUARY BUDGET OF FOUR OF OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
SO AND THEN TO ASSIST THE
LEGISLATURE IN DETERMINING AN
APPROPRIATE FUNDING LEVEL FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
THE FOLLOWING YEAR THAT IS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND IN AND OUT
YEARS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED APARTMENT
SOCIAL SOCIAL SERVICES. TO OUR
REPORT NEXT SPRING ON WORKLOAD
DEMAND WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SEEN ON THE GROUND IN TERMS OF
STUDENTS SEEKING LEGAL SERVICES.
AND THEN -- THAT INFORMATION CAN
BE USED TO HELP GUIDE THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION ON THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING LEVEL.
422-000-2020 -- ONE AS YOUR
AGENDA NOTES ON PAGE.
I THINK IT'S THIRTY TWO UNLIKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CSU YOU
SEE HAS ITS OWN.
A LEGAL SERVICE CENTER ITS OWN
PROVIDER WHICH IS THROUGH UC
DAVIS LAW SCHOOL.
AND THUS DOES NOT GO THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
LEGAL SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANTS.
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU SEE YOU SEE LIKELY WILL NOT
SPEND ITS CURRENT YEAR
APPROPRIATION BY THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY WE
DISAGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
THE STATE APPROPRIATION -- IS
NOT NEEDED -- CURRENTLY -- AND
IN ORDER FOR YOU SEE TO SUSTAIN
ITS LEGAL SERVICE PROGRAM IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
WE ALSO HAVE -- RECOMMENDATION
THE UC REPORT NEXT SPRING ON ITS
WORKLOAD WHAT IT SEEN ON THE
GROUND IT'S OPERATIONAL COSTS.
TO HELP THE LEGISLATURE IDENTIFY
APPROPRIATE FUNNY LEVEL IN THE
OUT YEARS.
AND MOVING FORWARD WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER THE PROS AND CONS OF
HAVING YOU SEE DELIVER ITS OWN
LEGAL SERVICES AT A MOST OF ITS
CAMPUSES AS OPPOSED.
TO HAVING THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES TO DELIVER THE SERVICES
WHICH IS -- ADMINISTER THE THE
PROGRAM WHICH IS AFTER ALL THE
THE WAY THAT THEY'RE GOING
FORWARD FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND CSU.
OF COURSE YOU SEE HAS A SERIES
OF LAW SCHOOLS AND PROGRAMS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO YOU SEE THAT
ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO THE OTHER.
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS SO I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE WOULD.
NOT INVOLVE THE UC LAW SCHOOLS
IN THE FACULTY AND THE STUDENTS
AND THE REST IN THIS PROCESS.
AND TURN IT OVER TO AN AGENCY
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT.
AS WELL EQUIPPED.
TO RUN A LEGAL SERVICES DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
SO YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THAT
THEY ADMINISTER PRETTY LARGE
LEGAL SERVICE.
PROGRAM -- CONTRACTING WITH A
NUMBER OF NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO.
THAT IS A PRETTY ESTABLISHED
PROGRAM JUST BE TAKING A LOOK AT
COSTS THE COST STRUCTURE.
WHETHER QUALITY COST IS
DIFFERENT BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS
SOCIAL SERVICES AND HOW THAT
PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED VERSUS
HOW YOU SEE.
ADMINISTERS ITS PROGRAM WELL
SOMEBODY'S GONNA HAVE YOU DO AS
LA -- DONE A STUDY ON THAT NOW
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO HAVE TO DO A
STUDY ON THAT.
TO CONVINCE ME BUT RIGHT I'M OF
TRY TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND SO IF
WE IN FACT RE DIRECT MONEY OR OR
DO NOT FUND -- AS OF AS
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED.
IF THE CASE LOAD OR THE WORKLOAD
IS HIGHER THAN ANTICIPATED I
ASSUME THAT THESE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS COULD COME BACK MID
YEAR FOR OF BUDGETARY ADJUSTMENT.
THAT'S THAT'S AN OPTION --
SOMETHING LIKE KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IS ENTERED INTO
CONTRACTS FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SERVICES.
AND SO THEY HAVE A TOTAL OF A
REMINDER SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT.
IN CURRENT YOUR MONEY IT'S AGAIN
ON SPENT TO GOING INTO THE
BUDGET YEAR.
WHAT DAVID WHAT THEY'VE ENTERED
IN THESE CONTRACTS WITH THESE
SERVICE PROVIDERS?
TOTALS ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR.
LEAVING THEM ABOUT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS OF FOR THE FOLLOWING
YEAR NOW IF.
IF -- WHAT DSS FOUND ON THE
GROUND IT CSU CAMPUSES WITH THAT
WAS THAT THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS
NEED?
AND THAT THE LEVEL OF FINE THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING AND STAFFING
WAS INAPPROPRIATE DSS ALREADY
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO TAKE THE
ONEY THEY ASSUMED WAS GOING TO
BE SPENT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND MOVE IT FORWARD TO NINETEEN
TWENTY PERFECT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I WOULD WANT.
TO HEAR BECAUSE IF THERE IS A
NEED I DON'T WANT TO NEED TO GO
ON MATT.
IN THIS AREA IT'S PRETTY
CRITICAL AREA IN A VERY.
IMPORTANT ONE I KNOW TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
TO IN THIS BUILDING THAT YES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
WHO'S NEXT.
YOU SEE YES I'VE BEEN NOMINATED --
THROUGH THE STRAW.
THANK YOU TO OUR AWESOME MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO DISCUSS THE-UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
DOCUMENTS STUDENT LEGAL SERVICES
WITH YOU TODAY I'M GOING TO KEEP
MY PRESENTATION QUITE SHORT
TODAY.
ARE RECOGNIZING THE GROWING NEED
FOR LEGAL SERVICES ON UC
CAMPUSES BEGINNING IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN UC PRESIDENT APOLLO TANO
PROVIDED FUNDING FOR LOW FOR A
LEGAL CENTER AT UC DAVIS.
THE CENTER OPENS WITH FOR STAFF
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR A
PARALEGAL IN TO LEGAL HELLO.
IT QUICKLY BECAME APPARENT THAT
THERE WAS A GREAT DEAL OF NEED --
FORTY SERVICES IN THE UC
COMMUNITY BETWEEN THE CENTER'S
OPENING AND JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ANNUAL GREAT CASELOAD GROUP BY
THREE HUNDRED AND 40%.
FROM INITIALLY THREE HUNDRED
ELEVEN CASES TO ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
CASES IN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN I'M BY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN USE YOUR P.
SUPPORT FOR IMMIGRANT LEGAL
SERVICES CENTER HAD GROWN TO
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WE HAVE.
WITH FOUR CAMPUSES MATCHING
CONTRIBUTIONS BY UNDING LAWYERS
ON THEIR OWN CAMPUSES.
I IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
LEGISLATURE GENEROUSLY PROVIDED
A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR.
ALLOCATION FOR YOU SEE ON
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS STAFF AND
FACULTY LEGAL SERVICES.
WE WILL BEGIN EXPENDITURES FROM
WHEN DO YOU SEE OKAY FUNDS RUN
OUT -- WITH STARTING AT A ONE
POINT THREE MILLION ANNUALLY.
SO WILL SPEND IT OVER THREE
YEARS AND IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
RUNNING OUT OF FUNDS IT'LL BE IN
THE THIRD YEAR WE WOULD RETURN
TO YOU TO DISCUSS.
UP FURTHER ALLOCATIONS OF THE
STATE FUNDS WILL ALLOW THE
IMMIGRANTS SERVICES CENTER TO
FUND ELEVEN STAFF FOR ALLOCATED
WHO ARE LOCATED THE CAMPUSES.
THE GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF
CASES SHOWS THAT THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL OF NEED FOR THESERVICES.
FOR STUDENTS AND UNCERTAIN
IMMIGRATION STATUS TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE BY HELPING STUDENTS
TO ACCURATELY FILED HER
PAPERWORK AND PROCESS THEIR
CASES WERE ASSISTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
HAVE PROVEN THAT THEY HAVE A
GREAT.
CITY TO POSITIVELY CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROPOSAL PROVIDES CONTINUITY OF
SERVICES AND WE REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISED BUDGET FOR YOU SEE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES.
THAT'S THE FUNDING STARTING IN --
TWENTY TWO PERFECT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS MAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA SENATOR
LEYVA MY NAME IS KERRY READ THAT
I AM THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR AND CHIEF COUNSEL OF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY.
WITH ME TODAY AND AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS IS DOCTOR ANNA AGUAYO
BRYANT ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
STUDENT PROGRAMS.
AS PART OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS
BOTH DOCTOR ACQUIRE BRYANT AND I
HAVE WORKED IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
CONCERNING THE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION TO DSS. TO
PROVIDE DIRECT LEGAL SERVICES TO
PERSONS ON CSU CAMPUSES.
FROM THE INITIATION OF THIS
PROJECT CSU HAS ENGAGED CAMPUS
LEADERSHIP AND KEY STAFF AND
ASSESSING THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
TO DETERMINE THE PRIORITY OF
SERVICES.
AND WE CONVEYED THIS INFORMATION
TO DSS TO HELP DESIGN A LEGAL
SERVICES MODEL SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR CAMPUS COMMUNITIES.
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT FOR
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED TO DELIVER
DIRECT LEGAL SERVICES AT TWENTY
OF THE TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES.
DSS CONTINUES TO SEARCH FOR A
PROVIDER ON THE CENTRAL COAST TO
DELIVER SERVICES TO THE MONTEREY
BAY AND SAN LUIS OBISPO CAMPUSES.
A PROVIDER WILL NOT BE ASSIGNED
TO THE CAL MARITIME CAMPUS.
STUDENTS AND STAFF AT THESE
CAMPUSES WILL BE INVITED TO
LEGAL SERVICE OFFENSE AT
NEIGHBORING CAMPUSES WILL BE
PROVIDED OTHER SUPPORT.
LEGAL SERVICES ARE BEING ROLLED
OUT REGION.
THEY ALSO RESERVE ARE BEING
ROLLED OUT BY REGION ON
DIFFERENT SCHEDULES OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS.
AND SOME ARE ALREADY IN PLACE.
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
CAMPUSES IN PROVIDERS TO
FACILITATE THE SUCCESSFUL
DELIVERY OF SERVICES ON EACH
CAMPUS.
WELL SERVICES WILL VERY BASED ON
CAPACITY IN NEED LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS WILL BE ON CAMPUS ONCE
OR TWICE A WEEK WITH AN ATTORNEY
AND PARALEGAL FOR A FULL DAY OF
APPOINTMENTS.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL
ASSIST CAMPUS EFFORTS TO PROMOTE
LEGAL SERVICE PROGRAMS THROUGH A
VARIETY OF MEANS INCLUDING CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH CAMPUS
RESOURCE CENTERS SOCIAL MEDIA
AND OUR INTERNET RESOURCES
RESOURCE PAGES.
IN ADDITION DEVELOPING DIRECTLY
CALL SERVICE PROGRAM CSU NDSS
ALSO PROVIDED EDUCATION OUTREACH
SUPPORT SERVICES TO OUR CAMPUSES.
AFTER OUR FIRST MEETING WITH DSS
WE BOTH RECOGNIZED THAT IT WAS
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME TO GET
OUR LEGAL SERVICE PROGRAMS UP
AND RUNNING.
UP BUT WE REALIZED THAT THE NEED.
FOR LEGAL SUPPORT WAS IMMEDIATE.
WE CREATED A TWO TRACK PROCESS A
LONG RANGE PROCESS TO DEVELOP
LEGAL SERVICES.
AS WELL AS AN EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PROCESS TO ADDRESS
IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
WE REACHED OUT TO OUR COLLEAGUES
AT TE UC WHO AGREED TO HOST
THREE WEBINARS ON TOPICS
SELECTED BY OUR STUDENTS.
THE FIRST WEB IN OUR UPDATES ON
DHAKA IMMIGRATION AND YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
WAS HELD THE SAME DAY THAT THE
NINTH CIRCUIT ISSUED ITS
DECISION ON DHAKA.
IN FACT THE DECISION CAME OUT
JUST A LITTLE OVER AN HOUR
BEFORE THE WEAPON ARE.
SO OUR PRESENTERS WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A VERY REAL TIME UPDATE.
IN ADDITION TO BEING VERY TIMELY.
THE WEAPON ARE WAS ALSO VERY
WELL ATTENDED AND INCLUDED
PARTICIPANTS FROM ALL TWENTY
THREE CSU CAMPUSES AND MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ALL THREE WEBINARS ARE POSTED
ONLINE AND AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC
VIEWING.
BECAUSE THE NEED FOR ACCURATE
AND CURRENT INFORMATION IS
CRITICAL IN AN ENVIRONMENT OF
RAPID CHANGE.
CSU NDSS ALSO INTEND TO CONTRACT
WITH THE PROVIDER TO CREATE AN
ONLINE HUB WITH UPDATED LAW AND
POLICY INFORMATION.
PACKAGE IN A WAY THAT'S
ACCESSIBLE TO OUR STUDENT
POPULATION.
I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE LEGAL
SERVICES MODEL DESIGNED BY CSU
AND DSS WAS BASED ON OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION WOULD
BE ONE TIME FUNDING.
DSS IS NEGOTIATING TO YOUR
CONTRACTS WITH PROVIDERS.
AND BECAUSE OF LIMITED DURATION
ARE PROVIDERS WON'T BE ABLE TO
ASSIST INDIVIDUALS WITH MATTERS
THAT ARE TOO COMPLICATED OR
REQUIRE SRVICE THAT EXCEED THE
CONTRACT PERIOD.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING COULD EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF THESE IMPORTANT
SERVICES.
CSU WAS EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR
THE FUNDING WHAT OULD WE
BELIEVE THE COST OF LEGAL
SERVICE EXCEEDS THE CURRENT
ALLOCATION.
CSU ESTIMATES THAT WE ENROLL
BETWEEN NINE TO ELEVEN THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT OUR STUDENT
POPULATION IS CHANGING AND THE
NUMBER OF UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
WHO DON'T HAVE DOC AS GROWING.
WHICH IN TURN INCREASES THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE NEED FOR
DIRECTLY CALL SERVICES.
AND WHILE SERVING ARE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IS A TOP
PRIORITY.
MANY STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES WITH
LAWFUL IMMIGRATION STATUS ARE
ALSO VERY MUCH IN NEED OF LEGAL
SERVICES.
SEVERAL RECENTLY ENACTED A
PROPOSED CHANGES TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
DIRECTLY AFFECT INDIVIDUALS WITH
LAWFUL IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
ASSESS THE TATE DIRECTLY CALL
SERVICES.
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE
PROPOSAL FOR RECURRING FINDING
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER SERVE OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR PROGRESS WITH YOU AND
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WELL I WOULD NORMALLY WAIT LET
ME JUST ASK.
ONE NOTING THE DIFFICULTY IN
SECURING A CONTRACTOR FOR THE
CENTRAL COAST.
CHANNEL ISLANDS AND WAS OBISPO
MODERATE DAY.
AND IN THE IN THE INTERIM UNTIL
YOU FIND ONE HAVE YOU HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT PARTNERING.
WITH THEM.
ON THEIR LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE IS A
UC SANTA BARBARA.
WE WE HAVEN'T HAD.
A CAN DEFER TO DSS WITH IT IF
THEY HAD THE DISCUSSIONS ARE
CHANNELISLAND CAMPUS IS GOING
TO BE COVERED THERE IF THEY HAVE
BEEN ADDED TO ONE OF THE REGION
SO THAT.
INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE THAT
WE HAVE AN UPDATE TO THAT SO
IT'S ONLY TWO CAMPUSES BUT I
KNOW THAT DSS HAS REACHED OUT TO
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROVIDERS.
WELL YOU MIGHT CHECK WITH THE
LADIES SITTING NEXT TO YOU THERE
IS.
THERE IS A CAMPUS AT SANTA
BARBARA THE LAST TIME I CHECKED
NOW I REALIZE THERE'S YOU KNOW
TIME AND SPACE ISSUES HAVING TO
DO WITH SAN LUIS OBISPO BUT IT'S
NOT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
EARTH SO.
IF WE HAVE IF WE HAVE A NEED IN
THE NEED IS CRITICAL -- ON IN
THE SHORT RUN WE CAN PROBABLY
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MOVE THE MONEY
AROUND. TOO TO PROVIDE FOR THE
SERVICE IF IF THAT'S POSSIBLE I
JUST WAS ASKING IF THERE'D BEEN
A CONVERSATION.
ABSOLUTELY I AND I CAN -- SPEAK
MORE TO THAT GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
MARC MY SALARY DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU TERRY
ROTH US ON THAT ARE LAID BACK --
I THINK IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTACTS ON THE LEGAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED -- AND LEGAL
SERVICES FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE.
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES -- TO UNDERSTAND THAT
GROWTH IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
WHY THIS IS CURRENTLY HOUSE BUT
IN SOCIAL SERVICES -- SO
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT IS
ADMINISTERING SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LEGAL
SERVICES AND FUNDS OVER HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES INCLUDING EDUCATION OUT
REACH THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS GROWN
AT TWENTY FIVE FOLD OVER -- OVER
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD IT STARTED
WITH A THREE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS.
AND NOW WITH THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM THAT
COVERS EVERYTHING FROM
NATURALIZATION TO DOCTOR
RENEWALS AND REMOVAL DEFENSE.
CDSS BONDS NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
IF I MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND TO WHEN THE PROGRAM WAS
EXPANDED INTO -- HIGHER
EDUCATION.
FUNDING WAS AWARDED TO CDSS TO
ADMINISTER BECAUSE OF THAT
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BOTH IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WITH THE
CS USE.
AND AS AN INITIAL ROLLOUT OF THE
FUNDING WE HAD EXTENSIVE
COMMUNICATION WITH THE UC SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE ALSO FUND THEM FOR
SOME OF THEIR LEGAL SERVICES --
THIS.
PROJECT IS UNFOLDING IN -- IN A
AND THE CONTACTS THAT I WOULD
SAY IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
I THINK. THREE THREE ELEMENTS
ONE IS THAT THIS IS ABOUT
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION ON THE ONE
HAND YOU HAVE THE LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDER IS INTEGRATING THEIR
SERVICES WITH TWO VERY DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS THE CSU.
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IT'S ALSO HAPPENING IN THE
CONTEXT OF GREAT EXPANSION FOR
THE LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS AND
IT IS A SERVICE WHICH REQUIRES
HIGHLY TRAINED INDIVIDUALS
MAINLY LAWYERS.
IT IS NOT A IT IS NOT IT A TYPE
OF SERVICE THAT IT'S EASY TO
EXPAND QUICKLY IT REQUIRES YES
MONEY BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES TIME.
AND ON TOP OF THAT THIS IS BEING
ROLLED OUT IN THE CONTEXT OF
RAPIDLY CHANGING IN A VERY
VOLATILE HEIL.
OF FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW AND
POLICY LANDSCAPE AND SO ALL OF
THOSE FACTORS HAVE TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THINKING ABOUT THE
TIME LINE FOR THE ROLL OUT OF OF
OF THIS PROJECT.
THAT SAID -- WITH THAT WITH THE
CS USE WE HAVE WE ARE IN IN IN
IN THE FINAL CONVERSATIONS AND
WILL BE M. X. ANY CONTRACTS TO
ABOUT FIVE PROVIDERS FOR OVER
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OFTHE
SEVEN MILLION.
DOLLARS THAT WERE ALLOCATED FOR
THE CSU AND I WANT TO REITERATE
SOMETHING THAT WAS SAID BY BY
THE CSU.
BY DESIGN -- WE HELD BACK SOME
OF THE FUNDING BECAUSE IT WAS
CONTEMPLATED THAT IT WAS ONE
TIME FUNDING WHEN IT WAS FIRST
APPROPRIATED.
AND SO WE CUT IT AND THE LAST TO
KNOW ONE TIME ONE YEAR
IMMIGRATION PROGRAM WE WANTED TO
BUILD OUT THE PROGRAM FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS SO BY DESIGN WE
DID HOME HEALTH.
HOLD BACK SOME OF THE FUNDING OF
COURSE OF THAT FUNDING BECOMES
ON GOING IT CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE EXPANSIVE
SERVICE ALSO TO EXPAND THAT.
THE SCHOOL BOTH THE SCOPE IN THE
BREATH OF THE SERVICE RIGHT NOW
THE THE THE PROGRAM IS TARGETING
LEGAL CONSULTATIONS.
BUT WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
COULD CONTEMPLATE EXPANDING
EXPANDING THE RESOURCE TO TO
ENSURE LEGAL REPRESENTATION IN
MORE COMPLEX CASES.
THE ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR CONTEMPLATING
HIRING NINETEEN LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE MOSTLY ATTORNEYS. TO
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS TWO OF
THEM ARE EXPANDING -- ARE
EXPANDING IN OPENING UP NEW
OFFICES ONE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ANOTHER IN SAN BERNADINE NOW.
AND AS AS THE CSU MENTIONED THIS
IS A PROJECT THAT IS BEING
PHASED IN SO THE INITIAL STAGES
WERE EDUCATION AND NOW REACH NOW
WE ARE ROLLING OUT THE LEGAL
SERVICES.
AS WE COLLECT MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF ON THE
CAMPUSES THEN WE CAN ADJUST THE
CONTRACTS TO ENSURE MAYBE
GREATER SCOPE OR OR BREATH AND
IN TERMS OF THE REPRESENTATION.
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE A
NEGOTIATIONS ARE ONGOING WE ARE
CONTEMPLATING THAT SOME OF THE
VERY SAME SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE DELIVERING THE
PROGRAM ON THE CSU CAMPUSES WILL
ALSO BE DELIVERING THAT PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
NOW THAT WE HAVE A DESIGN THAT
WE HAVE A PROG PROGRAM DESIGN WE
WE CAN ASK FOR EXPANSION OF OF
OF SERVICES ON THOSE CAMPUSES
BUT IT IS GOING TO TAKE A MUCH
MORE LOCALIZED IN REGIONAL
APPROACH WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
WITH THE CSU WE WERE ABLE TO
HAVE MORE OF A TOP DOWN APPROACH
IN TERMS OF WORKING WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
ARE WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP ON
THE GROUND WITH THE WITH THE
COLLEGES AND WE HAVE AN EVENT ON
MAY SEVENTEENTH IN SAN DIEGO TO
SPEAK TO THOSE LOCAL COLLEGES.
AND PLAN TO MOVE ON TO TO THE LA
REGION CENTRAL CENTRAL VALLEY
AND UP.
HOW DO YOU SURE WAS A QUALITY
CONTROL PROCESS IN THIS
ABSOLUTELY YOU HAVE A ZERO
TURNING YOUR GROUP OF ATTORNEYS
ON STAFF OF [inaudible]
TO ASSESS THE WELL ACTUALLY I AM
AN ATTORNEY SO I OVERSEE THE
PROGRAM -- AND SHOULD HAVE HEARD
FOR ONE PERSON.
TO OVERSEE ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE FIVE OR SIX PROVIDERS AND
CORRECTLY OVERSEE ONE HUNDRED
PROVIDERS -- WITH IT WITH THE
DSS FUNDING THERE'S THAT THERE'S
A SERIES OF A CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE BUILT INTO
THE INTO THE CODE -- REQUIRING
AT A CERTAIN LEVEL OF EXPERIENCE
OF OUR PROVIDERS -- WE ALSO A
SASS THE QUALITY OF THE SERVICE --
BY VERIFYING BY VERIFYING -- ANY
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS OR PARK-COMPLAINTS AGAINST ANY OF THE
PROVIDERS WE CONDUCT SITE VISITS
WITH OR PROVIDERS TO ALSO
ENSURE THE QUALITY THE QUALITY
OF THE WORK CASE FILE REVIEW
CASE POVERTY CORRECT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHRISTMAS MANY AGAIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT
THIS CONVERSATION THIS IS A
PLACE WHERE A CHANCE LOCALLY
AGAIN.
I THINK HIS -- YOU KNOW REALLY
FELT THAT THERE IS A NEED FOR
STRONG STATE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION LEADERSHIP
PARTICULARLY GIVEN.
THE UNCERTAINTY THAT OUR
STUDENTS SPACE AND WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS NEED IN OUR SYSTEM.
THE ANSWER TO YOUR THAT THEY
FACE GIVE AND JUST FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE LARGELY PLAYED FOR THE
THE TEN MILLION INCLUDED IN THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET A
SUPPORTIVE ROLE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
HAS YOUR LIKELY AWARE THE
STATUTE ASSIGNED TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE ROLE OF
SELECTING A LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT TO SEND THE
MONEY.
TO THAT DISTRICT THAT HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF CONTRACTING
WITH DSS. TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
SO AFTER CONVERSATIONS -- WITHIN
THE SYSTEM WE SELECTED LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE THEY ARE
BOTH CHAMPIONS OF THIS ISSUE
CHANCELLOR FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ A
LONG BEACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT HAS BEEN A CHAMPION ON
ON THESE ISSUES.
AND THEY AGREED TO ADMINISTER
THE FUND TRANSACTION.
WITHOUT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND
SO WE'VE DISTRIBUTED THE MONEY
TO LA CCD LA CCD HAS ENTERED
INTO A CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES IS
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM. TO
YOUR ONCE IN THE LAST PANEL I
WOULD JUST SAY -- CAN I THINK
THIS IS NOT AN AREA WHERE THE
CHANCES OFFICES BEEN RESOURCE
FOR WORK.
RELATED TO A LEGAL SERVICES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
AND SO WE DON'T HAVE A BUILT UP
CAPACITY IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE BUT AGAIN THIS IS BUT AN
AREA THAT THE CHANCELLOR.
NO REALLY THINKS IS IMPORTANT
FOR OUR SYSTEM TO TAKE A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THE
CONVERSATION.
THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHICH IS AN AUTHORIZED
FOUNDATION AND AUXILIARY OF OUR
OFFICE.
HAS REALLY DONE A LOT OF THE
WORK SUPPORTED BY PHILANTHROPIC
FUNDS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE ISSUES.
I'VE PASSED OUT A REPORT THAT
WAS PRODUCED EARLIER THIS YEAR --
AS A RESULT OF A DREAMERS
PROJECT THAT WAS LED AGAIN BY
OUR FOUNDATION -- WITH SUPPORT
OF THE JAMES IRVINE FOUNDATION.
OF THAT REALLY DID A LOT OF THE
LANDSCAPE STUDENTS WHERE DO WE
HAVE CENTERS WHAT ARE THE THE
STAFFING RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
THE STUDENTS WHAT ARE KIND OF
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE STUDENTS
NEEDS.
I THINK YOU KNOW TO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
THIS BEING A SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
PROJECT I THINK A LARGE PART OF
OUR ROLE HAS BEEN TO DO THIS
KIND OF WORK AND TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND BETTER UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS AVAILABLE
AT THE COLLEGES -- AND IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO OUR FOCUS THEIR
LEGAL SERVICES JUST SOME QUICK
FINDINGS FROM THE REPORT. THIRTY
FIVE OF OUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
COLLEGES CURRENTLY HAVE TREE
RESOURCE CENTERS.
OF THOSE THIRTY FIVE NINETEEN
HAVE STAFF THAT ARE DEDICATED.
TO THAT PROJECT I'LL
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO
LEGAL SERVICES SIXTY FIVE
COLLEGES OFFER REFERRALS TO
RELIABLE LEGAL SOURCES SEVENTEEN
COLLEGES PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES
CURRENTLY ON THEIR CAMPUSES. TEN
HAVE SCREENING ANOTHER TRIAGE
SERVICES.
AND THEN SIX HAVE COLLABORATIONS
WITH LOCAL LAW SCHOOLS.
I'M IN SO I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW
TO THE EXTENT THAT.
SO WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE HOW
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERED CURRENTLY TO THE
EXTENT OF THEIR ONGOING FUNDS AS
PER BY THE GOVERNOR.
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE COMFORTABLE
THAT EXISTING FRAMEWORK.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE US -- OUR OFFICE BUT YOUR
GREATER ROLE -- YEAH I THINK TO
YOUR CONVERSATION A CENTER I
THINK THINK WE WE WOULD WANT TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
ARE THE TYPES OF RESOURCES OUR
OFFICE WOULD NEED IN ORDER TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM BUT I
THINK.
WE THINK THE PROGRAM.
WE ARE COMFORTABLE -- THAT IT'S
BEING ADMINISTERED EFFECTIVELY --
BY DSS -- PARTNERSHIP WERE
OFFICE AND WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUED
COLLABORATION.
WELL THE REASON I MADE THE
COMMENTS I DID AMONG OTHERS
INCLUDING THE ISSUES HAVING TO
DO WITH WHETHER OR NOT WE HEARD
PEOPLE IN UNDER THE OTHER ISSUE.
AND COULD TRACK OF HAS TO DO
WITH THE COMMENTS IN OUR
ANALYSIS THAT THE CHANCES OFFICE
TRANSFERRED AUTHORITY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
OFFERING ME COACH FOUNDATION
WHICH I ASSUME IS A FIVE OH ONE
C. THREE IT IS BUT I I WOULD
JUST WANT TO CLEARLY THAT'S TRUE
THAT'S AN ACCURATE AND IN FACT
THE AUTHORITIES TRANSFERRED --
ALONG LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND IT WHICH IS CAN
SYSTEM OF THE SO THE STATUTE
VERY EXPLICITLY DIRECTS OUR
OFFICE TO SELECT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WHICH WE'VE
DONE.
AND YOU THOUGHT AND CONSISTENT A
STATUTE LA'S CCD HAS CONTRACTED
WITH DSS I THINK THE CONFUSION
MIGHT BE AROUND.
THE FACT THAT THE FOUNDATION HAS
TAKEN THE LEAD ON BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THESE ISSUES AND I
THINK THAT IS REALLY -- MAYBE TO
YOUR POINT -- INDICATIVE OF
RESOURCES THAT GIVEN CHANCELLOR --
PLEASE.
THE LEVEL OF IMPORTANCE IS
PLACED ON THIS ISSUE.
NO I THINK WE WE DECIDED WE
NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING ON THESE
ISSUES -- WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
LARGE COUNTRY WERE POPULATION IN
THE SYSTEM.
AND SO WE'VE WORKED TO GENERATE
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS ARE
MECHANISM FOR COLLECTING
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS THIS
THROUGH THAT FOUNDATION AND SO
THEY'VE REALLY -- BUILT UP THE
CAPACITY IN THE SHORT TERM AT
LEAST OUT TO DO THE KIND OF WORK --
INCLUDING THE REPORT THAT WE'VE.
PASSED OUT I HAVE NO TROUBLE
WITH FOUNDATIONS DOING STUDIES
AND PROVIDING THEM TO GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTIONS SO THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE OUR PROCESSES I WAS JUST
CONCERNED.
ABOUT HAVING MONEY MANAGED BY A
NON GOVERNMENT ENTITY ON A ON AN
ISSUE THAT WE THINK IS AN
EXTREMELY SERIOUS ONE AND THAT'S
NOT THE CASE YOU'VE CORRECTED
THAT SO I'M FINE.
ANYTHING ELSE EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION BY THE WAY LET ME
ASK ONE OTHER QUESTION.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH BEING A
LAWYER -- WHAT'S THE RIVER
WHAT'S THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT
AND FREQUENCY.
WITH RESPECT TO CASELOAD --
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS SERVICED.
IF IF I SHOULD KNOW THAT I DON'T.
SURE SURE NO PROBLEM.
SO GENERALLY ALL OF OUR
CONTRACTORS HAVE QUARTERLY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS -- WHERE
THEY PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THE
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN SERVED IN THE TYPES OF
REMEDIES WHICH?
HAVE BEEN ASSISTED IN ADDITION
TO EITHER THE SITE VISIT OR AT
DUSK REVIEW WHERE THEY PROVIDE
THE CASE INFORMATION WE REVIEW
THE CASE FILES.
SO ON SOME BASIS AYE ASSUMES AT
LEAST THE GENERIC VERSION OF THE
DATA YOU COULD PROVIDE TO OF
COMMITTEE STAFF.
ONCE THE CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN
EXECUTED AND THERE'S THE START
THE REPORTING PROCESS UP.
WE CERTAINLY ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
POPULAR REPORT.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU SEE HAS BEEN PROVIDING
IT BECAUSE THEY SEE THAT IN OUR
IN OUR AGENDA.
YES WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE
PERFECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO EVERYONE STRAP IN WE'RE NOT
READY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YET.
REMEMBER WHAT I SAID EARLIER --
I I WILL NEED TO PRESENT THE
VERY IS BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
WERE NOT PRESENTED -- PREVIOUSLY
AND THERE ARE A FEW OF THEM SO I
WILL MOVE QUICKLY.
AS QUICKLY AS I CAN.
BOND ISSUE NUMBER ONE ADDITIONAL
BUDGET REQUEST EARLY EDUCATION
AND K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
ITEM ONE BE ARMENIAN GENERAL
BENEVOLENT UNION BUDGET REQUEST
IS TO APPROPRIATE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR THE ARMENIAN GENERAL
BENEVOLENT UNION.
GENERATION NEXT PROGRAM CHEN
NEXT CURRENTLY OPERATES AS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GLENDALE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
PROVIDES TARGETED MENTORING. FOR
YOUTH AGES TWELVE THROUGH
EIGHTEEN WHO FACE RISK FACTORS
SUCH AS GANG INVOLVEMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH DRUG ABUSE AND
POVERTY.
ITEM ONE SEE EARLY CHILDHOOD
NUTRITION THE BUDGET REQUEST IS
TO APPROPRIATE SIXTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING ONE MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND FIFTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND. TO
RESTORE THE CHILD AND ADULT CARE
FOOD PROGRAM TO CHILD CARE
SETTINGS AND TO INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR MEALS
AND CHILD CARE SETTINGS UNDER A
CASE [inaudible]
TO TWELVE SCHOOL AUTHORITY.
ITEM ONE EAT HEALTHY START THE
BUDGET REQUEST IS TO APPROPRIATE
SIXTY MILLION OLLARS OVER FOUR
YEARS TO REESTABLISH THE HEALTHY
START INITIATIVE TO COORDINATE
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL COMMUNITY
INTEGRATED SERVICES AND
ACTIVITIES. TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF USE AND
FAMILIES FUNDS WOULD BE USED FOR
TO YOUR PLANNING GRANTS TO
ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT.
LOCAL COLLABORATIVE'S IN THREE
YEAR OPERATIONAL GRANTS TO
EXISTING.
CLUBBERS FUNDS WOULD ALSO BE
USED TO SUPPORT STAFFING AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
TO SUPPORT THE GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
PROVIDE. FOR AN EVALUATION.
ITEM ONE H. CALIFORNIA GROWN FOR
HEALTHY KIDS PROGRAM BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE FIFTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH A NON
COMPETITIVE GRANT. TO PROVIDE A
TEN CENT PER BREAKFAST
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
ELIGIBLE SCHOOL FOOD AUTHORITIES
MUST SERVE BREAKFAST UNIVERSALLY
FREE.
IN ALL SCHOOLS OR SERVE
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH FREE AT VERY
HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS
[inaudible]
ITEM.
ITEM ONE I'D CALIFORNIA EXCUSE
ME SUSIE ATION.
OF STUDENT COUNCILS BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ON
GOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS THESE FUNDS
WOULD SUPPORT NEED BASED
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN.
C. A. S. C. LEADERSHIP
PREVENTION FOR OUT REACHED UNDER
REPRESENTED REGIONS IN THE STATE
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
ITEM ONE J. FOUR DAY SCHOOL WEEK.
BUDGET REQUEST ADOPT BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO CORRECT
AN EDUCATION CODE SECTION THAT
CEASES FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
OPERATING ON A FULL DAY WEEK.
AND ELIMINATE RELATED PENALTIES
FOR LEGGETT VALLEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND MENDOCINO
COUNTY AND BIG SUR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MONTEREY
COUNTY BOTH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OPERATE IN REMOTE REGIONS OF THE
STATE.
AND THIS ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN THE
AREA.
ITEM ONE K..
HOW MINUTEMAN PROGRAM BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF THE?
MINUTEMEN WESTERN REGIONS.
A RESCUE AND SCOUTING PROGRAMS
THE HOME MINUTEMAN WESTERN
REGIONS PURPOSE IS TO PROMOTE
ATHLETIC AND SCOUTING PROGRAMS
FOR THE ARMENIAN AMERICAN USE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD
SUPPORT A RASK WHICH IS AN
ARMENIAN SPECIAL NEEDS OLYMPICS
PROGRAM IN HIRING STAFF
OBTAINING EQUIPMENT RUNNING
FACILITIES AND OTHER OPERATIONAL
COSTS.
THE SCOUTING PROGRAM IS
AFFILIATED WITH THE BOY SCOUTS
OF AMERICA AND FUNDING WOULD BE
USED TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
CULTURAL TRAINING.
SCOTT LEADERSHIP CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITY CPR AND FIRST AID.
THE BSA BADGES EVENTS AND THE
REGIONAL SCOUTING JAMBOREE.
ITEM ONE L. LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA BASED FUNDING
INCREASE BUDGET REQUEST INCREASE
THE L. C. F. F. BASED FUNDING BY
PROVIDING A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. TO THE LC IF OF
FORMULA OF FIVE POINT 16% IN
PLACE OF THE CALL OF THREE POINT
46% INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
THIS INCREASE IN THE COLD WOULD
PROVIDE APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
I'LL SEE IF OF FUNDING ABOVE THE
LEVEL INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
ITEM ONE IN CHARTER
ACCOUNTABILITY RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT NETWORK.
APPROPRIATE EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT.
CARS NET WHICH PROVIDE SUPPORT
GUIDANCE AND TRAINING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION IN THEIR OVERSIGHT OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
CARS THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
THROUGH A FIVE YEAR FEDERAL
GRANT PROGRAM THROUGH SPRING OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND DURING
THIS TIME ESTABLISHED AND FUNDED
REGIONALES A DEVELOPED BEST
PRACTICES AND TEMPLATES.
FOR STATEWIDE ADOPTION AND
PROVIDED IN DEPTH TRAINING ON
BEST PRACTICES IN CHARTER
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO
AUTHORIZE YEARS.
THE FUNDS WOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CARS NET REGIONAL
LEADS TO ELEVEN AND INCREASE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
ACROSS THE STATE [inaudible]
ITEM. ONE LGBT Q. PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT BUDGET REQUEST
APPROPRIATE SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
TO SUPPORT ANNUAL TRAINING FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS STAFF AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF LESBIAN
GAY BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND
QUEER STUDENTS.
THIS TRAINING WOULD CREATE A
MORE SUPPORTIVE AND SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR LGBT Q.
STUDENTS BY REQUIRING HIGH
QUALITY AND COMPREHENSIVE LGBT
Q. CULTURAL COMPETENCY SEAT
COMPETENCY TRAINING.
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING THE ADOPTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ANTI BULLYING
POLICIES.
STUDENT PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
CREATION OF A WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT AND AWARENESS OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
ITEM ONE OR CHILD DEVELOPMENT
INSTITUTE BUDGET REQUEST
APPROPRIATE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE EARLY
CHILD AND FAMILY CENTER IN THE
WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
A PROPOSED FOR THE CENTER HAS A
NEED FOR HIGH QUALITY CHILD CARE.
THE NEW CENTER WILL PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATIONAL AND TURNING
PROGRAMS DEVELOPMENTAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SCREENING HEALTH
PROMOTION AND INTERVENTION
SERVICES.
AND RESOURCE LINKAGE.
ITEM ONE S. CALIFORNIA GROWN
FRESH SCHOOL MEALS.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING TO EXTEND
THE CALIFORNIA GROWN FRESH
SCHOOL MEALS GRANT PROGRAM.
THE STEP WAS TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
INCREASE CALIFORNIA GROWN FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
AN ON SITE PREPARATION SCHOOL
MEALS GRANTEES MAY USE FUNDS TO
PURCHASE CALIFORNIA GROWN FOODS
PURCHASE EQUIPMENT NECESSARY. TO
PROVIDE SCHOOL MEALS TO STUDENTS
PROVIDE NUTRITIONAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS TO PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
RELEVANT FOOD SERVICE EMPLOYEES
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
FRESH AND HEALTHY SCHOOL MEALS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ONE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
PROVIDED FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION.
WAS PROVIDED IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ITEM WON T. EXPERIENCE BERKELEY
HIGH SCHOOL BUDGET REQUEST
APPROPRIATE SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE STYLES.
ALL EXPERIENCE BERKELEY HIGH
SCHOOL WHICH IS A FREE SIX MONTH
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES BLACK
LATINO AND NATIVE AMERICAN HIGH
SCHOOL JUNIORS WITH MENTORS.
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO COMPLETE
A COMPETITIVE UC COLLEGE
APPLICATION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET A CLOSE PERSONAL LOOK AT
UC BERKELEY.
THIS REQUEST WOULD BE MATCHED
WITH PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS.
ITEM ONE YOU. EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS FOR PARADISE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGET REQUEST.
IT UP TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
RETAIN ITS PRE CAMP FIRE AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE LEVELS THROUGH
THE 200-022-00020 ONE FISCAL
YEAR.
IN ADDITION PROVIDE FOR A THREE
YEAR EIGHTY A RAMP DOWN PERIOD
FROM 200-021-22000 TWENTY TWO
THROUGH 200-023-22000. TWENTY
FOUR TO ALLOW THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO DETERMINE AND ADJUST
FOR NEW LONG TERM ADA
PROJECTIONS.
THE CAMP
FIRE DESTROYED MUCH OF
THE TOWN OF PARADISE IN NOVEMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
DISPLAYS THE MAJORITY OF THE
TOWN'S RESIDENTS.
AS OF MARCH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE DISTRICTS AND ROMAN
HAS DECREASED BY ALMOST HALF
WITH AND FOR THE PURPOSE OF
OFFERING. ONE OR MORE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS A
PARTICIPATING.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR COLLEGES.
THESE PARTNERSHIPS ARE INTENDED
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALS FOR STUDENTS IN
AREAS THAT DO NOT HAVE OTHER
HIGHER EDUCATION OPTIONS
.
ITEM ONE W. CALIFORNIA PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD PROGRAM BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE UP TO ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CONTINUED OPERATION OF EXISTING
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS LOCATED IN
LOS ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO CHULA
VISTA HAYWARD IN CORNING AND TO
ADD.
FIFTEEN ADDITIONAL NEIGHBORHOODS
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS UNDER THE PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD PROGRAM A LEAD
NONPROFIT AGENCIES SELECTED TO
COORDINATE SERVICES.
THAT INCLUDE NUTRITION HEALTH
CARE EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
SUPPORT FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM WAS PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED
UNDER LIMITED TERM
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS BUT HAS
SINCE.
EXPIRED.
ISSUE TWO ADDITIONAL BUDGET
REQUEST HIGHER EDUCATION.
ITEM TO A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES SCHOOL UP
WE WERE DONE THAT ONE ISSUE TO
BE CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERSITY OF
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND TO THE UC WHICH
WILL BE ALLOCATED O SUPPORT
CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERITY OF
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE.
THIS FUNDING WILL ONE INCREASE
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
ENROLLMENT BY AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS.
AS WELL AS EXPAND ACCESS TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION FOR
RESIDENTS OF SELF LOS ANGELES
AND SIMILAR COMMUNITIES. TO
EXPAND HOUSING ON CAMPUS THREE
BILL BIOSCIENCE RESEARCH
BUILDING FOR DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT AUTONOMOUS MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND FIVE DEVELOP NEW
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE.
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS.
ITEM TO SEE SENATE BILL FIVE SIX
EIGHT RAPID RE HOUSING BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THE
RAPID RE HOUSING GRANT THIS
GRANT WILL PROVIDE AN INDIVIDUAL
OR FAMILY.
IMMEDIATE TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE
FOR HOUSING SEARCH ONE TIME
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO OFFSET
MOVING COSTS ON GOING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO BRIDGE THE GAP.
BETWEEN HOUSEHOLD INCOME AND
RISING HOUSING COSTS FOR UP TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AND OTHER.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO COMMUNITY
RESOURCES FUNDING WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED BASED ON PROPORTIONS
STUDENT ROMAN EACH POP.
OF SECONDARY SEGMENT THE QUALIFY
FOR THE PROGRAM EACH CAMPUS MUST
IMPLEMENT SPECIFIC REFORMS
INCLUDING A POLICY. TO
PRIORITIZE HOMELESS AND FOSTER
YOU STUDENTS IN THE TIMING OF
THE DISTRIBUTION OF FINANCIAL
AID.
FOOD MUST BE ENROLLED AT LEAST
HALFTIME RECEIVE SERVICES
HOWEVER IF THE STUDENT FALLS
BELOW HALF TIME A STUDENT MAY
RECEIVE SERVICES. FOR UP TO SIX
MONTHS.
ITEM TWO D..
C. ISSUE WILD LAND AND WILD FOR
URBAN INTERFACE GRANT PROGRAM.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR THE
C. ISSUE TO ADMINISTER THE WILD
LAND AND WILD FOR URBAN
INTERFACE GRANT PROGRAM. TO
CONDUCT WELL FOR RESEARCH AND
SYMPOSIUMS PROVIDE EDUCATION AND
PUBLIC OUTREACH AND ESTABLISH A
MECHANISM TO DISSEMINATE
RESEARCH RESULTS.
ITEM TO EAT.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY BUDGET REQUEST
APPROPRIATE ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME. TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
ON SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY AS
FOLLOWS SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE OPERATOR OF
OPERATIONAL COSTS OF THE CCS
DECIDES FOLLOWS FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS.
AND FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
PUT IN AN ENDOWMENT TO MATCH THE
PRIVATE C. DONATION. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THIS PURPOSE.
ITEM TWO G. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHULA VISTA BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME. FOR A
POTENTIAL CAMPUS IN CHULA VISTA.
ITEM TO H. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SILICON VALLEY.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME TO
CONDUCT A FEASIBILITY STUDY AND
PLAN FOR THE CREATION OF C.
ISSUE SILICON VALLEY AT CANADA
COLLEGES EXISTING CAMPUS WITHIN
THE SAN MTTEO COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
ITEM TO OUR AYE LAKE AND
MENDOCINO COUNTY CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION BUDGET
REQUEST.
APPROPRIATE ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME TO MENDOCINO COLLEGE TO
PROVIDE START OF FUNDS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM.
IN LAKE AND MENDOCINO COUNTIES.
ITEM TWO K. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACCALAUREATE PILOT PROGRAM
BUDGET REQUEST AMEND EXISTING
LAW TO CHANGE THE DEADLINE ON
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
REPORT.
ON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAM PILOT
PROGRAM FROM JULY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TO FEBRUARY.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ITEM TWO M.
CALIFORNIA AMENITIES BUDGET
REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE LIBRARY TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA UMANITIES AND
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
CULTURAL ACTIVITIES.
ITEM TWO IN.
HISTORICALLY BACK BLACK COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES TRANSFER
PATHWAYS BUDGET REQUEST PROVIDE
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
H. B. C. YOU TRANSFER PATHWAY.
THIS PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY BEING
FUNDED BY A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT EQUITY
AND ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM.
ITEM TWO OH CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY COUNCIL ON OCEAN
AFFAIRS SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE C. ISSUE
COUNSEL ON OCEAN AFFAIRS SILENCE
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
COAST IS THE UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATION FOR MARINE COAST
ONE COASTAL WATERSHED RELATED
RESEARCH AND EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE C. ISSUE.
THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
STUDENT TRAVEL AND RESEARCH
AWARDS FACULTY INCENTIVE GRANTS
RAPID RESPONSE GRANTS AND STAFF
SUPPORT.
ITEM TWO P..
SEE ISSUE CELERY INVERSION
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS. TO THE
C. ISSUE TO ADDRESS CLASSIFIED
STAFF SALARIES AND PAY
DIFFERENTIALS BETWEEN NEW
SUPPORT STAFF AND CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED STAFF.
THIS WOULD
A BUNCH CENTER FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES BUDGET
REQUEST.
APPROPRIATE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO THE
U. C. L. A. RALPH J. BUNCHE
CENTERFOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDIES THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
PROVIDED ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONE TIME FOR THE CENTER.
ITEM TO OUR C. ISSUE DOMINGUEZ
HILLS BERMAN M. D'ITALIE AFRICAN
AMERICAN POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
INSTITUTE.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
INSTITUTE. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET PROVIDED ONE
MILLION DOLLAR.
BUDGET REQUEST APPROPRIATE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND WAS ESTABLISHED THE
MARCUS FOSTER RESEARCH
FELLOWSHIP AT UC BERKELEY SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION IN PARTNERSHIP.
WITH MARCUS FOSTER INSTITUTE THE
INSTITUTE IS LOCATED IN OAKLAND
AND NAMES TO PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES
AND OUTCOMES. FOR
STUDENTS IN OAKLAND.
FILE ITEM TO YOU.
APPROPRIATE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN SUPPORT OF THE INCARCERATION
TO EDUCATION PIPELINE THIS
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT THE
MAINTENANCE EXPANSION OF RE
ENTRY SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISHED ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND THE STATE'S COLLEGE
COMMUTERS [inaudible]
DEL PUBBLICO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
LET'S.
HERE ARE THE GROUND RULES.
LOOK AROUND YOU.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SPEAK.
I DON'T PUT A TIME CLOCK ON
ANYONE HOWEVER.
I HAVE A HARD STOP AT ABOUT
THREE THIRTY AND IT IS.
TO BECAUSE I HAVE TO AND IT IS
ABOUT.
TWO THIRTY NINE SO FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO SPEAK -- WHO ELONGATE
YOUR COMMENTS AT THE FRONT THE
ONES AT THE BACK ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE VERY SHORT SO?
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT AS WE
START.
YOU WERE UP MA'AM.
NOW HERE'S BIG THINK ON ISSUE
ONE AIMLESS LEARNER ROAD MAP
INITIATIVE -- WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AN
ALLOCATION OF THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS. ONE
TIME FUNDS TO BE.
USED TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
I GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE STUDENT
POPULATION THE POSITIVE SHIFT IN
POLICY DIRECTION CONTAINED IN
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
FRAMEWORK AND THE FACT THAT THE
ENGLISHMAN A ROAD MAP.
NEEDS TO FULLY BE ROLLED OUT AND
AND GIVEN USED AS A TOOL FOR
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS -- ALSO WANT.
TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THAT AND
HERE WITH COLLEAGUES THAT ARE CO
SPONSORING.
AFTERNOON DOCTOR MINE BUT HE
STEPPED FROM A COPY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AT BY THE
LEGISLATION.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AND
CALIFORNIANSTOGETHER AND COPY
ARE CO SPONSORING SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR IT'S THE L. ROLL BACK ROAD
MAP INITIATIVE REQUESTING THE
BUDGET APPROPRIATION.
AT THIRTEEN MILLION -- SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR WILL HELP US PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY -- FUNDS IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SPREAD THE WORD
ACROSS ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY -- GET THE L. A ROADMAP
TO BE POLICY THAT IS USD ACROSS
THE STATE ADDITIONALLY IT ALLOWS
TO PROVIDE THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT ARE TEACHERS IN
OUR ADMINISTRATORS NEED.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO USE THIS
ROADMAP AND PUT IT IN THE HANDS
OF OUR EDUCATORS IN THE
CLASSROOMS AND SEE HOW IT WORKS
WITH IN THE CLASSROOM.
ON A DAY TO DAY BEST BASIS IF WE
DON'T DO THAT.
THEN THIS JUST BECOMES A COSTLY
HAND OUT THAT'S BEEN PUT OUT
THERE AND IT DOESN'T AFFECT OUR
ENGLISH HONORS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE COUNTING ON US TO BE THEIR
VOICE AND THEIR ADVOCATES AND
PROVIDING HEM EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION THAT'S
A BETTER BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
THAT.
THANK YOU WE NEED TO DO BETTER
LOOK THEY'RE OUT THE DOOR.
HEY -- MY NAME'S MERRY BAR AND I
REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND I'M ALSO.
SCHOOL BOARD PRESIDENT FOR
CORONA NORTH UNIFIED.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY SO ON BEHALF
OF THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS AND
BILINGUAL TEACHERS.
SCHOOL OF BILINGUAL PROGRAMS I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO SUPPORT AND
APPROVED.
OF INCLUDING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY STATE BUDGET
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ESTABLISHING A SUPPORTING DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION.
AND BILINGUAL PROGRAMS FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
ALSO ON A SEPARATE REQUEST
THIRTY MILLION FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROFESSION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT. ONE ADDITIONAL REQUEST --
ITEM ONE SHE ASUS AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION SAFETY PROGRAM --
CRITICAL SUPPORTS TO SERVE.
STUDENTS AND WORKING FAMILIES
WITH AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMMING
AND ALSO -- TO SUPPORT THAT
MEDIA LITERACY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION THANK YOU
THINK YOU.
PUT PLEASE BE AS BRIEF AS YOU
CAN YOU'LL SEE THE LINE IS OUT
THE DOOR.
AND IT'S THREE THIRTY I
APOLOGIZE I HAVE TO STOP SO
WHOEVER IS LEFT STANDING.
YOU BETTER RUN SO NEXT THANK YOU
SENATOR DILUTION ON BEHALF OF
CHARLES STREET UNIVERSITY I'VE
I'M I'M NOT CONTEST BY THE
PRESIDENT INA NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
VERY BRIEFLY TO ITEM TO BE IN
SUPPORT.
WE'RE COMPLETELY IN SUPPORT OF
THAT SO IF THAT MAKES ANY
DIFFERENCE TO THE LENGTH OF YOUR
CUMMINS.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- WE'RE
HONORED TO HAVE YOU HERE SIR.
OKAY I'M DOCTOR DAVID CARLISLE
PRESIDENCY OF OUR CHARLES R.
DREW UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE
SCIENCE AND WE COME BEFORE YOU
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF OF BUDGET
REQUEST ITEM TO BE THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION OF GENERAL FUND TO
CDO.
TO FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. FOR THE PAST -- FORTY FIVE
YEARS BEFORE THE OPENING OF OUR
JOINT PROGRAM WITH UCLA.
A CALIFORNIA'S PROVIDED DIRECT
PUBLIC SERVICE FUNDS TO CD YOU
FOR GENERAL UNIVERSITY SUPPORT.
AS AUTHORIZED BY SB TEN TWENTY
SIX AUTHORED BY AMERICAN DIALING
SIGNED BY GOVERNOR RONALD REAGAN
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THE
ORIGINAL NINETY SEVEN THREE
APPROPRIATION OF ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TODAY.
AFTER ADJUSTING FOR INFLATION IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SEE RECEIVED
AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IN THE CURRENT YEAR THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
A COMMENSURATE WITH THE GROWTH
AND IMPORTS OF CD YOU AS LONG
STANDING ABILITY TO INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
PROFESSIONS.
AS WELL AS TO ENCOURAGE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO PRACTICE IN
UNDERSERVED UNDER RESOURCE AREAS.
CITY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ITEM TO BE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER THANK YOU.
ANYONE ON THIS ITEM ME TOO WOULD
BE JUST FINE.
VERY BRIEF OR DID -- DID ALL
THAT AND I'M A FOURTH YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT I'LL BE
GRADUATING IN TWENTY TWO DAYS
SIX HOURS TWENTY SEVEN MINUTES
IN A FEW SECONDS.
AND I'LL BE CONTINUE MY CAREER
AS AN ANESTHESIOLOGIST I COME
FROM THE COMMUNITY FROM WHICH
YOU MENTIONED I GREW UP IN
COMPTON.
AND I'LL BE RETURNING BACK TO
THAT COMMUNITY PROVIDE CARE --
SO THAT OUR DOCTOR COLUMN THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO YES MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS ADRIAN MARTINEZ
I AM A CERTIFIED PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE I GOT MY MASTERS IN
NURSING AT DREW I'M A FIRST
GENERATION HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE --
IN TWENTY DAYS I WILL FINISH MY
PHD IN NURSING RESEARCH I LOOK
SPECIFICALLY IT DIABETES AMONG
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
GONNA DO WHEN I GRADUATE THINK
SECURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANA BOSSY I'M A
BY A MEDICAL STUDENT UNTRUE AND
I'M ALSO PRESIDENT OF THE
STUDENT GOVERNMENT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WERE IN
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF WHATEVER DR
CARLISLE SAID AND I HOPE THAT
YOU ALLOW US TO DO WHAT WE WERE
CREATED TO DO WHICH IS HELPED
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU.
NEXT.
HI MY NAME IS JASIM CHILDRESS
AND I AM IN A SCENE STATE IN THE
ELLEN PROGRAM AT CHARLES
UNIVERSITY AND I ALSO HAD THE
HONOR OF BEING A STUDENT TRUSTEE.
AND I DID -- EVERYTHING DR
CARLISLE SAID I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU THE
NEXT.
HI MY NAME'S ABDOMEN AND I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT STUDENT
GOVERNMENT AND FOURTH YEAR OF
THE BATTLES BY MEDICAL PROGRAM
IS CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERSITY --
AND I COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE
DIED BUDGET REQUEST AS WELL
THANK YOU NEXT.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS PHYLLIS AND
THE A I AM.
I COMPLETED THE MASSES ABOUT
MEDICAL SCIENCE CHARLES TRUE AND
I'LL BE GOING TO MEDICAL SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR IN THE
FALL.
AND AGAIN I SUPPORT THE BILLS SO
I SUPPORT AND I REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU'RE NOT ONLY -- ATTENDS TO
THE HEALTH OF INDIVIDUALS BUT
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITIES IN THE
ALLOW US TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA CAMPAñA
STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY AS A
CANDIDATE FOR THE DEGREE OF
MASTER OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AN ADVOCATE FOR HEALTH POLICY
AND A CONSTITUENT THE SOUTH LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY AS WELL -- I
CHOSE DREW BECAUSE OF THE
EXCEPTIONALLY CONSCIOUS
ATMOSPHERE IN THEIR MISSION TO
ACHIEVE SOCIAL JUSTICE.
I CANNOT THINK OF AN ENDEAVOR
GREATER THAN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A FOR YOUR MEDICAL SCHOOL AT
CHARLES DREW NOR CAN I FATHOM A
BETTER TIME TO DO WITH THE NOW.
SO WITH ADEQUATE FUNDING IT IS
MY HOPE THAT CHARLES DREW WILL
CONTINUE TO STAND OUT AHEAD OF
THE CURVE.
THROUGH ITS OMMITMENT TO IN
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO CULTIVATE
THE FUTURE HEALTH LEADERS.
THAT WE AS A STATE OF SOCIETY
TODAY AND AS A CONSEQUENCE I DO
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET REQUEST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT.
I AM LESLIE CAMP AND I'M --
BASIC NEEDS CENTER DIRECTOR FOR
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND I'M HERE --
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU -- ALL I WANT TO
SAY WAS THAT -- FROM BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW AT
THE UNIVERSITY I WORK AT -- WE
HAVE -- HOMELESS MAN COMMUNITY
OF ABOUT THIRTY STUDENTS THAT'S
ONLY PART OF THE POPULATION OF
HOMELESS STUDENTS ON OUR CAMPUS.
WE RECEIVED CALLS THIS WEEK FROM
TO STUDENTS WHO ARE INCOMING
FRESHMEN AND ARE ALREADY THERE
HOMELESS NOW IN THEIR HOME
COMMUNITIES AND THEY'RE COMING
TO CAMPUS.
WE HAVE OUR STUDENTS WHO HAVE
CALLED US IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
WILL BE HOMELESS NEXT YEAR AND
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO FOR
THEM [inaudible]
OF WE KNOW THANKS TO A STUDY OUT
OF UCSF THAT -- FOOD AND
SECURITY AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY HOMELESSNESS DIRECTLY
AFFECT GPA AND GRADUATION RATES
SO THIS BILL WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS AND
HELPING THEM TO GRADUATE AND
GRADUATE IN.
FOUR THANK.
BEFORE YOU START HOW LONG IS A
LINE OUT THE DOOR. FOR ME.
OKAY HERE HONEST TO GOSH AT
THREE THIRTY I HAVE TO GO SO
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
I WOULD SAY FIFTEEN SECONDS AND
IF THEY'RE GROUPS OF YOU
SPEAKING ON THE SAME LINE ITEM
AND GATHER TOGETHER AND LET'S
GET LET'S DO IT ALL ONCE I
APOLOGIZE.
BUT SOMEBODY'S GOING TO GET CUT
OFF AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
VERY HAPPY IN THE NECK CAN BE
VERY HAPPY WITH ME.
SO HELP ME MAKE THEM HAPPY WITH
ME HOUSE A YES MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS ONE KOTOR AND A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT UC DAVIS --
WITHIN THE LAST ACADEMIC YEAR
18% OF OUR STUDENT COMMUNITY
GRADUATES AND UNDERGRADUATES
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS OR
HOUSING INSECURITY SO I'M HERE
TO SPEAK ON BEHALFOF OF SENATE
BILL -- FIVE SIXTY EIGHT I LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK I AM AT%
DOMESTIC PARTNER DISPUTE I AM.
A MEDICAL BILL AWAY FROM BEING
HOMELESS THIS DIRECTLY SUPPORTS
MY ABILITY TO GRADUATE OF ANY
ABILITY OF MY CLASSMATES AND
MICHAEL COURT MATES AND ALSO THE
STUDENTS THEY TEACH.
I ALSO NEED TO AND IN I
REPRESENTING THE U. EIGHT U. A.
W. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ON
AND NINETEEN THOUSAND UNION
MEMBERS THAT WE REPRESENT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
HI -- MY NAME IS WILL GET THE
MARTINEZ WE ARE HEALTH PROMOTERS
FORTY AGENCY PARTNER FOR HEY
WHAT PROMISE HE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WE ARE AND AN EXAMPLE DAY OF
GOING OVER AT THE BRISTOL SO HEY
WHAT PROBLEM THEY WILL HOOK AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT OUR
VOLUNTEERS ARE EMPOWER AXES
RESOURCES.
COMMON DAM AND THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS -- WHICH HAS SAID
DOMINO EFFECT IT'S FAMILY EACH
INDIVIDUAL AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
IS TRIAL HAS THE POSSIBILITY OF
RECEIVING THE HOW THE WARRANTY
IS THEIR SCHOOL SUCCESS.
SO THAT WAIT WE ARE HERE TO
FULLY SUPPORT THE ITEM ONE W..
WHO ARE FINDING THE PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU LADIES
NEXT.
HI TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES WERE IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE
C. ONE D..
AND ONE H. THERE ARE OTHERS TO
SPEAK ABOUT SEE IN DIESEL JUST
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON ONE H. --
pTHIS UNIVERSAL BREAKFAST IS
PROVEN TO WORK IT REDUCES EXT
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
INCREASES ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
AND IT GIVES KIDS FRESH FOOD ON
THIS IS SOMETHING CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO DO BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
CUT OFF. FOR FREE MEALS THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND FOR A FAMILY OF
FOUR THAT IS NOT ENOUGH TO GET
BY -- THIS SUPPORTS LC FF AND
SUPPORTS ALL CAPITALS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR COMING JOIN THE
SYSTEM.
HI MY NAME IS MONIQUE THEY GUY I
AM RECORDED WITH THE CENTER
SECOND CHINESE COMMITTEE SERVICE
CENTER WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EAST THIS FUNDING.
THE ONE POINT A HUNDRED TWELVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION FOR
INCREASED I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT YES WE ARE KEEPING
CHILDREN SAFE A SHORT STORY.
WE ARE ALL MANDATED REPORTERS
AND THREE THAT WE ARE GETTING
TRUST OF THE CHILDREN THE
CHILDREN ARE REPORTING TO US
THESE TYPES OF ABUSE THAT ARE
HAPPENING AT HOME AND ONE STORY
I HAVE WERE IS WHERE I'VE BEEN
ABLE.
TO ACCOMPLISH A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSFER OF HOUSEHOLD ON CAMPUS
WITH SUPPORTER OF CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND THAT THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SO.
I CAN IMAGINE NINETY ONE
THOUSAND CHILDREN LOSING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPORT THIS TYPE
OF ABUSE AND TO HAVE TRUSTED
ADULTS THAT WILL BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM.
I'M SORRY NO THAT WAS LONG AND
FIFTEEN SECONDS BUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR COMING. TO THE
GOOD JOB YES MA'AM HI MY NAME IS
OTHER DAYS ARE ABI I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
THAT UC BERKELEY AND I'M HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON ITEM TO
USED.
SUPPORT.
HIGH ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR CURRENTLY AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS THANK YOU
THANKS FOR JOINING US JUST MA'AM
HI MY NAME IS COURTNEY KERR
LAWYER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SCIENTIFIC
ADVENTURES FOR GIRLS.
AND I'M HERE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
OF ONE G. FOR THE A. S. E. S.
AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING -- THIS IS
A WE ARE IN OAKLAND AND WE ARE
REACHING GIRLS -- IN OAKLAND
FROM LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS.
GETTING THEM ENGAGE IN EXCITED
ABOUT SCIENCE AND WE NEED AFTER
SCHOOL FUNDING TO DO THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BALLER DINERO
WITH EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ONE SEE
EARLY CHILDHOOD NUTRITION TO
RESTORE THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
TALENT AND HEALTH FOOD PROGRAM
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ONE G. AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION.
AN ASUS PROGRAM THANK YOU THANKS
FOR JOINING US JUST SIR HI
CHARLIE FUSSY OF IT'S AN WAS A
STATE UNIVERSITY ONE OF THANK
SENATOR BELL AND ASSEMBLYMAN
CHOLERA.
PUTTING OUT OF THE ALQUIST
BUILDING -- AND THE PARTNERSHIP
THERE IT'S AN EIGHT ABILITY FOR
US TO USE FACULTY STAFF AND
GRADUATE STUDENT HOUSING IN AN
OLD STATE BUILDING I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES TEXT.
BELOW CHAIRMAN ROTH CENTER LABOR
I'M JULIE FRY PRESIDENT CEO
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM TWO AM -- I DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN GRANTEES WERE
PROUD TO BE A LEARNING
ORGANIZATION.
MY NAME IS MOLLY MCCARTHY I
REPRESENT THE HUMANITIES
INSTITUTE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS AND I I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST
FOR CALIFORNIA AMENITIES WE
REALLY COULDN'T DO.
THE WORK THAT WE DO AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
WITHOUT THE PARTNERSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES THEY'RE
WONDERFUL PARTNER FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND FACULTY AND HELP
THEM CONNECT TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND OUR COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT.
HI DEAR FROM RIVERSIDE ART
MUSEUM HELLO -- WE SUPPORT THIS
I TOO AM AT CAL.
CALIFORNIA AMENITIES FUNDING HAS
MADE POSSIBLE INTO THE WILD BLUE
YONDER EXHIBITION THAT WE SHARE
THE STORIES OF FAMILIES AND
THEIR VETERANS FOR MARCH
AIRFIELD BASE -- IT'S A GREAT
GREAT ORGANIZATION AND HELPS US
TELL STORIES EDUCATE OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES MA'AM.
I'M TRACY RANDOLPH FROM THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY LIBRARY SYSTEM
AS A MANAGER IN THE GROUP OF
VALLEY AREA -- WE RECEIVED
FUNDING FROM CALIFORNIA
AMENITIES FOR LIBRARY INNOVATION
GRANT -- WE HAVE A COOKBOOK
WHICH REALLY PULLED TOGETHER OUR
CULTURAL PROGRAMMING FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF THE VALLEY AND WE
SUPPORT TO M. THANK YOU THANKS
FOR JOINING US JUST SIR.
DETERMINEJEFF FROST REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
ONE AM THE MODEL SCHOOL LIBRARY
STANDARDS.
IN ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF INDICATION
WE SUPPORT THE CARS NO PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES MA'AM.
MISTER CHAIR SENATOR LABOR WE
ALSO WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
MODEL SCHOOL LIBRARIES ONE AM
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION WE'RE HERE
TO SUPPORT A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION FOR AN OFFICE.
OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH WITHIN
THE C. D. E. CALIFORNIA IS ONLY
ONE OF TWO STATES THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND C.
D. E. WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND THE CAUCUS.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE ABOUT
SCHOOL HELP PARTICULARLY THE
ACCESS TO PROP SIXTY THREE
POINTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR COMING.
I AM IN.
ON STRONG SUPPORT OF THE OFFICES
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ARE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO REALIZE
THE LEVEL HIGH LEVEL OF HEALTH
SERVICES IN THAT ARE BEING
DELIVERED IN THE SCHOOL.
WITH THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE
OUT TO ALL MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN SCHOOLS CONSTRUCTED
CLAIM ELLIE A AND MARK.
REIMBURSEMENT WE THINK THIS
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH THE OFFICE
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THERE WILL
BE A COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CD AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT.
OF COURSE SERVICE THANKS FOR
JOINING US YES SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICHARD REID
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF MISSION
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAN
FRANCISCO REPRESENTING THE FIVE
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE
TO SUPPORT -- PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE BUDGET --
THESE HAVE BEEN VERY
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
LOCATED IN AND EIGHT WE THINK
THAT BY EXPANDING THAT THE
NUMBER TO TWENTY HE WOULD BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE STATE.
WE GET WE SEE A SIX DOLLAR TURN
ON EVERYONE DOLLAR INVESTMENT
AND I'LL LEAVE THAT LITERATURE
WITH YOU I THANK LEGISLATURE OF
COMING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANY
OTHER MINGUS AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH THERAPIST WORKING WITH
MISSION PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND I FEEL THAT ENSURING THAT
THIS OF FUNDING CONTINUES THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE CREATE SAFE
SPACES FOR CHILDREN AND TEACHERS
AND CLASSROOM SETTINGS.
I'D ASK YOU TO DO ME TO SEE IF
YOU CAN IF IT'S THE SAME ISSUE.
ME TOO SIR I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF MR PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD
PERFECT WILL GO TO WORK
[inaudible]
SAME HERE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING SAME HERE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING GREAT JOB
BY THE WAY.
YES SIR YOU'RE UP YES I AM A
ALSO SUPPORT THEY WERE PROMISE I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
JUST ABOUT THE GENERATIONAL
MINUTE THAT YOU GUYS DON'T CARE
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN AND THAT
MEANS A LOT TO US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GLORIOUS RESERVES SECULAR
DIRECTOR IN THE TO LIVE IS TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ME TOO PERFECT THANK YOU SIR YES.
YES SIR.
JACK ALONG WITH THE GRACE
INSTITUTE AND THEN HAVE ALREADY
IN CALIFORNIA AT CAMPAIGN ME TOO
BUT I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
RAPPER WE HOUSING. FOR THAT WILL
PLUS WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
THANK YOU THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN CENTER
LABOR GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WESLEY SAY REPRESENTING JOHN BUT
NEXT FEW CONSTRUCTS PORT OF ITEM
TO SEE -- WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
SEE THE INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR
THE CSU WHEN YOU SEE SYSTEMS TO
ADDRESS TO HOMELESSNESS THE
REFEREE HOUSING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYBE -- BUDGET
REVISION COVER - ONE OF FIVE
STUDENTS A COMMUNITY COLLEGES OF
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ALSO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR COMMUNICABLE
JUST THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
VERY MUCH YES.
CENTER OFF ME TOO OKAY GOOD.
HELPING THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DON BLACK CHORUS AND
HONEST IN SUCCESS SPECIALIST UP
YOU COLLEGE I'M HERE TODAY AS
PART OF THE TWENTY MILLION
BUDGET TWENTY MILLION BUDGET
REQUEST. FOR TO SEE RAPID RE
HOUSING -- ONLY STUDENTS NEED TO
HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND THEIR
COLLEGE EXPERIENCES AND FUTURE
CAREERS TO DO THIS THEY NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT FIT THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT.
I URGE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT RAPID RE HOUSING.
IT WILL MEAN THE WORLD TO THOSE
HOMELESS STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO SUCCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
FOR YES SIR.
WHO ARE ONCE?
JUMP IN MAY TWO OF THEM I IN.
I WAS A COMMITTEE COLLEGE
HOMELESS STUDENT -- THE MOST
TERRIFYING EXPERIENCE MY WIFE
AND I STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN A
VERY HIGH GPA.
THANKS TO THE GREAT PEOPLE OF MY
SCHOOL AND THE HELP OF THE
COMMUNITY PLEASE CONSIDER THIS
BILL.
WILL HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE TRYING
TO CRAWL OUT OF THE ASHES AND
EARN A FUTURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SECOND SALAS ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WITH A ME TOO ON THE TO
SEE -- THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
I'M CRISTINA PARKER WITH ON
CALIFORNIA CONNECTION AND ME TOO
ON TO SEE OF A RAPIDLY HOUSING
WE GET IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS YOUR QUICKTIME CARLOS
CRUZ APPEAR FROM THE BAY AREA
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND WE ARE
SUPPORT OF ACES GRANT.
THANK YOU NEXT ALISON SANTOS --
WORK FEBRUARY COMMUNITY
RESOURCES ALSO WITH ACES --
AFTER SCHOOL PLAYS A VITAL PART
IN NOT ONLY THAT MANY ASPECTS OF
OUR CHILD DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO
THE INCREASE IN LIKE. FOR OUR
CULTURE TOWARDS EDUCATION AND
FAMILY INFLUENCES SO WHERE IN
SUPPORT FOR THANKS FOR JOINING
US NEXT.
MY NAME IS A LETTER HERNANDEZ
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN THE BAY AREA
THROUGH BEARD TO ME RESOURCES.
I WANT TO SHARE BRIEFLY MY STORY
AND THEN POINTED TO FIND
ESPECIALLY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY TO LOW INCOME
COMMITTEE IS A COLOR LIKE MINE
AND WEALTHY MARIN COUNTY I WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN CANAL AND HER
PHONE AND MY PARENTS ARE MIXING
GUATEMALAN IMMIGRANTS OF THE
WEST WITH.%
NO KNOWLEDGE OF THE AMERICAN
EDUCATION SYSTEM I WAS PART OF
THE ACES PROGRAM GROWING UP AND
HELP ME TO BECOME ON PAR WITH MY
PEERS WITH EDUCATED PARENTS.
WHAT THE HELP OF MY AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WITH THEIR TUTORS I CAN
SAY RECEIVED A FOUR POINT THREE
HIGH SCHOOL GPA AND THE FIRST
PERSON TO GRADUATE FOR MY FAMILY
FROM UC SANTA CRUZ DURING?
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH HONORS AND
SOCIOLOGY IN EDUCATION NOW IT'S
LIKE COORDINATOR FOR THE
ELEMENTARY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
IN MARIN GIVING BACK TO MY OWN
COMMUNITY THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
KEEP IT UP YES MA'AM THANK YOUNG
MONEY IN A LOW BY SOME HERE TO
REQUEST DAY INCREASING FUNDING
FOR ASUS AND THANK YOU WITHIN
OUR LABOR FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT
THROUGH THE YEARS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US SIR.
I'M ALSO HERE FOR THE INCREASE
IN -- ASUS THOUGH -- FOR THE
INCREASE ON IT HELPS KEEP YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PASSIONATE
AND YOU DEVELOPMENT TO KEEP --
GETTING THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND ALSO GIVEN BACK
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES AND ALSO --
BEING ABLE TO OF SUPPORT MORE
STUDENTS IN OUR PROGRAMS WITH
THAT WITH -- INCREASE THANK YOU
MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS I I
WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
AGE CONSORTIUM ALSO ME TO WITH
THE INCREASED ASUS FUNDING THANK
YOU.
YES MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSALYN SALAS I
AM A FAMILY CENTER COORDINATOR
AT BAY AREA COMMUNITY RESOURCES
AND I AM -- ASKING YOU AGAIN --
TO RAISE THE FUNDS FOR ASUS
THANK YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US
JUST SERVE MAP AND SEE A TA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS YOU TAKE
OVERSIGHT POSITIONS PRESENTED AN
ISSUE SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION I ALSO HAVE TO RESPECT
PALACE HERE WITH ME WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE AND THE CARS
THE PROPOSAL ALL OF THE WORK
THAT THE STATE IS DOING TO
OVERHAUL CHARTER SCHOOL
OVERSIGHT.
WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL IF WE DO
NOT RESOURCE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHO ARE AT GROUND -- ZERO WITH
REGARD TO CHARTER SCHOOL
OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US YES
THANK YOU MY NAME IS THERESA
COUPLE LESSON ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF KERR'S NET.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT --
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A SUCCESSFUL
MODEL FOR BUILDING -- CHARTER
SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THESE PAST FEW
YEARS -- WITHOUT THIS CONTINUED
FUNDING WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICE TO DO THE SAME.
AND THEN FINALLY I JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE SENT IN A
BUDGET LETTER.
ON THAT HAS THE SUPPORT OF A LOT
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION CALLASPO ACCESS.
AND C-SPAN CCP THANKS FOR
JOINING US JUST NEXT.
HI JAN DIETRICH ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR TO YOUTH AND THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL ADVOCACY
ALLIANCE.
TODAY'S BUDGET PROPOSAL LEAVES A
HOLE FOR THE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THAT RELY ON ASUS PROGRAMS EVERY
SINGLE DAY MOST OF THESE ARE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
AND WE'VE HEARD THAT THESE
PROGRAMS WILL CLOSE UNLESS
THERE'S FUNDING THIS YEAR AS AN
EXAMPLE IN BUTTE COUNTY THEY
SERVE.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED RURAL AND
ISOLATED.
LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
IF THEY DON'T RECEIVE FINDING-THEY WILL CLOSE THEIR TWENTY
FOUR PROGRAMS.
THE SUPPORT ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE POINT EIGHT MILLION THANK
YOU.
NEXT.
HI HEATHER WILLIAMS AT THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL NETWORK
I'D LIKE TO DATE OF JAN AND THE
SUPPORT FOR ASUS FUNDING THE
VERY MUCH SEX THE SERVER.
ADAM SIDING WITH THE THING
TOGETHER WHICH PROVIDES AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS TO ABOUT 10% OF
THE STUDENTS THE FOUR THOUSAND
KIDS FOR CALIFORNIA.
ALSO ME TO THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION IT'S REALLY IT'S AN
EQUITY THING -- WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT HIGH GOOD HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION -- AFTER SCHOOL
CHILDCARE IS AVAILABLE ON THE
YOU KNOW IN IN EVERYWHERE AND SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT -- PART OF
THE BUDGET THAT IS TO BE BROUGHT
IN THANKS FOR JOINING US YES
MA'AM.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON JACQUELYN THE
OUTER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FREEH
MAX FOR SPONSORS CA C. F. P.
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME PROVIDERS
WE HAVE NINE HUNDRED PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT.
EQUATES TO ELEVEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN THE PARTICIPATE ON CA
C. F. P. WE WOULD.
STRONGLY.
SUGGEST THAT YOU SUPPORT BOTH
ONE C. N. ONE H. -- CALIFORNIA
ALREADY SUPPORTS AT THE SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN AND THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF THEIR MEALS AND
WE ASK THAT YOU DO THE SAME FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YES MA'AM HI MELISSA CANNOT
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
PROVIDING THE ME TOO ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE FOOD
PROGRAM MOUNTIE ONE CONTINUING
DEVELOPMENT IN FOR ITEM ONE C..
HELP INCREASE ACCESS TO MEALS
FOR TYPE CHILDREN IN CHILDCARE
THANK YOU THE SHOP THANKS FOR
JOINING US YES SIR IS OPEN TO ON
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AND I JOIN
MY COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT OF THE
CHILD NUTRITION BUDGET REQUEST.
PERFECT THANK YOU.
JAKE PRIMER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY --
AND EDUCATION TRUST WEST WHEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE Q.
THE CALL TRADE INS BLOCK GRANT
REQUEST AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION IN OVER
TWENTY FIVE PARTNERS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE LEGAL
SERVICES INVESTMENT THAT YOU HAD
A PANEL TO DISCUSS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF TO SEE
SACRAMENTO'S SUPPORT OF ONE W.
THE HUNDRED MILLION FOR PROSTATE
BUT THANK YOU NEXT I A HANNAH
BRAG START WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION -- PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB -- FIVE SIX EIGHT
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM TO
SEE RAPID RE HOUSING THANK YOU
THANK YOU THINK HEARING AS A
SERVER.
ERNIE SO THE FOUR SCITECH WERE
DROPOUT RECOVERY HIGH SCHOOL
HERE IN SUPPORT OF A ONE THE
ITEM ONE F..
WE DO NOT USE THE PROP THIRTY
NINE OF RIGHTS INSTEAD WE RELY
ON SEVEN FORTY REIMBURSEMENT TO
LOCATE NEAR OUR DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT.
KEVIN FROM HALF THE COUNTY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FLEXIBLE
EDUCATORS AND TRANSPORT OF ITEM
OF ONE G. THANK YOUTHANK YOU
NEXT YES MA'AM PORTABLE TO SKI
WITH THE YMCA OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY REPRESENTING TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND YOUTH IN THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SCHOOLS.
IN AN ASUS INCREASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU YES SIR JOHN WINGER ON
WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM ONE F. WHICH WOULD.
FULLY FUND A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM AND IT'S STOP CUTS TO
OUR SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK YOU
YES SIR.
DR DANIEL A MEAT IS SCHOOL BOARD
PRESIDENT OF FALL WITH CHARTER
SCHOOL IN STOCKTON CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS WE HAVE A 90%
FREE FOOD LUNCH POPULATION.
THE MAJORITY BLACK AND LATINO
POPULATION AND THE WE NEED TO
FACILITIES SUPPORT THANK YOU
JOINING US YES SIR YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SERAPHINA ROSE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING PARAGON CLICK A
CATEGORY SMALL LITTLE CHARTER
SCHOOL LOCATED UP IN THE MERS EL
áREA.
HI -- FREEDOM REDUCE POPULATION
AND WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE SB
SEVEN FORTY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIR.
AFTERNOON ERIC TURNER HERE WITH
LA'S BEST AFTER SCHOOL
ENRICHMENT PROGRAM UNLESS
ANGELES SUPPORTING ONE G. --
SUPPORT FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE WE
SERVE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED
NEIGHBORHOODS IN LOS ANGELES.
AND WE ARE ABSOLUTELY AT RISK OF
CLOSING WE HAVE MAXIMIZE ALL
OTHER FUND RAISING EFFORTS AND
WE I'M A REALLY RELY ON THE
STATE FUND SO PLEASE SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION SAFETY PROGRAMS THANK
YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YES SIR GOOD AFTERNOON CAME TO
MEET SHE WITH TECHNET AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE CLASSES ARE
INTEGRAL TO THE FUTURE WORKFORCE
THIS STATE AND WE SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION A SAYS FUNDING INCREASE
THANK YOU NEXT.
HELLO LINDA APPEARS PRINCIPLE
DIRECTOR OF CHAMPS CHARTER
SCHOOL OF THE ARTS IN VAN NUYS
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
ITEM ONE HALF.
INCREASE FUNDING FOR SB SEVEN
FORTY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
BARBARA HALE SYCAMORE ACADEMY
AND WILL TO MARIN OPENING IN
CHINO I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ONE
AT THANK YOU FOR JOINING US YES
MA'AM.
DR VALERIE BAD FROM A
CONSERVATORY VOCAL AND
INSTRUMENTAL ARTS CHARTER SCHOOL
IN OAKLAND AND I AM HERE BECAUSE
EQUITY WAS POSTED BROUGHT TO
FACILITIES TO PROPOSITION THIRTY
NINE IT HAS NOT BROUGHT IT BUT
SEVEN FORTY DOES BRING SOME
EQUITY IN TERMS OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WHICH ARE CHARTER AND
PUBLIC.
THANK YOU NEXT CAN'T ONE YOUNG
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ALLIANCE OF YMCAS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB IN SUPPORT OF ONE G..
AND ON BEHALF OF THE ONE FOR
COLLEGE PREP ACADEMIES IN
SUPPORT OF ONE F. AND I'M AFTER
THE BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN THE CINEMA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN SUPPORT
OF AN ITEM WHEN YOU.
GREAT GREAT JOB BY THE WAY YES
SIR NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MATT
SMITH I AM THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
A GROUP OF WONDERFUL CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN BELAY -- CALLED
GRIFFIN CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ONE ENOUGH
WHICH IS THE ADDITIONAL
APPORTIONMENT.
THROUGH SB SEVEN FORTY WE REALLY
NEED THAT MONEY ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS REALLY NEED THAT MONEY
THANK YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US
YES SIR.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON ANTHONY
WILSON EPRESENTING K<c.cyan> BAY</c>
AREA SCHOOLS WE HAVE -- FIFTEEN
SCHOOL SIX THOUSAND FAMILIES --
ABOUT ABOUT THAT OF OUR SCHOOLS
RECEIVE SB -- SEVEN FORTY FUNDS
ARE ASKING THAT YOU SUPPORT ONE
HALF -- IT WILL BE A ONE MILLION
DOLLAR IMPACT ON OUR SCHOOLS
THANK YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US
JUST SERVE.
GREG LACKEY FROM VALLEY LIFE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND BUY SELL YOU
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
THE CITY IS FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH.
IF THEY LOSE A REIMBURSEMENT FOR
RENTAL THE PROGRAM WILL BE
DAMAGE THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANKS
FOR JOINING US.
YES MA'AM HI THERE SUSANHOWARD
MANAGER OF REAL ESTATE OUT A
SPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN OAKLAND
I WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY NINE RECEIVE
SB.
SEVEN FORTY AND WE HUMBLY
REQUEST THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
SB SEVEN FORTY THANK YOU THANKS
FOR JOINING US YES SIR HI MY
NAME IS THAT WERE LANA BUT SHE
FINANCIAL OFFICER VOICES
CODDLING WHICH ACADEMIES.
WE HAVE FOUR SCHOOLS THREE IN
SAN JOSE -- AND ONE IN EAST BAY
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE
F. IT'S A IT'S A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR BUDGET
OTHERWISE -- PROGRAM WILL BE
THAT WILL TAKE SOME HEADS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US JUST
SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME JASON
CHAN ON THE GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS.
I'M ALSO A HIGH SCHOOL SOPHOMORE
A LITTLE HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO -- I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF ITEM ONE I'D WHICH IS FUNDING.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
SOON COUNCILS THIS IS A SMALL
BUT EXTREMELY UNIQUE INVESTMENT
DIRECTLY IN STUDENT LEADERS SUCH
AS MYSELF -- AND THE WORK THAT
WE DO ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
TRADITIONALLY UNDER REPRESENTED --
MY ROLE FOR COST BECAUSE ALLOWED
ME TO DIVE DEEPLY INTO MY
PASSION FOR GOVERNMENT AS
UNDOUBTEDLY CHANGED MY LIFE AND
IT HAS SHE LIVES OF MANY OTHER
STUDENTS AS WELL -- WITHOUT I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BUTTERFLY THANKS FOR JOINING US
SIR THANK YOU COME BACK IS SIR
LOVES CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE WITH
ERIN REGION SOCIUS IN SUPPORT OF
TWO D..
THIS IS THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IT WAS IN THE LABOR BILL LAST
YEAR IN THE GOVERNOR RECOMMENDED
WE DO IT THROUGH THE BUDGET.
WE ALLUDED TO IT IN THE HEARING
FOR TOM PORTER -- FOR HELLFIRE
DIRECTOR IN ITS STUDIES THE
IMPACTS UPON WILDLAND FIRE THANK
YOU SURVEYS YOU DOING THIS YES
MA'AM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
A CENTER LEYVA CHRISTY ABOUT MOM
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM TWO D..
AS PROUD STATE ORGANIZATION FOR
LOCAL TWENTY ONE BUT ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS TO RESPOND TO WILDFIES.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THAT ITEM
THANK YOU YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- LEAGUE BYNUM
UW ASK ME THIRTY NINE THIRTY ON
BEHALF OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND THIRTY NINE COUNTY START
STATE.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF ONE P. AND
REGARDS TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FOR TALK I WRITERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU YES NEXT GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
UNDER ITEM ONE SEE -- THE
LESSONS COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SPEAKING FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL NUTRITION
ONE AS TECHNICAL ASSISTANT PILOT
PROGRAMS.
THAT PROVIDE QUALIFY INJURES AND
PROFESSIONALS WILL PROVIDE
DIRECT SUPPORT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TRANSPARENT OCCASION
AND EVIDENCE BASED RESOURCES
AFFAIRS ELEAZAR.
AND SCHOOLS IN THE AREA OF
NUTRITION EDUCATION AND ONE IS
POLICY EXPANSION IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS ITEM IS NEEDED TO PROVIDE
CONSISTENT STABLE FUNDING FOR
THIS CRITICAL PROGRAMS UNDER
ITEM ONE AND WE SUPPORT A TEAM
IN MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING -- FOR
CARS NOT RECOGNIZING THE FEDERAL
GRANT HAS ENDED AS A REGIONAL
LEAD LIKE -- KNOWS FUNDING WILL
STRENGTHEN SCHOOL DISTRICT
OVERSIGHT -- OF OF TIMES WHEN
STATE.
UNDER ITEM ONE A WE SUPPORT
CENTER RUBIO PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA ENGLISH
ON A ROAD MAP INITIATIVE.
THIS WILL PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
IMPLEMENTING THE ROADMAP WHICH
MAY -- ME BARRIERS THERE'S A
LACK OF A LOCAL RESOURCES.
AND FINALLY UNDER ITEM ONE L.
LEGO CONTINUES FOR THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR QUEST FOR THE
LOWEST PERFORMING STUDENTS FOR
THREE YEARS.
WE KNOW THE PURPOSE OF THE LC OF
OFFICE -- TELESERYE STUDENTS --
WHO ARE FUN BEHIND THIS BILL
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP REGIONAL
STUDENTS THANK YOU?
SO WE HAVE.
ABOUT NINETEEN TO TWENTY MINUTES
LEFT AND I DON'T KNOW WHO'S
OUTSIDE THE DOOR.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU
WOULD JUST YOUR COMMENTS
ACCORDINGLY OR SOMEBODY'S GOING
TO GET CUT OFF SO.
MA'AM PLEASE BE BRIEF IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF YOU WOULD SIMPLY
INDICATE THE LINE ITEMS THAT YOU
SUPPORT THAT WOULD.
SEE FORTUNATELY AT AND MIGHT
MAKE COMMON ISN'T ABOUT A LINE
ITEM ALL OF THE DO MY BEST BE
VERY BRIEF.
IT'S ABOUT THE LETTER I JUST --
SUBMITTED TO YOU -- AT MY NAME
IS RIGHT ON THE STAR ON THE HAVE
A PUBLIC ADVOCATES THE EDUCATION
TRUST WES.
AT VOICE TEACH PLUS AND CHILDREN
NOW WE'RE ASKING FOR TWO FULL
TIME STAFF OF THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. TO
ANALYZE AND PUBLISHED NEARLY
AVAILABLE DATA PURSUANT TO AN
EMMA YOU LAST YEAR'S BUDGET TO
IDENTIFY BRIGHT SPOTS IN AREAS
OF IMPROVEMENT IN TEACHER
PREPARATION RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION.
A CDC HAS PERFORMED A SAMPLE
ANALYSIS OF THIS DATA BUT
CURRENTLY LACKS THE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE IT TO THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL.
JUST LAST YEAR UNTIL JUST LAST
YEAR CD EASE CREDENTIALING DATE
CITIES EMPLOYMENT AGENCY DISEASE
CREDENTIALING DATA WERE SILO TO
WE WERE UNABLE TO ANSWER BASIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT TEACHER
PREPARATION MOVEMENT AND
RETENTION PARTICULARLY IN
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS SERVING OUR
HIGHEST NEEDS STUDENTS -- THIS
DATA COULD PUSH WAS ON WAS
MATCHED PURSUANT TO ****
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BUT
SHOULD NOT BE LIMITEDTO THAT
PURPOSE STATE AND LOCALS AND
LEANED NEED THIS INFORMATION TO
INFORM THEIR TEACHER QUALITY AND
SUPPORT AND SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
HI I'M KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA ALSO NOT
HERE ON A LINE ITEM -- BUT I
WILL BE BRIEF -- I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE OF
A BUDGET REQUEST -- ON THE ISSUE
OF MENTAL HEALTH STAFFING IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS -- WE ARE
ASKING FOR FUNDING OF FOR A
GRANT PROGRAM TO SEARCH FOR MORE --
SCHOOL COUNSELORS PSYCHOLOGISTS
SOCIAL WORKERS AND NURSES TO
SERVE IN CALIFORNIA'S MOST
UNDERSERVED SCHOOLS.
AND FOR MONEY FOR TRAINING FOR
THE STAFF MEMBERS IN RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRACTICES -- THE
COMMITTEE HEARD THIS MORNING
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF FOR A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND WE FEEL LIKE THIS GRANT
PROGRAM WOULD BE A FIRST STEP
TOWARDS -- SETTING AN EXAMPLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AS TO
WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH HIM FROM
THE ROOM.
YES MA'AM HI PRISCILLA KIDDOS ON
BEHALF OF A LAKE CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT OF ON ONE G.
THE WONDER.
TWELVE POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING PROP -- NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING TOWARDS ACES AND THE
HUNDRED MILLION ARE FOR CONTINUE
HEALTHCARE COMES NEIGHBORHOOD
PROGRAM UNDER ONE W..
THANK YOU THANKS FOR BEING BRIEF
YES MA'AM -- WHEELCHAIR AND
MEMBER OF SENATOR LIVE AT I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER
ONE Q. THAT'S THE COLLEGE
READINESS BLOCK GRANT MY NAME IS
LISA CHIU.
FROM ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA NO ONE IS
SURE WITH YOU THAT THIS BLOCK
GRANT HAS HELPED TO DIGITIZE
TRANSCRIPTS IN OUR MOST RURAL
COUNTIES WHILE ALSO COVERING THE
COST OF ALL AP EXAMS FOR
STUDENTS IN AP CLASSES.
IN SCHOOL DISTRICT SUCH AS TAX
CITY UNIFIED -- IN ADDITION TO
THAT THE BLOCK GRANT ALLOWS FOR
OUR NEEDIEST HIGH SCHOOLS OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND IN THE STATE.
HUGH ISSUE ARE ADMINISTERED THE
PSA TEACH ALL KIDS GRADE EIGHT
THROUGH TEN AND THE S. E. T. FOR
KIDS IN.
GRADE ELEVEN THAT QUALIFY OUR
FOSTER USE LOW INCOME IN ENGLISH
LEARNER CHILDREN NEED AN
INVESTMENT THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN
AND OUR COALITION THE COLLEGE
FOR ALL COALITION WOULD BE HAPPY
TO MEET WITH YOUR OFFICE TIãU.
ON DISCUSS THIS AS A BUDGET ITEM
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
ADVOCACY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GABRIEL GARCIA WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER ALSO WITH THE COLLEGE FOR
OUR COLLISION -- ADVOCATING FOR
ITEM ONE Q. -- AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SHARED THIS LINE
ITEM IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
FOR DIE VOTING DEVOTING
RESOURCES TO USE STUDENTS WHO
NEED IT MOST THESE ARE STUDENTS
LCF OF SCHOOLS MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARING THEM TO BE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READY.
AND ALSO PREPARING THAT THE UC
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
WANT THAT ONCE THEY GET ON
CAMPUS THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
YES I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NINE AS ELL FOR LEGAL SERVICES
THROUGH THE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER AT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT THE SPENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERRY MEMBERS
AND RAY RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
WINK -- ONE CALIFORNIA COALITION
THE COALITION IS A GROUP OF
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS THAT CAME
TOGETHER IN -- TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO ADVOCATE FOR THE CREATION OF
THE ONE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S.
ALLOCATION FOR A COMBINED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TOWARDS
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES AND
SEVENTEEN MILLION OF THAT IS FOR
THE C. S. USING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES AND
COUNSELING SERVICES TO STUDENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU YES NEXT.
IN THE GARAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN JUST IN SUPPORT OF
ONE GM ONE W. THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
YES MA'AM CAN REALLY RESONATE
WITH SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION YOU'VE HEARD
ME BEFORE SO ALL TO SAY THE ITEM
NUMBER NOW THAT I HAVE ONE ONE
P. FOR CHILDCARE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS S. YEAH YOU
PRIORITY AS IS. TO P. WHICH
ADDRESSES -- INVERSION FOR
CLASSIFIED THE CSU AND TO TEA
THE CFA ASKED TO GET FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH WERE ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF ONE SEE WHICH IS
THE TROUT CONTRITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT IS FROM.
AFTERNOON THE AYE GUY GOES WITH
THE UC SOON ASSOCIATION -- AS
FAR SHARE THE THAT WE'RE EXCITED
TO SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
ATTENTIVENESS TO OUR BASIC NEEDS --
SERVICES INCLUDING OUR PROPERTY
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS -- AS
WELL OF THE IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES THAT WAS -- INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET THIS MORNING.
HOWEVER WE STILL NEED THE
STATE'S SUPPORT AND MEETING SOME
OF THE NEEDS THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET.
INCLUDING AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS -- AS WELL
AS FUNDING FOR AN ROOM EXPANSION
AND TUITION SUPPORT IN ORDER TO
ENSURE A TUITION FREEZE.
IN THE NEXT YEARS REGION'S VOTE
COMING THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU
THANKS FOR JOINING US YES SIR.
A THIS PARTIAL WITH THE SEASON
ASSOCIATION JUDGES RINGS ORDER
ONE Q. -- THE CARD FOR THE
BECAUSE FILE COLLISIONS ASK FOR
TWENTY TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS --
THAT TWENTY WILL GO TO WAS COULD
YOU TWELVE TWENTY WAS GOING
TOWARDS -- HIGHER ED AND YOU SEE
ALSO ONE OUT OF ONE READ THERE
ARE SPEAK ON IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ON BEHALF OF OUR FRIENDS AT
EDUCATION TRESPASS WILL BE HERE
TODAY BUT WE BOTH OF OURS IS OUR
SUPPORT OF THIS.
APPRECIATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT YES MA'AM.
JENNIFER ROW WELL ON BEHALF OF
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL IN SOUTH LA.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF TO BE THE
CHARLES DREW UNIVERSITY FUNDING
GOT IT THANK YOU THANKS FOR
COMING YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE CAN DO
QUESTIONS IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ITEM WHEN SEE THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD NUTRITION THAT
WILL ALLOW OUR CHILDREN.
OUR CHILD CARE AND EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMS PROVIDE MEALS
AND SOME OF OUR TO SOME OF OUR
MOST FRAGILE IMPOVERISHED
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
LIVING FAMILIES AND CHILDREN UP
FROM POVERTY IN GIVING CHILDREN
THE TOOLS NEEDED TO THRIVE AND
LEARN BECAUSE OF NURTURING
CHILDHOOD.
CHILD CARE AND NUTRITIOUS MEALS
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
JUST SIR.
I GET AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TEAR WITH FIGHT
CRIME INVEST IN KIDS IN MISSION
READINESS AND I'M HERE N
SUPPORT OF ONE G. THE AFTER
SCHOOL.
OF EDUCATION SAFETY PROGRAM SO
WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
EFFORTS ON EARLY CHILDHOOD --
CARE AND AND PRE K.
UNFORTUNATELY SEEN IS NOT MADE
AFTER SCHOOL PRIORITIES SO WE'RE
IN CRISIS MODE IN MANY THE
LEGISLATURE'S STEP UP THIS YEAR
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T GET THIS
MONEY.
IS A VERY STRONG LIKELIHOOD THAT
A QUARTER THESE PROGRAMS TO
CLOSE NINETY ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS COULD BE.
LEFT OUT ON THE STREETS.
ROGER SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS
FOR COMING YES MA'AM.
HI DIANA DOMINGUEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
AND CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE
G. FOR AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
AND SAFETY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS FOR JOINING US YES SIR.
RESIDENTS ON BEHALF OF THE NO
KID HUNGRY CAMPAIGN AND SPORT
SEVERAL MEASURES FIRST ONE IS
ITEM ONE H. MAGUIRE'S REQUEST
FOR FULL FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
GROWN HEALTHY KIDS PROGRAM AND
ONE C..
TESTY WITH EARLY CHILDHOOD FOOD
PROGRAM BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR
US -- ITEM ONE D. WHICH IS THE
PRACTICE AFTER THE BELL PROGRAM
WHICH IS OUR PRIORITY AND ALSO
ONE OF OUR SPONSORED ASK THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM.
HELLO ON OUR CARE AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS AMY HEINZ SHAKEN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR UP THE CW A LOCAL
NINETY ONE NINETEEN I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON AN ITEM THAT DOES NOT
YET APPEAR IN YOUR BUDGET BUT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CHANGE THAT.
HI I THINK BILLY GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S MAY REVISED THE STATE
BUDGET PROPOSAL STATES
SIGNIFICANT ADJUSTMENTS
RETIREMENT PROGRAM THAT MAY
REVISION INCLUDES ONE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE UC
RETIREMENT PROGRAM.
A DEEP CW A LOCAL NINETY ONE
NINETEEN BUDGET REQUEST IS THAT
THE STATE WOULD PROVIDE A TOTAL
OF ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION JUST ONE YEAR AND
PROPOSITION TWO OR GENERAL FUND
MONEY TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO SPEND DOWN THERE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING.
THE STATE FUNDS THE UC WOULD
AGREE TO WITHDRAW THEIR
BARGAINING DEMAND THAT THE
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES UP THE CW
A LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN AND
ASKED ME LOCAL.
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE BE FORCED
TO ALLOW THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN OPTION FOR OUR
NEW MEMBERS AND AS OF THIS
MOMENT WERE STILL STRIKING ON
MAY SIXTEENTH THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US YES MA'AM.
HI ANA HAS ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA SAVING THE
BEST FOR LAST DOING A FAST -- WE
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM ONE
EVE TO RESTORE AND MODERNIZE THE
HEALTHY START PROGRAM SIXTY
MILLION OVER FOUR YEARS WHEN AS
A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO THE STAFF
FOR HELPING US WITH THE AGENDA
ITEMS.
AND THAT'S ALL.
THANK YOU YES THANK YOU.
UNDER A PAIR WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE WE OCCURS
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
AT